Intro/Outro
Und wir sind immer noch nicht in einem Raum zusammen.
Aber wir hätten eigentlich gekonnt Du hast es ja auch gesagt Komm doch nach Frankfurt und ich habe es nochmal ein bisschen verschoben aber ich verspreche die nächste Ausgabe bin ich da.
Sehr gut es ist alles vorbereitet. Richtig.
Denn das war ja die Idee. Das war ja die Idee dass wir uns gegenübersitzen Das ist ein analoger Podcast wird.
Aber die Idee ist natürlich auch dass wir uns an die Gesetze und politischen Vorgaben halten so weit sie für uns auch Sinn machen.
Natürlich unterliegen wir im normativen Zwang.
Na ja man dürfte schon wieder allerdings bis 29. Juni sind die Kontakt Beschränkung und so weiter pro forma verlängert wurden um letzte Risiken auszugehen um zu umgehen.
Allerdings hat ja Drosten gestern schon darauf hingewiesen dass hier auch eine kleine änderung meinerseits Ich wollte eigentlich groß über Innenräume nochmal sprechen weil sich doch irgendwie herausstellt dass die Aerosolen in der Luft stehen so krass sind plötzlich mein Drosten.
Vielleicht sind es doch diese super Events spezifische soziale Konstellationen die es ermöglichen dass in Innenräumen dann sowas passiert die unter freiem Himmel erst gar nicht möglich werden.
Also ist der Innenraum vielleicht doch nicht so die große Gefahr.
Das heißt. Vielleicht ist das ganz gut wenn die Kinos bald öffnen und auch gar nicht so Problem behaftet.
Ja
genau deswegen wäre nämlich der Innenraum hier so ein wichtiges Thema gewesen weil ein großer Innenraum den man nun nicht einfach nach draußen verlegen kann auch wenn Autokino eine schöne Sache ist ist natürlich der Kinosaal,
auf der anderen Seite ist der Kinosaal finde ich wie das Flugzeug auch schon so ein bisschen drauf vorbereitet da die Belüftung ja in modernen Kinos doch recht gut ist.
Also ich habe noch nie im Kino geschwitzt oder so in letzter Zeit sondern da fühlt man sich noch gut belüftet sich eh nicht so großes Problem aber stellt sich raus.
Man merkt dass du nicht in Programmkinos gehst. Das verrät die Aussage.
Das stimmt das stimmt. Das Ding ist ein bisschen wenn ich ins Kino gehe dann ist der Film immer schon ein paar Wochen alt.
Das hat dann auch ein bisschen Vorbereitungszeit und so weiter gekostet. Und wenn ich dann ins Kino gehe bin ich der einzige dort.
Also ich und meine Frau und ich sitzen vielleicht hinten nochmal drei und vorne nochmal zwei aber ein volles Kino kenne ich sowieso nicht und Programmkinos die sich jetzt so Nischen Säle suchen sowieso nicht. Das ist dann schon der große Kino Palast.
Deswegen hätte ich jetzt Kino sowieso nicht auf dem Schirm so Mégane aber ich sehe natürlich auch die Diskussion um Tenet.
Das ist Christopher Nolans großer Zeitreise Film der nun mit der Pointe beginnt dass wir nicht genau wissen wann er ins Kino kommt.
Und wenn man solche Witze auf Twitter macht heißt es dann schon. War das nicht schon so.
Da wird sozusagen die Meta-Analyse der Zeitreise gleich nochmal eingebaut.
Aber es gibt vielleicht neue Kinosäle Du hast es auch nochmal nochmal informiert.
Der Trailer von Tenet Worte in Fortner hat gezeigt was bedeutet das kannst du dir schon einen Reim darauf machen.
Noch nicht so richtig also es ist ja bei Christopher Nolan eigentlich so,
dass er einer der wenigen ist der noch wirklich ans Kino glaubt und dass er auch mit seinen Filmen immer wieder bewiesen hat dass er auf Material drehen will er ist eigentlich ein bisschen wie Tarantino.
Und er ist auch der letzte große Hollywood Autorenfilmer wird häufig gesagt oder der Autorenfilmer der das größte Budget auch bekommt.
Das sind ja gigantisch teure Filme aber trotzdem ist er einer der alles in der Hand haben will der eben nicht so eine,
Entscheidung seines Werks haben möchte sondern der eigentlich alle Fäden in der Hand behalten will und der auch sagt das Kino ist der erste Ort wo man eigentlich Filme genießen kann alles,
ist sonst eben nur ein Abklatsch erreicht das nicht was das Kino erreichen kann. Deswegen ist es sehr eigenartig.
Ich glaube aber dass er sehr gut weiß dass er über den klassischen Weg,
den man eigentlich bei Interstellar noch beobachten konnte oder ganz stark noch bei Inception dass man eben diese klassischen Pressevorführung macht dass man den Film dort.
Bewirbt wo er in so einer Film Community zu Hause ist so dass das immer weniger funktioniert auch weil sich das so sehr ausdifferenziert hat durch diese vielen Streaming Plattformen.
Dass man eigentlich jetzt wo anders suchen muss wo bündelt sich eigentlich gerade ein großes Publikum das tendenziell vielleicht sagt Ach ja das klingt so interessant da gehen wir sogar mal für ins Kino weil das nicht,
etwas ist was ich auch auf Netflix sehen kann.
Und vielleicht ist das die überlegung warum es da diese Beziehung zu.
Als Inception angekündigt war habe ich mir einen Termin gemacht Den letzten hatte ich mir damals als Schüler für Pearl Harbor gemacht.
Michael Bay 2001 da stand ich Wochen vorher sozusagen in meinem Hausaufgabenhilfe kommt ins Kino und der nächste Termin den ich mir so markiert hatte war dafür Inception.
Und es war auch der einzige Film mit dem ich einmal alleine ins Kino gegangen sind weil ich dachte Ich will jetzt mal diesen Film sehen.
Da warte ich nicht ein halbes Jahr länger und habe irgendwie zu Hause sondern das will ich jetzt mal sehen wie es von Christopher Nolan erdacht wurde.
Und als jetzt dieser neue Trailer kam der zweite da wurde ja dann auch am Ende nur noch mit kommt ins Kino kommt demnächst ins Kino. Aber das Datum 17. stand eben nicht mehr drin.
Also überlegt Start hängt dann auch ab ob dein Mulan im Herbst rechtzeitig rechtzeitig kommt.
Dann ist ja diese James Bond Verschiebung auf November auch noch eine große.
Kometen Einschlag in diesem Kino Kalender der ja sonst immer so eine heilige Sache gewesen der sehr viel im Hintergrund.
Das finde ich wieder so typischen in Familie mäßig den Trailer in Fortner zeigen weil die Leute dann auch zu dem Film hingehen ja sie sind es auch.
Aber sie sind dann in dieser Welt und ich habe mich also ich bin jetzt kein Gamer oder so. Aber ich hab mich daran erinnert.
Ich habe damals als GTA 5 rauskam irgendwann 2000 12 13 14 oder so habe ich das gespielt. Aber extra für eine Xbox 360 geholt weil die wurde damals gerade aussortiert immer ein bisschen billiger zu haben.
Und das war ja so das erste Spiel das da oben wertmäßig ist wo du wirklich mit einem Auto in jede Straße Biegungen abbiegen konnte.
Sind die gegen die virtuelle Mauer sondern immer diese Straßenland fahren und in Los Santos oder wie die Stadt heißt gibt's ja auch Kinos in die man ja auch tatsächlich rein und dann wird auch tatsächlich ein Film gezeigt.
Ich finde das irgendwie so witzig dass wir jetzt mit Christopher Nolan jemanden haben der darüber nachdenkt ob er vielleicht Inception in Fortner zeigt wo man eh schon nicht genau weiß auf welcher Ebene sind wir eigentlich gerade des Traums.
Gleichzeitig sind wir nicht im Kino aber irgendwie doch aber in dieses Kino sind wir selber reingegangen nämlich in dem Computerspiel das wir eigentlich spielen.
Es ist wirklich total verdreht.
Ich glaube diese Kinogeschichte wird jetzt durch Corona nochmal ein bisschen angepasst zumindest denn solche Verstrickungen finde ich.
Wirklich super interessant auch wenn man nicht genau weiß ist es nur Quatsch oder steckt viel dahinter. Also wirklich verdreht. Mal gucken.
Aber es ist ja sehr schön. Jean Baudrillard hätte glaube ich viel dazu zu sagen gehabt.
Welche Simulation ausübende da eigentlich erreicht ist.
Denn es ist ja dann so im Spiel wenn dort wieder ein Film der real existiert auftaucht,
bekommt etwas eigentlich ja auch was wir sagen Fiktionales etwas illusionäre es wieder ein Realitätscheck Charakter.
Dadurch dass wir es noch woanders her kennen als nur in innerhalb des Spiels sondern wir kennen den Film außerhalb des Spiels und das ist eine sehr schöne überlegung.
Es ist verrückt und ermöglicht durch große Fernseher die man zu Hause hat.
Es ist ja heute überhaupt nicht mehr kostspielig sich Fernseher mit über einem Meter Diagonale zu holen die,
im Grunde ein Bild darstellen können dass der Fernseher niemals senden wird weil die senden immer noch in 720 Pixel skaliert man das auf 4K wo man das Fernsehbild in Realität in einem Fernseher abbilden würde dann würde das links oben wo früher das Logo war da war jetzt das ganze Fernsehbild,
das sowieso alles miteinander und die Spiele und das Business der Spiele ist auch größer als das des Kinos.
Das sind so Verschränkungen die sind wirklich verrückt aber gut.
Ich glaube nicht dass wir uns in Fortner anmelden nur um dann dort einen Nolan Film zu sehen oder.
Ich denke nein.
Ich bin gespannt. Bei Ford hat man sich wo man sich wirklich treffen kann als Großereignis wo man viele Figuren sieht.
Gleichzeitig ist das natürlich alles so Simulation im Sinne von dass man ja eigentlich doch alleine auch in diesem virtuellen Kino ist denn woher weiß man denn dass die anderen gerade echte Spieler sind nicht nur rein simulierte die dir so ein bisschen Sozialität vorgaukeln.
Ja. Also Spieler Bots quasi.
Sobald man darüber nachdenkt ist es ein bisschen verrückt genau das einfach so eine Gruppe Bootssteg gleichzeitig aber auf deinem iPhone auf dem Second Screen nachliest.
Auch da sind aber eigentlich sind sie gar nicht da sondern Du liest nur davon dass sie da sind.
Also dieses Gefühl erzeugen und jetzt gucken alle Fußball.
Du weißt es aber nur in deinem Kopf. Du siehst sie nicht alle Fußballgucken sondern du hast nur so ein Gefühl. Das gucken gerade alle.
Und darüber wurde ja auch sehr viel wetten dass Romantic hergestellt und so weiter.
Was man so einen Gemütszustand bedienen das gucken jetzt alle aber gleich sieht man gar niemanden. Es ist doch nur alleine zuhause.
Kino Wird sich mal sehr wandeln.
Dann kommen wir doch mal die Innenräume verschieben. Thema Superstar Events oder wie auch immer im Juli,
kommen ja nicht nur ich bin auch gespannt ob das Oktoberfest nochmal eine Diskussion wird weil irgendwann ist ja der Termin da aber es ist ja kein Oktoberfest da und alle werden feststellen warum.
Wir hatten doch seit zwei Monaten keinen Fall mehr in München.
Das Thema wird aber für die nächsten Monate aufheben.
Ein Thema das uns hier beschäftigt Wie ist das Geld. Wir haben schon häufiger darüber gesprochen.
Wir haben beispielsweise in der Januar Ausgabe über Ursula von der Leyens Green New Deal Green Deal gesprochen und du hast den eigenen Wohlstand für alle wie er sich nennt mit.
Und jetzt haben wir wieder so eine Krisensituation und eine Gemengelage in der man sagen kann steht Corona nicht im Mittelpunkt.
Kommt dann aber auch später dazu als Thema aber wir haben so ein Thema das massenmedial ein bisschen unterbelichtet wurde nicht nur quantitativ.
Es fanden meiner Meinung nach zu wenig Meldungen zum Thema statt welches genau sag ich gleich sondern ich fand auch qualitativ steckt einiges drin das man noch einmal rauskamen könnte wenn man sich im Originalton Sachen anhört kriegt man vielleicht auch noch einen anderen Dreh.
Und da wir beide auf der Höhe der Zeit sind sag ich mal so Wir kennen die Protagonisten und deren Vorgeschichte und unsere Hörer auch dachte ich mir,
wir gehen jetzt mal bei einem Thema das wahnwitzig ist weil es hier um mehrere Billionen Euro geht und bei den Protagonisten handelt sich um die höchsten Verfassungsorgane und so weiter und so fort.
Gehen wir doch einfach mal ein paar Clips durch gucken uns das in einer Geschichte an und übertreiben nicht.
Anmerkung hinsichtlich. Das ist aber wirklich bescheuert.
Das kann man durchaus mal sagen auch wenn es hier um Herrn Voßkuhle den Chef des Bundesverfassungsgericht nach 12 Jahren Berufserfahrung geht es ist nämlich wirklich erstaunlich verrückt.
Es geht um den 5. Mai.
Da hat nämlich das EZB ein Urteil verkündet. Zu einer Frage die schon lange auf den Schreibtischen der Richter lag.
Und Herr Voßkuhle von dem man so ein bisschen die Ahnung hatte in seinem allerletzten großen Urteils Amtsarzt wird er doch vielleicht ein bisschen über die Stränge schlagen und mal einen Pflock einbauen beispielsweise in seiner.
Darstellung wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht gerankt sein sollte gegen den Europäischen Gerichtshof und so weiter und so fort war man dann doch ein bisschen überrascht dass es so krass sein muss.
Wir sind jetzt im Akt eins Mai Vorstellung der Protagonisten macht Anmerkungen zu seinem eigenen Urteil über die Anleihekäufe der Europäischen Zentralbank.
Und leider muss man Voßkuhle spielen weil er das Urteil verkündet hat.
Gleichzeitig möchte ich anmerken wer das jetzt wirklich eine Daily Soap gewesen hätte man Herr Voßkuhle sagen müssen Ja sie sind nicht besonders textsicher können wir es nochmal drehen.
Er hat sich selber sehr verhaspelt Textes wird das jetzt mehrere Male auffallen aber wir hören das trotzdem an es ist im Original.
Man muss es mal im Original gehört haben Wir können auch direkt danach inhaltlich einschätzen was hier gesagt wird.
Herr Voßkuhle setzt sein Hütchen ab sitzt auf seinem Richterstuhl hat alle zur Ruhe gemahnt und trägt vor.
Es ist vor diesem Hintergrund nicht Aufgabe des Bundesverfassungsgerichts bei Auslegung zu fragen im Unionsrecht wie auch bei Methoden gerechter Bewältigung im üblichen rechtswissenschaftlichen Diskussionsforum zu verschiedenen Ergebnissen führen können.
Seine Auslegung an die Stelle derjenigen des Gerichtshofs zu setzen Es muss die Entscheidung des Gerichtshofs vielmehr auch dann respektieren wenn dieser zu einer Auffassung gelangt wer sich mit gewichtigen Argumenten entgegentreten ließe.
Allerdings gilt dies nur soweit sich die Entscheidung auf anerkannte methodische Grundsätze zurückführen lässt und nicht objektiv willkürlich erscheint im vorliegenden Fall ist diese Grenze überschritt.
Juristendeutsch vorgetragen ohne das vorher zu proben aber was er sagt ist ja wir wissen dass eigentlich der Europäische Gerichtshof für die Kontrolle der Europäischen Zentralbank zuständig ist.
Es sei denn wir können feststellen dass die so inkompetent in ihrer Kontrollfunktion sind dass wir uns dieses Recht,
anmaßen müssen als gäbe es diese Institution gar nicht auch wenn wir erst mal nur für die Bundesbank sprechen können die nur ein Teil der EZB des EZB-Rats darstellt,
so krasse Worte gefallen denn er musste ja sagen.
Der EuGH der auch schon mal in der Sache geurteilt hat wie wir gerade hat anerkannte methodische Grundsätze nicht beachtet und deswegen objektiv willkürlich gehandelt.
Fragt man so ein bisschen kann das wirklich sein es ist so ein Schulhoff Streit der auf dieser Ebene des Bettie Nene neben meinem Bruder ist aber zehn Jahre älter als deiner ausgetragen wird und stellt sich raus.
Ja denn im FAZ.NET-Interview hat dann der Bundesverfassungsschutz,
Richter Peter Huber der in dieser Sachlage Berichterstatter war also intern sozusagen der Geschäftsführer dieser Klage,
wurde gefragt von Reinhard Müller seinerseits auch Jurist Warum haben Sie dem EuGH schlechterdings nicht mehr nachvollziehbare und willkürliche Entscheidungen vorgeworfen.
Daraufhin Peter Huber zu. Die Begriffe schlechterdings nicht mehr nachvollziehbar und willkürlich klingen hart. Sie sind aber nicht.
Sie sind es aber nicht weil sie es dem Bundesverfassungsgericht überhaupt erst ermöglichen in eine ultraviolettes Kontrolle einzutreten also dem EuGH Kompetenzen abzusprechen.
Eine Frage in der Sache dienen sie dazu die Auslegung des europäischen Rechts dem EuGH so lange zu überlassen wie diese Grenze das schlechterdings nicht mehr nachvollziehbaren nicht überschritten wird.
Übersetzt heißt das Da wir in der Sache nur handeln dürfen wenn wir den EuGH für völlig bescheuert darstellen und erklären müssen wir das halt machen um dann handeln zu dürfen.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau das ist obwohl es nun mal renommierte Institutionen sind die hier einer wichtigen Sache entscheiden uns um sehr viel Geld und um sehr viel schicksalhafter Heftigkeit geht ist auf einer Ebene die mich ein bisschen überrascht hat ehrlich gesagt.
Ja sie überrascht deshalb weil man meint dass es dann.
Es gibt eine klare Hierarchie. Aber jetzt ist ja eigentlich die Frage Wie kann man diese Hierarchie umkehren.
Wie schafft man es jetzt aus Deutschland heraus doch wieder mehr Einfluss zu gewinnen und dann geht das eigentlich nur so indem man,
das System an sich dann anzweifelte in seiner Effektivität oder in seiner Vernunft oder was auch immer.
Und deshalb ist das eigentlich die einzige Möglichkeit überhaupt etwas zu machen.
Und das ist irgendwie großartig das auch im juristischen Diskurs der uns so ein trockener erscheint dann so was stattfindet.
Wir haben jetzt auf sehr vielen Ebenen Diskussionen sind wir alle 80 Millionen Virologen gibt's nicht echte Virologen dann haben wir echte Virologen die wiederum anderen Virologen weil sie nicht gerade forschen,
Kompetenz absprechen und die Twitter-App stützen daneben und sagen Ich bin zwar nicht mal Virologe aber der Virologe hat gesagt Der,
Biologe ist ja gar kein richtiger darf mich gar nicht kritisieren.
Auf der Ebene Wir diskutieren in einem Modus indem wir zuallererst den anderen Sprechern ihre Kompetenz absprechen um dann ein inhaltliches Argument nachzuschieben was natürlich nicht gelingt weil schon der erste MUW nicht akzeptiert wird.
Wir können nicht im Virologie Professor die Kompetenz absprechen weil ein anderer Virologe der auch noch Koryphäe auf dem Gebiet ist irgendwas sagt weil auf der Ebene haben wir nichts mitzureden. Da sind wir nun wirklich nur Publikum.
Ja da können wir zwar Prominenz und so weiter irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit verteilen aber es hat nichts mit wissenschaftlicher Reputation zu tun die wir da verteilen an der Stelle ist völlig Banane.
Und jetzt kommt ein Verfassungsgericht und macht genau so genau so Twitter Streiterei.
Spricht sie einem anderen Haus die Kompetenz ab mit krassen Worten um sich selbst zu legitimieren dann auch mal was inhaltlich sagte Döpfner und es kann auf der Ebene ja eigentlich nicht so richtig funktionieren.
Es muss halt im juristischen Text so gemacht werden damit es funktioniert aber es ist wirklich krass.
Und jetzt kann man mal schön gegenüberstellen Wir hören jetzt zuerst Voßkuhle als Chef des Bundesverfassungsgericht und kontrastieren das dann mal mit dem Bundespräsidenten.
Der ja nun auch ein Verfassungsorgan ist von ähnlichem Rang.
Also ich ordne sie jetzt alle mal als die Top vor oder irgendwie ein.
Und ich habe mir zuerst Voßkuhle bei seiner Urteilsverkündung.
Und er muss jetzt auch mal auf Draghi sozusagen ein bisschen persönlich werden Draghi Was hast Du eigentlich gemacht. Er wirft ihm hier in diesem Clip Blindflug vor.
Der Senat somit nicht an die Entscheidung des Gerichtshofs gebunden ist hat er eigenständig zu beurteilen ob die EZB mit den Beschlüssen zur Errichtung und Durchführung des PCP noch innerhalb ihrer Kompetenzen gehandelt hat das ist offensichtlich nicht der Fall.
Jetzt hat er gesagt Wir sind ja nicht gebunden an das was dieser Senat damit meint er sein eigenes Gericht ist nicht daran gebunden was er sagt sondern Urteil selbst und sagt,
Das ist ja gar nicht der Fall dass die ordentlich gehandelt haben im EZB-Rat beim Ankauf von zwei Billionen Anleihekäufen.
Weil die EZB Erwägungen zur Verhältnismäßigkeit nicht angestellt hat die Beschlüsse beschränken sich auf die Feststellung dass das angestrebte Inflationsziel von 2 Prozent nicht erreicht sei und weniger belastende Mittel nicht zur Verfügung stünden.
Sie enthalten keine Prognose zu den wirtschaftspolitischen Auswirkungen des Programms sowie dazu ob sie in einem angemessenen Verhältnis zu dem erstrebten währungspolitischen Vorteilen stehen.
Es ist nicht ersichtlich dass der EZB-Rat im PPP angelegten und mit ihm unmittelbar verbundenen Folgen,
die dieses Programm aufgrund seines Volumens von über 2 Billionen Euro Euro und einer Laufzeit von mittlerweile mehr als drei Jahren zwangsläufig verursacht erfasst und abgewogen hätte.
Also Ja die EZB möchte die Zinssätze kleinhalten knapp unter 2 Prozent macht es aber mit Methoden dessen Nebenfolgen sie gar nicht erfasst und abgewogen hat.
Sehr schön und damit wird auch gleich suggeriert etwas was ja die EZB bin ich darf mich Wirtschaftspolitik zu betreiben.
Genau.
Sie beruft sich darauf Währungspolitik zu betreiben und da gibt es eben das Inflationsziel und das ist dann das was man erreichen möchte durch diese Geldpolitik.
Aber hier dann selbstverständlich die Unterstellung die wollen ja eine Wirtschaftspolitik machen und die ist ziemlich unverantwortlich da denken die noch nicht einmal über die Folgen nach was das eigentlich heißt.
In Klammern der arme deutsche Sparer zum.
Z.B genau das halten wir uns mal genau den Gedanken fest Da kommt man nämlich dann später drauf Der Bundestag wird nämlich dann auch zum Urteil noch kurz debattieren,
und wir müssen an der Stelle sagen wenn die EZB irgendwas mit dem Geld macht und sie kann zum Beispiel die Geldmenge erhöhen indem sie einfach Geld rauswirft dann hat das Folgen und da kann man auch sagen Das greift irgendeine Wirtschaftspolitik ein.
Die Frage ist dann hat es Folgen weil man die Folgen wollte oder sind da jetzt einfach Nebenfolgen die passieren wenn man die Geldmenge erhöht.
Und wir haben ja auch im Januar schon so ein bisschen erfreut eigentlich auf die EZB Pressekonferenz von Lagarde zum Green New Deal oder Queen geschaut als sie so meinte ja dieses Programm von alleine finde wir ganz gut.
Wir machen im Haus auch viel weil da verbinden sie ja natürlich ein ganz klares politisches und inhaltliches Ziel nämlich Klima Rettung,
mit geldpolitischen Maßnahmen dem Sie sagen ja wenn sie die Umwelt schützen wollen mit ihrem Wirtschafts Projekt dann investieren wir lieber rein als wenn sie jetzt nochmal,
50 prozent des Umsatzes mit Kohleverstromung oder so machen.
Die EZB ist eigentlich schon das kann man ihr schon unterstellen die hat schon mal so ein paar Anliegen und die finden wir eigentlich auch ein bisschen gut wenn man sie sich mal anschaut.
Wir finden die gut ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt schon zu sehr vorweg greife Wir finden die gut weil die EZB eigentlich keynesianisch hier argumentiert und sagt Wir müssen jetzt was für die Infrastruktur tun oder so.
Da kann der Staat jetzt Geld in die Hand nehmen und das machen das was auf Bundesebene eher nicht passiert. Wir kennen.
Was in der Politik nicht passiert.
Wir wollen jetzt gar nicht Bahn oder so ansprechen. Das sehen wir jetzt aber dass das bei der EZB denkbar ist.
Und deswegen sind wir da durchaus positiv erst einmal gestimmt.
Genau. Und wir müssen noch anmerken historisch und strukturell.
Die EZB ist ein Kompromiss einen Kompromiss Institutionen haben sich sehr viele Länder zusammengeschlossen.
In anderen Ländern indem man so eine gewisse politische Einigung Einigkeit hat wie z.B.
In Amerika oder bei der Bank of England ist es völlig normal dass diese Banken sich natürlich darum kümmern dass irgendwie der Laden auch läuft.
Und genau das ist der EZB verboten vermeintlich wird ihr jedenfalls gesagt Wir sind ja an einem Stadium ganz Frye wo wir auch Voßkuhle sagen müssen diese Aberkennung von Eugenia Kompetenzen.
Das kann man gar nicht so einfach machen nur weil du behauptest wenn ich mal sage das ist schlechterdings völlig willkürlich.
Dann hab ich mir selber eine Kompetenz zugeschrieben das ist auch so sehr ausgedacht das Ding wurde später kommentiert.
Ich sehe mich ja eher ein bisschen auf schwammigen Grund.
Was das angeht habe ich gehört wie Voßkuhle Draghi als EZB-Chef denn die Programme Zeit verantwortet verantwortet hat die Folgen nicht erfasst und nicht abgewogen hat.
Und jetzt haben wir im Kontrast dazu unserem Bundespräsidenten Frank-Walter Steinmeier der im Januar diesen Jahres meinen 30.
Januar Draghi das Bundesverdienstkreuz verliehen hat und zwar mit folgender Erklärung.
Vor allem gilt diese Ehrung heute Ihnen ganz persönlich verehrter Herr Professor Draghi Sie müssten mit den Instrumenten einer Zentralbank in einer Zeit handeln,
als es noch kein voll entwickeltes europäisches Instrumentarium zur Krisenintervention gab.
Sie müssten in einem Szenario Handeln für das es kein europäisches Drehbuch gab.
Ein Szenario in dem Abwarten keine Option war.
Und sie haben gehandelt.
Der Bundespräsident macht genau die gleiche Einschätzung wie der Verfassungsgerichtspräsident nur sagt Danke für ihn Mut.
Er dreht das Urteil genau um.
Es war kein Drehbuch da das ist sehr schön da würde Voßkuhle sagen Ja die hatten kein Recht dazu das zu machen.
Genau die hätten sich erst mal ein Drehbuch schreiben müssen.
Und Steinmeier erkennt an es gab kein Drehbuch sondern es musste jetzt gehandelt werden. Und.
Das müssen wir vielleicht noch hinzufügen. Draghi ist der der diese whatever it takes Rede gehalten hat der dann,
versprach die EZB werde alles dafür tun um den Euro zu retten und dann alles was ihr sozusagen gestattet ist zu tun und das hat alles ihr Mandat.
Genau alles in ihr Mandat.
Das hat er selbstverständlich auch mit allen Spielräumen dann ausgeweitet aber das war eben das was so viele aufgebracht hat und bis heute.
Wir werden ja irgendwann noch heute über Verschwörungstheorien reden.
Auch da gibt es ein ganz ganz Interessantes zu erleben gerade bei YouTube.
Merkwürdige Finanzer Gurus die immer wieder in Draghi den Teufel in Person sehen und sehen dass wir dadurch alle enteignet werden und so weiter.
Deswegen ist Draghi so eine Hassfigur und die haben natürlich auch Rot gesehen.
Als er dann die Auszeichnung vom Bundespräsidenten noch erhalten hat.
Während Bill Gates gerade das Hassobjekt des armen Mannes ist ist Draghi sozusagen die Hassfigur des reichen Mannes mit genau den gleichen Unterstellungen.
Der hat ja alle Strippen in der Hand und alle anderen sind sozusagen nur noch ihm untergeordnet.
Und jetzt hören wir nochmal Voßkuhle Wir.
Und das ist wirklich so es ist. Wann wird sich eigentlich Was Voßkuhle macht jetzt mal eine Ansage.
Was passiert wenn seinem Urteil dass nämlich die EZB erklären muss was geschehe geschah mit dem Geld und warum das so notwendig war den Staaten dieses Geld zukommen zu lassen.
Was passiert wenn jetzt nicht auf ihn Voßkuhle gehört wird.
Bundesregierung und Bundestag sind aufgrund ihrer Integrations Verantwortung verpflichtet auf eine Verhältnismäßigkeit Prüfung durch die EZB im Rahmen des PCP hinzuwirken.
Entsprechendes gilt für die am 1. Januar 2019 begonnene Investitions Phase des PCP und seine Wiederaufnahme zum 1. November 2019.
Insoweit dauert auch die Pflicht die Entscheidung des Eurosystems über Ankäufe von Staatsanleihen unter dem PCP zu beobachten und mit den ihnen zu Gebote stehenden Mittel auf die Einhaltung des ESZB zugewiesenen Mandats hinzuwirken.
Forth zweitens der Bundesbank ist es untersagt nach einer Abstimmung im Eurosystem notwendigen übrigen und ganz Frist von höchstens drei Monaten,
an Umsetzung und Vollzug der Verfahrens gegenständlichen Beschlüsse weiter mitzuwirken,
wenn nicht der EZB-Rat in einem neuen Beschluss nachvollziehbar darlegt dass die mit dem PPP angestrebten währungspolitischen Ziele nicht außer Verhältnis zu den damit verbundenen wirtschafts und fiskalpolitischen.
Sondern jetzt.
Stehen.
Unter derselben Voraussetzung ist die Bundesbank verpflichtet für eine im Rahmen des Eurosystems abgestimmte auch langfristig angelegte Rückführung der Bestände an Staatsanleihen Sorge zu tragen.
Also der Bundesverfassungsgericht das Bundesverfassungsgericht gibt dem Bundestag den Auftrag kommt mal eure sozusagen ihr seid legitimiert die EZB hier,
zu legitimieren also zur Mandatarin aber ihr müsst dann eben auch mal nachfragen was die so machen wenn die EZB euch keine zufriedenstellende Antwort gibt dann müsst ihr die Bundesbank beauftragen dass sie die Anleihen wieder zurückholen.
Und das fragt man sich so ein bisschen wie es geht auch hier um um wieviel geht es eigentlich.
Wieviel Geld ist eigentlich in Frage Wieviel wieviel Anleihen soll denn die EZB die die Bundesbank jetzt zurückkaufen und Voßkuhle hat selbst mal den Rahmen hier kurz abgesteckt.
Zum 8. November 2019 hat das Eurosystem im Rahmen des EAP Wertpapiere im Gesamtwert,
von zwei tausend fünf hundert sieben und fünfzig Milliarden Euro erworben wovon circa 2000 88 Milliarden Euro auf das PPP entfielen.
Also das fragliche Programm über das fragliche Programm hat die EZB für 2008 und 80 Milliarden Euro Staatsanleihen gekauft,
die Bundesbank also die nationalen Notenbanken erledigen ja diesen Kauf nehmen sie tatsächlich vor die Gendern auf den Markt und kaufen einfach dieser Staatsanleihen auf.
Und die Bundesbank ist ja mit ein und zwanzig komma vier Prozent an diesem Kapitalstock der EZB beteiligt.
Das hieße Der Voßkuhle hat gerade gesagt Wenn der Bundestag der EZB die Frage stellt Was habt ihr mit dem Programm gemacht und seid ihr euch im Klaren darüber und so weiter und die Antwort ist nicht zufriedenstellend.
Dann muss der Bundestag die Bundesbank beauftragen diese fünf Milliarden zurück zu bewegen also die Anleihen wieder.
Für also 500 Milliarden zu mobilisieren die man ja eigentlich mobilisiert hat damit überhaupt noch der Laden läuft wieder zurück.
Es ist völlig wie es tatsächlich ist.
Also mir fehlen auch so ein bisschen die Worte. Aber jetzt wird ein weiterer Protagonist vorgestellt nämlich einer der Beschwerdeführer Peter Gauweiler.
Für die Beschwerdeführer der Verfassungsbeschwerde 2b war er 2006 aus 2015. Herr Dr. Peter Gauweiler.
Also namentlich aufgerufen ist auch anwesend hat sich Gott hingestellt gesagt.
Peter Gauweiler hat natürlich nicht viel zu reden. Er wurde aber im Deutschlandfunk noch einmal interviewt. So machmal.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch ganz kurz sagen wir Peter Gauweiler weiß nicht ob das so bekannt ist also CSU Abgeordneter.
Ein CSU-Politiker der ganz eigenartig ist der im Zuge von 68 in die CSU eingetreten ist.
Auf der einen Seite also stramm konservative Positionen vertritt auf der anderen Seite auch so ein bisschen das C und das Soziale in der CSU.
Dann wieder geschrieben hat sich auch ganz gut mit Oskar Lafontaine und Sahra Wagenknecht versteht,
der fast manchmal zu irgendwelchen sozialistischen äußerungen bereit ist aber jetzt hier eigentlich eine ganz eigenartige Rolle spielt dass er eigentlich jetzt sagt Nee also,
das ist jetzt mit der EU eigentlich ein großbürgerlich.
Er ist ein großer EU-Kritiker und er als sehr erfolgreicher Anwalt hat er immer wieder den Versuch unternommen irgendwie die EU anzugreifen auf juristischem Wege.
Es gab die letzten Jahrzehnte im Grunde keine Vertragsänderungen,
zu denen Peter Gauweiler nicht einmal seine Jura-Professor losgeschickt hat um in Hunderten seitenlangen Texten des Bundesverfassungsgericht aufzufordern dem jetzt zu widersprechen weil diese Einigung geht so weit und ja die Demokratie so,
Peter Gauweiler sehr erfolgreicher Anwalt als der Bundestag sah es war immer der reichste unter allen also mit Abstand wirklich der reichste der dann einfach ein bisschen rum gepoltert hat,
sich mittlerweile ein bisschen auch altersbedingt jetzt isoliert hat aus diesem politischen Prozess aber über dieser Verfassungsgegner immer wieder auftaucht.
Peter Gauweiler hat jetzt als Beschwerdeführer ein Urteil erwirkt das die Möglichkeit in den Raum stellt dass die Bundesbank in drei Monaten in diesem Herbst 550 Milliarden mobilisieren muss,
um Staatsanleihen wieder zurückzuholen die man Menschen gegeben hat.
Wem auch immer man hat die auf dem Markt gekauft nicht direkt bei den Staaten.
Deutschland hat Staatsanleihen ausgegeben irgendwo auf dem Markt hat sie gekauft um eine Bank oder die Bundesbank sagt kaufen wir euch aber für fünf Milliarden.
Und jetzt besteht durch das Urteil die Gefahr dass diese fünf Milliarden mobilisiert werden müssen und dann fragt man sich ja wie denn.
Wo soll denn das Geld jetzt herkommen. Die Idee war ja eigentlich umgedreht dass wir das Geld damit erzeugen und nicht wieder vom Markt nehmen.
Peter Gauweiler sagt jetzt im Deutschlandfunk und jetzt wird es wirklich haarsträubender. Es ist folgendes.
Die Europäische Zentralbank hat sogenannte Anleihekäufe gemacht PSP in einer Höhe die sogar die Milliardengrenze überschritten hat in Billionen.
Dafür haftet die Europäische Zentralbank die diese Anleihen in ihre Bilanzen aufnehmen wird. Der größte Gesellschafter der Europäischen Zentralbank ist die Deutsche Bundesbank.
In einer Ausfall Situation in einer Extremsituation haften dafür die Gesellschafter für die Schulden der Deutschen Bundesbank haftet wiederum der deutsche Steuerzahler.
Peter Gauweiler hat Angst davor dass die EZB in eine Extremsituation sein Zitat noch ein Zitat in seine Ausfall Situation kommt,
wodurch die Bundesbank verantwortlich für ihren ein und zwanzig komma vier Prozent Kapitalstock dafür verantwortlich wird.
Diese Verantwortung muss sie dann weitergeben an den Bundestag. Der muss eine Steuer machen die dann irgendwie die EZB stützt und dass er mit seinem Steuergeld,
den Ausfall der EZB stützen muss da fragt man sich ein bisschen,
was für eine ausfall Situation der EZB stellt er sich denn vor bei der dann nicht die ganze Welt in Trümmern liegt und ein Komet eingeschlagen ist sondern eher noch in der Lage wäre über Steuerzahlungen dieses Loch zu füllen.
Das ist wirklich eine ganz absurde Geschichte und ich erzähle dir jetzt einmal einen ganz realen Effekt der mir zugetragen wurde aus entfernteren Bekanntenkreis von Leuten,
hier in der Nähe lebend.
Die Angst davor haben jetzt durch die Coruna Krise.
Und was die EZB da gerade tut dass sie enteignet werden bzw.
Dass der Staat von ihnen das Geld doch zurückverlangen muss weil er es nicht mehr hat.
Und dann überlegen sie ob sie hundert 150 000 Euro Hypothek aufnehmen müssen dann auf ihr Haus um dem Staat das Geld zu geben.
Und da sehen wir den realen Effekt und da wird jetzt gerade überlegt Wäre es besser jetzt das Geld noch von der Bank zu nehmen es in Silber anzulegen in Gold anzulegen.
All diese überlegen also Silber und Goldpreis boomt gerade.
Ich glaube das hat viele Gründe aber auch den dass Privatleute jetzt sagen Oh Gott ich klammern mich jetzt daran bald werden wir enteignen.
Das sind solche Fantasien die eben auch in diesen Finanzen Verschwörungstheorien vorkommen.
Und da sehen wir gerade wohin das im Kleinen führt dass wirklich Leute glauben ja wenn die EZB da pleitegehen sollte dann muss ja der deutsche Staat einspringen.
Dann muss das irgendwie aufgefangen werden und der macht das dann über Steuern oder eben durch Enteignung.
Ja das ist Wahnsinn. Denn wenn man Angst vor so einer Situation hat also dass Notenbanken ausfallen und dafür gibt's eigentlich nur zwei Möglichkeiten,
Entweder es gibt einfach ein technisches Problem die Druckerei geht kaputt oder es gibt einen irgendwie ein Computer Ausfall sodass das Geld nicht mehr verbucht werden kann,
oder das zweite Es ist stellt sich eine neue juristische Hürde auf.
Das sind die beiden Szenarien die zu diesen Ausfluß Szenarien führen können.
Also einfach ein technisches sozusagen wie so Naturereignisse Stromausfall bei der EZB. Und nichts geht mehr.
Deswegen kann man die Anweisungen an die Bundesbank nicht geben und die können auch nicht auf ihre Händler Computer auf Kaufen klicken weil es im Moment nicht geht.
Oder wie gesagt eine juristische Hürde die man nicht mehr überspringen kann sodass sich die beiden Oswalds Szenarien vor denen hat Peter Gauweiler Angst weshalb er das Bundesverfassungsgericht beauftragt so eine juristische Hürde aufzustellen,
in eine juristische Ausfallsicherheit.
Das System hacken kann er ja nicht dass die Druckerpressen nicht mehr funktioniert.
Genau das kann ich nicht. Er hat Angst vor einem vor einem Extremfall vor einer Ausfall Situation die er mit seinem Urteil selbst hervorruft und es ist so verrückt das kann man sich wirklich dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht dem auch noch entspricht.
Das ist so verrückt man kann sich wirklich nicht ganz erklären. Wir können es hier sozusagen nur im O-Ton dokumentieren was da vor sich gefallen ist.
Steinmeier hat im Januar und ich meine das Urteil hat sich nur ein bisschen angebahnt Er hat es ein bisschen antizipiert als er Merkel und Voßkuhle und dann Draghi als ausgezeichneten in einem Raum hatte,
und hat da auch schon mal eine Anmerkung noch gemacht.
Mich besorgt das leichtfertige Fingerzeigen auf Frankfurt.
Wir haben nur eine EZB Deutschland braucht die EZB und die EZB braucht Deutschland.
Deshalb hoffe ich dass wir wieder zu einer Auseinandersetzung finden die ernst und deutlich in der Sache ist,
aber sachlich bleibt und die nicht ausschließlich von denen geführt wird die Niedrigzinsen in den Vereinigten Staaten gut finden und in Europa schlecht oder gleichzeitig für die Sparer schlecht für die Bauwirtschaft gut.
Ich wünsche mir dass es gelingt die Missverständnisse und auch die gelegentliche Sprachlosigkeit zwischen der EZB und der deutschen öffentlichkeit zu überwinden.
Frommer Wunsch ihm wurde nicht entsprochen sondern diese Bombe ist einfach rein explodiert in eine nicht laufende Diskussion weshalb wir es jetzt mit absurden Argumentationen zu tun haben,
die einfach so aufeinander Bräuten sind eine richtige Karambolage.
Würde man sagen Es ist völlig verrückt aber es haben ja einige Autoren Heiner Flassbeck hatte ja große Angst hat er immer wieder geschrieben.
Ich habe große Angst davor dass die Deutschen irgendwann mal verstehen wie es wirklich funktioniert mit dem Geld dass da nicht so viel Leistungs,
Disziplin und Aera dahinter steckt sondern einfach eine politische Entscheidung darüber sollten wir mal finanzieren Geldquelle ist ja die Notenbank.
Solange das mit den Inflation im Rahmen bleibt und davon sind wir nun wirklich weit entfernt dass wir hier eine Inflation bedrohlichen Ausmaßes haben eher das Gegenteil.
Man braucht nur nach Japan zu gucken was dort ausgegeben wird wie verschuldet man sich dort.
Auch China will jetzt wohl doch wieder sehr viel mehr investieren. Erst war man vor einigen Wochen ja noch zögerlich und es gibt aber diese Angst und diese ist natürlich politisch wahnsinnig gut aus nutzbar.
Also ich glaube dass es auch am Ende wieder ein guter Ankerpunkt für eine AfD die damit auch ein bisschen wieder zu ihren Wurzeln zurückkommen kann.
Denn was wir auch eingestehen müssen Die EU ist eine sehr merkwürdige Wirtschafts Konstruktion das große Problem ist Wir haben eben viele Staaten mit ganz unterschiedlichen Wirtschaftsleistung und das unter einen Hut zu bringen,
ist auch fast ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Dadurch treten auch sehr viele Komplikationen auf aber man kann eben mit so einer Angst vor Enteignung vor Steuern dass wir am Ende wieder für alles aufkommen und dann diese narrativer heißen,
sehr gut Wahlkampf machen und ich glaube auch dass das was ist wo ein,
Friedrich Merz oder so drauf gucken wird ob er da auch mit aufspringt.
Das ist angesprochen eines der Probleme ist die europäische Ungleichheit der kann man begegnen mit einer gemeinsamen Wirtschaftspolitik die beispielsweise mehr Arbeitslosigkeit als europäisches Problem begreift und nicht immer die Deutschen bevorzugt wird.
Da geht man ein Jahr bessere Bezüger als in Griechenland wo man gleich durchs Rost fällt.
Nur genau diese gemeinsame Wirtschaftspolitik wurde der EZB beispielsweise ja gerade aus der Hand geschlagen sondern da kam das Urteil des Bundes sie dürfte nicht Ihr dürft nicht mal Nebenfolgen die ihr nicht haben wolltet,
mit einkalkulieren sondern es darf einfach gar keinen Nebenfolgen im Grunde geben.
Dieses Programm muss eventuell sogar rückabgewickelt werden.
Altmaier Steinmeier hat hier im Januar dann nochmal eine ganz gute Frage gestellt die es besonders in Bezug auf natürlich ein bisschen verklausuliert aber ich will noch mal dran erinnern.
Hans-Werner Sinn hat als wissenschaftlicher Berater des Finanzministers,
Schäuble Wolfgang Schäuble seinerzeit den Griechen empfohlen doch einfach den Euro zu verlassen ist nicht richtig hinhaut und daran erinnert Herr Steinmeier mal ohne Namen zu nennen.
Aber im historischen Vergleich ist triftig und drastisch darzustellen.
Sie haben bewahrt was andere aufzugeben bereit schien.
Das ist ein bisschen seine kleine Laudatio an Draghi. Wenn er sagt sie meint da Sie Herr Draghi haben bewahrt was andere bereit waren aufzugeben.
Niemand mag sich vorstellen wo Europa heute stünde wenn nicht nur das Vereinigte Königreich die Europäische Union verlassen hätte sondern wenn es zugelassen worden wäre dass die Euro-Zone erodiert,
oder gar zerbricht.
Sie haben sich mit aller Kraft und ja auch unter Inkaufnahme von Risiken dagegen gestemmt und deswegen fährt Draghi freue ich mich heute mit dem Verdienstorden der Bundesrepublik Deutschland auszuzeichnen.
So Herr Draghi Sie haben sich mit allen dagegen gestemmt dass nach dem Brexit auch noch eine Erosion der Eurozone passiert beispielsweise durch das,
vielleicht sogar zwanghafte gewalttätige Ausscheiden einzelner Staaten die das nicht aus eigenen Stücken machen wie beim Brexit sondern dem man einfach sagen kann könne hier nicht brauchen ihr Loser haut mal ab.
Darin schwingt ja so ein bisschen die Argumentation drin dass man sagen kann Ja Herr Voßkuhle Sie können es durchaus alles kritisieren was Herr Draghi macht nur was wäre denn die Alternative.
Damit müssen sie sich nicht befassen als Bundesverfassungsgericht Sie haben ja nur ihren Streitgegenstand aber mal politisch diskutiert Was wäre denn die Alternative zu keiner hat Geld.
Keiner verfügt über Geld und es gibt auch keine 2 Billionen dazu um eine Krise wie 2008 zu bewältigen.
Wie sieht dann wie sähe dann eigentlich Europa aus. Da muss er sich keine Gedanken machen und deswegen kommen wir jetzt hier in den zweiten Akt.
Das Problem Die Entwicklung ins Drama wenn man dachte das ist schon dramatisch wird jetzt erst einmal Voßkuhle sagte drei wichtige Sachen Wir fangen wir bei dem ersten an.
Meine Damen und Herren. Das vorliegende Urteil ist keine leichte Kost.
Erstmals in seiner Geschichte stellte das Bundesverfassungsgericht fest,
dass Handlungen und Entscheidungen europäischer Organe offensichtlich nicht von der europäischen Kompetenz gedeckt sind und daher in Deutschland keine Wirksamkeit entfalten können.
Man spricht insofern von ultra Pires Akten.
Für viele Kenner der Materie dürfte die Entscheidung indes keine überraschung sein weil sie den wahrscheinlich nur vorläufigen Endpunkt einer längeren und absehbaren Entwicklung markiert.
Ja dies aber so als Diskussion nur in Deutschland gab es sehr viele Nichtdeutsche haben mir sehr die Augen gerieben und sich fragt bitte was,
glaubt ihr seid da kompetent rechtlich zuständig in der Sache und zweitens ist das irgendwie folgerichtig dass man jetzt sagt Nee nee das Ganze Anleihekaufprogramm war falsch. Es muss eventuell auch rückabgewickelt werden.
Er sieht sein Urteil hier irgendwie folgerichtig.
Denn es war auch lange Zeit von Politikern so vermittelt dass man sagte naja europäische Fiskalpolitik vernünftige ist selbstverständlich so wie deutsche Fiskalpolitik Fed ansonst und das können wir doch überall adaptieren.
Wir sind ja Exportweltmeister und so weiter wir sind erfolgreich.
Und deswegen ist es so ganz logisch und zwingend dass das für die ganze EU gut sein wird.
Und da muss man sagen ja für Deutschland wäre das dann gut aber für alle anderen eher nicht bzw.
Man jetzt gerade ja erleben kann durch das was da vom Bundesverfassungsgericht gekommen ist dass es da Applaus auch gibt das vielleicht,
auch ein Herr Gauweiler zum Nachdenken bringen müsste wenn zum Beispiel in Polen man dann jubelt und sagt Ja wunderbar da sieht man mal,
was wir da eigentlich für ein schlimmes EU Monster herangezüchtet haben.
Wenn man in Polen sieht also die Deutschen die haben jetzt plötzlich so eine kompetente Sprachregelung gefunden. Wir dürfen jedoch doch zuständig.
Wieso hat das Europarecht dann eigentlich bei uns Vorrang. Wenn wir das oder jenes machen. Diese Frage stellt sich ja durchaus.
Da kommen wir zurück denn es gibt natürlich Nebenschauplätze die auch noch so eine Rolle spielen.
Jetzt hat Voßkuhle Ja gesagt Mein Urteil ist folgerichtig zumindest aus der deutschen Brille.
Das bringt also zehn Jahre Hans-Werner Sinn als einziger Rädelsführer,
des ökonomischen Denkens so mit sich jetzt haben wir ja andere und so kommen wir gleich darauf,
mein Urteil ist folgerichtig und dann zieht er hier im zweiten Akt auch ein bisschen den Schwanz ein und sagt Na ja so folgerichtig schon aber es ist auch begrenzt mein Urteil und im übrigen auch folgenlos.
Finanzielle Hilfsmaßnahmen der Europäischen Union oder der EZB im Zusammenhang mit der gegenwärtigen Krise sind nicht Gegenstand dieser Entscheidung.
So die aktuellen Anleihekäufe. Die EZB kauft für 750 Milliarden Möhrchen sie Staatsanleihen auf um die Staaten zu finanzieren und zwar bezogen auf Coruña.
Das ist nun wirklich Wirtschaftspolitik die die EZB macht mit der klaren Ansage Wir haben ja ein Problem Corona Wir haben geldpolitische Möglichkeiten aber na klar die aktivieren wir natürlich nur um die Wirtschaft zu stützen.
Und es ist ein klares politisches Anliegen also wenn man eigentlich Voßkuhle ernst nehmen wollte müsste er hier sagen wir erkennen den Grund an warum sie das machen.
Sie wollen hier die Wirtschaft Europas helfen und kaufen deswegen für 77 Milliarden gerade Anleihen.
Aber wir müssen leider aus der juristischen Brille sagen das dürfen sie gar nicht sie sind ja nicht legitimiert.
Da zieht er aber komplett den Schwanz ein. Was das angeht da kann man jetzt auch keine leichtere Sprache oder so wählen. Das ist richtig. Schwanz einziehen muss man halt einfach so.
Drittens Das ist jetzt ein sehr komplizierter Kapsel Satz ist eigentlich unglaublich dass überhaupt so aber der eigentliche Punkt den er machen wollte ist ja der EuGH.
Gibts in diesem Urteil eine Rolle der EZB auch.
Aber eigentlich kann er nur zum Bundestagwahl sagen weil das andere europäische Institutionen der EU zuständig.
Seine Reichweite ist sowieso begrenzt auf deutsche Institutionen also Bundestag und Bundesbank.
Und das stellt er dann hier auch noch da. Allerdings ist der Satz nun wirklich mal so aus humoristischen gründen drin gelassen.
Ich weiß juristische Sprache ist schwierig aber ich glaube man kann das auch ein bisschen runterfahren wenn man so eine wichtige Botschaft hat an den Bundestag.
Drittens Bundesregierung und hinsichtlich der Beschwerdeführer böhmisch erstens und zweitens braucht der Deutsche Bundestag haben die Beschwerdeführer zu römisch erstens und,
zweitens und drittens in ihrem Recht aus Artikel 38 Absatz 1 Satz 1 in Verbindung mit Artikel 20 Absatz 1 und Absatz 2 in Verbindung mit Artikel 79 Absatz 3 des Grundgesetzes verletzt,
da sie es unterlassen haben geeignete Maßnahmen dagegen zu ergreifen.
Dass der Rat der Europäischen Zentralbank klein a in Beschluss 2015 aus 774 der Europäischen Zentralbank vom 4.
März 2015 über ein Programm zum Ankauf von Wertpapieren des öffentlichen Sektors an den Sekundärmarkt Märkten geändert durch Beschluss 2015 21 01 der Europäischen Zentralbank vom 5.
November 2015 durch Beschluss 2015 2000 464 vom 16.
Dezember 2015 durch Beschluss 2016 702 vom 18.
April 2016 und durch Beschluss 2017 vom 11.
Januar 2017 weder geprüft noch dargelegt hat dass die beschlossenen Maßnahmen dem Grundsatz der Verhältnismäßigkeit entsprechen.
Wenn man das.
Eine Rüge direkt an Bundesregierung und Bundestag mit vielen römischen Ziffern.
Genau. Bundesregierung Bundestag.
Aber eigentlich sagt er den vier hätte mal schauen müssen was habt ihr denn da eigentlich gemacht habt ihr geschlafen oder was.
Sobald man dafür ein Drehbuch schreibt wofür ich sehr plädiere ich will das nochmal ordentlich dargelegt haben müsste man sich überlegen wie man diese Szene so macht dass sie juristisch korrekt aber trotzdem ein bisschen verständlicher ist denn was er im Grunde gemacht hat ist hat gesagt lieber Bundestag der EZB.
Die EZB hat in mehreren Beschlüssen gesagt Wir kaufen jetzt mal diese Programme und ihr habt euch da nicht ordentlich eingebracht und die mal gefragt Was machen wir da eigentlich.
Warum er dann noch das Datum der Beschlussfassung im EZB-Rat geklammert hat in Halbsätze ist mir ein bisschen unklar.
Ich glaube da kann man auch ein bisschen Lockerheit walten lassen während man so ein Urteil verliest und sagen Sehen Sie die Termine bitte in der Tabelle nach Terminkalender oder so.
Aber gut als sie alle da eingebaut.
Na ja das ist schon etwas wo man sagen muss Das kann auch eine Strategie sein.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so firm darin dass ich weiß wie weit einfach so eine Urteilsverkündung eben diesen formalen Ansprüchen genüge tun muss.
Aber du hast es ja anfangs schon als du eingeleitet hast zu dem Thema daraufhingewiesen dass das ein bisschen unterbelichtet war in den Medien.
Und dass man jetzt von Deutschlandradio oder so mal abgesehen nicht allzu viel davon erfährt.
Und wir sehen ja schon Wir sind jetzt schon eine Weile dabei.
Wie kompliziert das auch erst mal ist um diese Konstruktion zu verstehen.
Ich würde sogar soweit gehen das ist gar nicht mehr kompatibel für die Nachrichtensendungen die wir kennen aus dem Fernsehen.
Also das kann ich mir auch bei Tagesthemen oder so gar nicht vorstellen dass man das in den vier Minuten Beitrag bekommt wenn es dann mal richtig lang sein soll.
Oder man hat nochmal kurz UN-Experten Interview also das ist sehr sehr schwierig.
Das heißt bei solchen Konstruktionen müsste eigentlich zugleich ein Medienwandel stattfinden dass man darüber nachdenkt wie kann man das anders überhaupt vermitteln.
Und dann wäre die Frage die man anschließen muss will man das überhaupt groß vermitteln.
Genau will man das. Vielleicht kriegen wir ja noch die nächsten zwei drei Jahre so ein Stimmungswandel hin von Hans-Werner Sinn und Marcel Fratzscher oder so. Dann liegt es auf der Hand weil die sitzen ja heute genauso wie wir hier da sitzen in den Tagesthemen und sagen Das ist so banane.
Was da abläuft. Die trauen sich ja wirklich zu sagen was sie davon halten.
Ich wünsche mir allerdings auch ein Drehbuch. Ich glaube auch die Nachrichten Nachrichtensendungen werden hierfür falsch hier brauchen wir eine richtige Verfilmung.
Also kurz ins Fiktionale um.
Wir haben ja Bad Banks Wir haben ja diese Banken sehr Bad Banks die nicht schlecht ist,
die vor allem toll besetzt ist und ich glaube dass gerade diese ganzen Dinge hier was wir jetzt hier schon alles gehört haben wirklich wie du sagst das ideale Drehbuch zu einem großartigen Film ergeben würden.
Und das Problem ist dass die sich gar nicht so dran trauen.
Also jemand wie Adam McKay in den USA der würde sowas vielleicht fertigbringen das zu machen.
Doch diese ganze Absurdität und wir haben es ja auch hier mit Eitelkeiten zu tun alle auf die Leinwand zu packen naja also Voßkuhle ist ja jetzt niemand der einfach sagte Ich,
bin da mal an einer juristischen Sache dran sondern da geht es ja auch darum sich zu produzieren und man ist verletzt wenn man weniger Kompetenz hat als die in der EU.
Und das wäre eigentlich ganz hervorragend.
Zudem dann auch glaube ich eine gewisse Ahnungslosigkeit vieler Politiker die man sehr gut ausstellen könnte denn ich glaube das wären auch mal schöne fragen wie man so auf dem Gang des Reichstags darstellen könnte.
Wer weiß eigentlich gerade wie das so funktioniert mit den Staatsanleihenkäufe oder so.. Naja.
Damals war was ein Brause Eitelkeiten das ist vielleicht supertoll Sandoval zu sagen Das mit den Eitelkeiten.
Das hätte man durchaus in zahlreichen Clips darstellen können wie Voßkuhle hier ein richtiges Eitelkeit Statement.
Kurz vor Ende seiner zwölfjährigen Amtszeit noch einmal macht er sich in mehreren Urteilen herumgeschlagen hat mit der Kompetenz des EuGH.
Und jetzt so richtig stolz verkündet hat zum ersten Mal kommt mein Gericht zur Ansicht dass und so weiter. Da steckt das absolut drin.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen die lesen Sie das Spielen soll die sie richtig darauf freuen dass das so darzustellen ist eine sehr einladende Rolle für den einen oder anderen Naja jetzt wandert dieses ganze Thema in den Bundestag.
Denn der ist aufgerufen worden wie wir gerade gehört haben.
Erklären Sie uns doch mal oder holen Sie sich Erklärungen ein damit sie die öffentlichkeit erklären können was die EZB da so treibt.
Und Carsten Schneider von der SPD die Seeheimer spielt aber jetzt nicht ganz so eine große Rolle.
Hat hier ein Punkt gemacht wo ich mich wieder Frage Kann man kann man die Diskussion wirklich so dämlich weiterführen.
Wenn ich mir das Urteil genau so wie es hier referiert hat ist der Einsatz ganz klar Es gibt keine verbotene monetäre Staatsfinanzierung die gibt es nicht. Es gibt keine monetäre Staatsfinanzierung sondern das was.
Es hat sich herausgestellt dass sie das Verfassungsgericht unseres das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat Es gibt keine verbotene monetäre Staatsfinanzierung das ist ja dieses,
Wirkliche Mandat überschreiten das nämlich die EZB tatsächlich einfach dem Bundesfinanzminister hundert Milliarden überweist und er dann damit eine Arbeitslosenversicherung in Coruña Zeiten bezahlt oder so sondern es hat ja über Bande gespielt.
Scholz braucht Geld. Wie soll man da noch gleich Steuern erhöhen. Es war ja total Banane. Ich gehe mal hier in die Verschuldung.
Dann muss er Staatsanleihen ausschreiben kriegt dann für jede Staatsanleihe sehe ich 1000 Euro brauche ich dafür einen Käufer und der Käufer darf nicht die Zentralbank sein sondern das muss nochmal ein richtiger Marktteilnehmer sein,
der allerdings weiß natürlich dass die EZB solche Ankaufprogramm hat und dass er seine Staatsanleihe immer für den Preis für den er sie gekauft hat weitergeben kann er die EZB,
also die Staatsanleihe fungiert selbst wie Bargeld ist abgesichert wie Bargeld durch diese Programme gleichzeitig.
Dadurch bekommt Scholz auf jeden Fall Geld vom Markt.
Das ist das eine das zweite ist Scholz muss auch keine besonders hohen Zinsen draufschreiben weil er ja weiß dass ist auch geregelt.
Es ist sozusagen Staatsfinanzierung auf zweifacher Ebene sowohl Weißmann diese Staatsanleihen auf jeden Fall Bargeld.
Und sie kostet mich nichts sondern ich kann selbst 30 jährige Staatsanleihen.
Die Bundesbank kann gerade 30 jährige Staatsanleihen für Minuszinsen ausschreiben Sie muss dann weniger Geld zurückgeben als sie eingenommen hat und dass das keine Staatsfinanzierung sein soll.
Das ist wirklich auch so eine Verlogenheit die da mitschwingt. Da kann ja Carsten Schneider jetzt gerne sagen hat es Voßkuhle gesagt.
Aber da muss man dann auch mal so ehrlich sein und sagen es ist halt Staatsfinanzierung vielleicht keine verbotene aber es ist Staatsfinanzierung.
Und das kann man ja bei Flassbeck und vielen anderen auch nachlesen.
Das ist eine Sache die ist nicht kleinzureden.
Da kann man doch nicht sagen dass es irgendwie billige EU-Kritik oder so sondern das ist einfach ein Konstrukt das man sich geschaffen hat weil man es nicht drinstehen hat dass man das machen darf.
Man könnte auch sagen Gut wir sagen jetzt die EZB soll monetäre Staatsfinanzierung machen das darf sie ab jetzt dann brauchen wir dieses Konstrukt nicht mehr.
Könnte vielleicht sogar besser sein. Also kann man sich überlegen denn wir haben natürlich zumindest nach der letzten Finanzkrise das ja erlebt dass das auch,
immer sehr gut für die Märkte ist aber nicht unbedingt für sinnvolle Märkte und Realwirtschaftlich ist das dann eben auch nicht so ertragreich.
Wir haben ja den Dax nach oben schießen sehen aber bei uns im Portemonnaie war das nicht so rosig.
Das heißt da wäre jetzt darüber nachzudenken nur das große Problem ist ja auch hier da wären ja dann auch wieder die Konservativen schon mal gar nicht bereit.
Dann wäre Herr Gauweiler Man weiß gar nicht was dann passieren würde wenn man das wirklich sagen würde Okay dann ändern wir das insofern als die EZB dann tatsächlich.
Ja genau da schwingt einfach noch so eine Lebenslüge mit angetrieben von der Angst vor den Konservativen dass sie das nicht mal ihren Wählern erklären können und deswegen niemals in Angriff nehmen weil so eine Vertragsänderung natürlich dringend nötig.
Wir brauchen jetzt eine europäische Wirtschaftspolitik in der natürlich die EZB als Finanzier für wenn es mal knapp wird eine Rolle spielt.
Aber jetzt einfach zu sagen Es ist keine Staatsfinanzierung und warum jetzt nicht ökonomisch argumentiert sondern weil der Verfassungsgerichtshof gesagt hat ist es nicht und deswegen gilt das jetzt da lügt man sich halt wirklich in die Tasche.
Da fragt man sich ein bisschen Carsten Schneider wenn er solche Sachen sagt woher weißt du das denn wie ist denn jetzt so der Zusammenhang mit der EZB. Und den stellt er auch nochmal dar.
Ich verstehe so langsam warum der Voßkuhle das Urteil dann doch ein bisschen härter gemacht hat damit der Bundestag auch mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt was er da eigentlich tut.
Weil wie Carsten Schneider hier darüber redet wie er sich informiert was die EZB tut.
Oder dort vielleicht nochmal instruktiv tätig wird was er ja durchaus machen kann. Es ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Ich habe mich mehrfach in der letzten Legislatur und viele andere Kollegen auch mit Mitgliedern,
der Europäischen Zentralbank getroffen und ihre Maßnahmen Herrn Choreo Frau Lautenschläger die Maßnahmen im Vorfeld besprochen erläutern lassen deutsche Positionen eingebracht die der Sozialdemokratie,
in den Entscheidungsprozess wie auch bei uns eingebracht hat vielleicht nicht formell stattgefunden.
Vielleicht ist das der Punkt an dem wir noch angebissen sondern informelle und informelle Gespräche.
Ja Herr Carsten Schneider Vielleicht ist es falsch über die 2 Billionen Anleihenkäufe die so nötig sind,
für unser aller ökonomisches und überhaupt Schicksal nicht nur beim Kaffeeklatsch informell zu sprechen sondern da ich meinen Tagesordnungspunkt zuerwarten.
Also redet hier so der Bürgermeister der sagt wie er mit dem Bürgerverein geregelt hat wer dieses Jahr die Kirmes bezahlt. Sitzung Knopfes.
Und hier erkennt man jetzt auch so langsam das Problem das Problem ist nicht die EZB die erklärt in Pressekonferenzen die Ameisenbär schon gesehen in Langen Ausarbeitungen in wissenschaftlicher Begleitung und so weiter erklärt die was sie tut.
Man kann das Wort jetzt häufiger gesagt in Hunderten Tausenden PDFs auf der Seite und in vielen Büchern nachlesen was die EZB macht.
Dass der Bundestag daneben steht und denkt die machen das schon ist ja alles ganz locker und die Zinsersparnis für uns finde ich auch gut Jordaan rufe ich morgen nochmal an und mache so ein informelles Ding draus.
Und bringen auch noch ein paar Gedanken der Sozialdemokratie mit ein.
Genau. Vielleicht hätte Voßkuhle diesen Satz nicht allzu verschachtelt machen sollen vorhin er wirklich klar sagen was er meinte nämlich lieber Bundestag.
So wie ihr das handhabt geht das nicht.
Die EZB gibt sich jede Mühe euch zu informieren. Bitte laden wenigstens die PDF runter veranschlagten Tagesordnungspunkt im Ausschuss für Sohn.
Damit das mal formal abgehandelt habt ihr darüber informiert seid was da stattfindet und dann auch mal ein Rückkanal aufgebaut hat.
Da steht ja einfach da und sagt Ich hab da schonmal mit denen und denen hinter die Namen weil das nochmal unterstreicht wie wichtig das in seinem Terminkalender war.
Ich habe mir hier wirklich mit einem Bundestag zu tun bei dem man sich fragt. Leider ruht er nicht euch zu sehr auf.
Erstens Die EZB regelt das schon. Zweitens Die Zinsen sind niedrig Wir müssen hier gar nichts machen und wir sind ja eh das Powerhouse in Europa.
Also wie gesagt Ja da hätte Voßkuhle vielleicht mehr auf Bundestag einschlagen sollen statt auf den EuGH nur weil er da auch noch so neben Schauspiel Platz aus Eitelkeiten seinerseits hat.
Naja der AfD d.h. der AfD hat das Anberaumen im Bundestag eine Stunde darüber zu sprechen hätten wahrscheinlich die anderen Parteien auch mit die Melzers,
stellt ja nochmal das Problem da ich habe nur nochmal sozusagen weil die Zahl genannt wird ganz gut im Verhältnis zu diesen zur Herangehensweise von Carsten Schneider.
Wenn wir aber noch einmal fünf Jahre warten bis es dann das sichere Urteil zur Verfassungswidrigkeit von Pepp geben wird dann wird beim aktuellen Ankauf Tempo der EZB,
bis 2025 ein Schadenspotenzial von sieben Billionen Euro entstanden sein.
Das Schadenspotenzial sagt ist natürlich eine Meinung Wir sind hier der Meinung dass es absolut notwendig ist das zu finanzieren weil warum sollte man jetzt noch mal,
griechische Krankenhäuser ausquetschen und die Flughäfen nach China verkaufen wenn man Geld braucht wo das Geld zur Verfügung stellen kann.
Aber man sollte das dann doch jetzt mal formalisieren ein Tagesordnungspunkt im Tagesablauf des Bundestages.
Damit das nicht informell läuft. Denn die sieben Billionen werden ja kommen wenn man das hochrechnet auf die nächsten Jahre und jetzt sind zwei Milliarden zwei Billionen durch fünf Billionen offen.
Da kann man ja mal ein bisschen juristisch auf sicherem Grund das regeln ohne inhaltlich viel anders zu machen.
Aber genau davor haben sie Angst das haben wir hier an Fabio de Masi von den Linken angenommen.
Der Bundestag setzt jetzt auf seine Tagesordnung. Da sitzen ja nicht nur SPD und CDU und sagen es ist egal.
Ja wir haben mal formell ab was die EZB hier macht sondern man könnte ja durchaus doch noch ein paar inhaltliche Ansprüche auch mal zumindest in der Diskussion nennen und davor haben die Regierungsparteien Angst.
Die Linke begrüßt wenn die Zentralbank von Parlamenten kontrolliert und auch die Geldpolitik demokratisch in der öffentlichkeit diskutiert wird.
Wir fordern seit Jahren dass die EZB auch für Wachstum und Beschäftigung Verantwortung Verantwortung.
Die EZB soll Verantwortung für Wachstum und Beschäftigung übernehmen.
Da gefriert natürlich die Peter Gauweiler zur Hölle weil das wäre natürlich völlig Banane.
Das wäre jetzt irgendwie für italienisches Wachstum und Beschäftigung zuständig sind mit unserem Einlagen mit unserem Geld ja mit unserem Know how und was auch immer wir ins Spiel einbringen können.
Also hat Deutschland das alles vermieden weshalb wir jetzt Franziska Brantner in einem absoluten super Clip hören.
Sie stellt jetzt die Probleme dar wie sie sich heute im Mai 2000 durch Voßkuhle und Gauweiler und so weiter darstellen.
Und selten habe ich so schön von diesem Knoten der dann irgendwann mal platzen muss.
Selten wurde so gut dieser große gordischen Knoten mal inhaltlich genannt.
Wir haben noch einmal bekräftigt bekommen dass das Auslagern der Krisenbewältigung an die Europäische Zentralbank brandgefährlich ist.
Wir sind jetzt in einer Situation in der Karlsruhe die geldpolitischen Notmaßnahmen beschränkt und in Berlin die fiskalischen Notmaßnahmen beschränkt.
Diese doppelte Packung ist für den Euro brandgefährlich.
Brandgefährlich. Zündelt nicht nur eine Zündschnur sondern die Bombe selbst ist schon langsam explodieren wenn nach Jahren und Jahren und wir reden hier von zehn Jahren 11 Jahren jetzt mit Schäuble und Scholz,
keine gemeinsame europäische Verschuldung keine koordinierte und erst recht keine gemeinsame Wirtschaftspolitik möglich ist also wenn der politische Weg komplett blockiert wird.
Und jetzt kommt es Verfassungsgerichtshof der deutsche Verfassungsgerichtshof und sagt auch noch die geldpolitischen Maßnahmen der EZB werden jetzt genauso noch Weg blockiert.
Dann kann man es wirklich einfach sein lassen mit dem Euro dann hat das alles keinen Sinn.
Dann haben wir es mit immer weiter klaffenden Unterschieden zu tun die nicht mehr eingefangen werden können dadurch dass die Länder einfach eigene Wirtschaftspolitik und Geldpolitik machen sondern sie sind einfach der Geldpolitik unterworfen die komplett blockiert wird,
und dann bringt das dann sind alle im Euro Verlierer außer halt,
Niederlande Belgien Dänemark Deutschland und Schweden. Dann ist einfach Sense.
Was mich aber gerade noch die Bürger Perspektive einbringen,
es bräuchte ja eigentlich jetzt eine Innen Wirtschafts Unterricht in ganz Europa und besonders in Deutschland,
um überhaupt zu erklären wie das ganze Konstrukt funktioniert welche Vorteile das für uns ja durchaus hat es ist ja keineswegs so dass wir,
nur weil wir eine starke Wirtschaftsleistung haben jetzt allen anderen permanent Geld zustecken sondern wir profitieren gerade durch unsere Exporte auch sehr gut davon,
wenn es anderen nicht so prima geht wenn die nicht so gesunde Wirtschaften haben und das alles aufzudröseln zu zeigen wie die EZB eigentlich funktioniert.
Über Sinn und Unsinn der Staatsanleihen zu diskutieren also da wirklich einen öffentlichen Diskurs zu haben ist das denkbar ist das möglich wir haben es beim Klimawandel.
Daran muss ich gerade denken so dass wir eine gewisse Verwissenschaftlichung der Debatte haben durch sein TIS vor Futuro durch,
for Future das also durchaus jetzt Menschen sich informieren dass auch in Fernsehberichten sehen in Zeitungen lesen einfach mal über wissenschaftliche Fakten Untersuchungen zum Klimawandel,
da gibt es ganz diverse,
Geschichten die man sich aneignen kann.
Angefangen von der von der Biene und ihrer Funktionen der Natur bis hin zu Geo-Engineering und was weiß ich alles,
wäre das denkbar dass man so etwas Sciences vor Future mäßiges auch hinbekommt auf einer wirtschaftlichen Ebene,
wäre das überhaupt denkbar dass man eine.
Informationslage schafft auf der dann wirklich auch vernünftig argumentiert werden kann,
denn hier kann man ja davon ausgehen wird es am Ende umschlagen in eine nationalistische Argumentation oder und das ist zwar,
im Resultat besser aber nicht viel klüger.
Einfach so ein abgefeimte der EU und wir sind alle eins und blablabla.
Die Leute die das alle sagen die wissen ja auch nicht wie eine Staatsanleihe funktioniert und was die EZB eigentlich.
Es ist. Es mangelt nicht an Wissen es Grundlage.
Ich finde es sogar inhaltlich so interessant. Es ist ja nicht mal so dass man jetzt mit Problemen zu tun hat die wahnsinnig kompliziert sind sondern man kann ja auch,
sagen wir mal so Geld ist super kompliziert wenn man so ich hab ein kleines Einkommen und ich will mir etwas kaufen dann ist es super kompliziert aber wenn man so im großen Maßstab die zwei Billionen der EZB.
Da wird es ja doch relativ übersichtlich sag mal so da kann man ja im Panorama drüber fliegen und es wunderbar erklären.
Es gibt ja durchaus auf Deutsch. Ich habe zum Beispiel Gunnar Heinsohn und Otto Steiger Eigentum Zins und Geld das ist ein Buch bei dem er jetzt Amazon sagt Das hab ich im Oktober 2009 gekauft.
Also das ist schon über 100 Jahre in meinem Schrank und es gibt es seit 2006 zumindest die vierte Auflage also ein bisschen älter.
Dann gibt es Thomas Strobl Ohne Schulden läuft nichts. Wo nochmal. Wunderbar erklärt wird wie das so funktioniert mit dem Geld.
Dann sehen wir natürlich auf Twitter wie sich ökonomen darüber lustig machen dass sie sagen Gestern z.B.
Ah die Virologen streiten sich. Ich dachte es wäre eine Spezialität unserer Wirtschaftswissenschaften.
Wir haben natürlich mit einer empirischen Grundlage zu tun die ein bisschen streitbarer ist als selbst in der Biologie wo man ja eigentlich das Virus vor sich unter dem Mikroskop liegen hat und sich dann trotzdem noch darüber streitet was es bedeutet Innensicht.
Zweischneidige Sache ja als Unterrichtsmaterial sollte man auf jeden Fall mal so in die Bücher reinschauen. Heinsohn Gunnar Heinsohn oder Thomas Strobl.
Allerdings ist die politische Diskussion natürlich besonders vergiftet weil Geld ist das was uns allen am liebsten ist.
Gauweiler Das muss dann individuell partikulare geschützt werden.
Und selbst wenn die EZB die ganze Welt rettet und es kostet vielleicht ein paar Anlage Zinsen die man jetzt nicht mehr einfährt dann ist das schon ein Grund da,
zu zündeln und es ist natürlich für so eine Diskussion nicht besonders gut da wird es immer gleich so ins brennendem gerät aber irgendwie muss dieser Wandel Ich bin ja wirklich Wir kommen gleich nochmal auf.
Hans-Werner Sinn hat sich jetzt verabschiedet in Rente und wir haben plötzlich diesen Jens.
Ich lese gleich nochmal ein paar Zitate vor das ist ja wirklich. Da geht mir das Herz auf wenn man plötzlich solche Typen sieht die auch einfach mal mit klarer Haltung in diese Diskussion reingehen.
Doch ein Wandel in dieser Bundestagsdebatte wollen natürlich jetzt auch nochmal da könnten.
Vielleicht könnte man den Spieß jetzt mal umdrehen und die EZB die den Voßkuhle Als Verfassungsgerichtspräsident fragen Herr Voßkuhle.
Haben Sie eigentlich die Nebenfolgen von ihrem Urteil bedacht oder sind sie da genauso im Blindflug wie die EZB mit ihren Nebenfolgen die Sie hier kritisieren.
Denn diese Franziska Brantner von den Grünen hat wirklich sensationell nochmal im Bundestag angemerkt.
Ich möchte zum Beispiel dass das Außenministerium das der Außenminister seinen Puhl seinen polnischen Kollegen sehr klar macht recht staatsfeindlicher ist durch dieses Urteil nicht gedeckt.
Gestern habe ich diese Reaktion aus dem Auswärtigen Amt leider vermisst.
Das ist natürlich eine Bankrotterklärung. Wenn wir in Bundesverfassungsgericht Urteil zu Europa haben bei dem wir dann unseren Außenminister losschicken müssen damit er die anderen mal davor warnt dem Bundesverfassungsgericht nachzueifern,
weil wir die Gefahren ja durchaus sehen.
Das ist wirklich so haarsträubend. Von der Leyen erwägt ja nun auch ein Vertragsverletzungsverfahren um mal die Rechtsstaatlichkeit des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zu überprüfen.
Dürfen die sich eigentlich einfach so die Kompetenz zuschreiben indem sie sagen die einen ja willkürlicher darf das Bundesverfassungsgericht dem Europäischen Gerichtshof Wirklichkeit bei seiner Entscheidung vorwerfen.
Und da hat Reinhard Müller in der FAZ nochmal gefragt.
Am Ende müsste der EuGH über dieses Vertragsverletzungsverfahren entscheiden also der vom nicht von unserem dazu kritisiert wird.
Und es ist wohl kaum zu erwarten dass er zu dem Schluss kommt Deutschland habe sich Europa rechtskonform verhalten.
Oder dann sagt Peter Huber der das Urteil zu verantworten hat.
Ich wünsche es mir ich würde es mir wünschen aber es ist wohl nicht sehr realistisch.
Er ist selber in der Erwartung dass falls man dieses Vertragsverletzungsverfahren wirklich durch paukt und am Ende weil Deutschland dem dann widersprechen würde was Resultat ist,
dürfte Deutschland dagegen klagen würde der EuGH sagen Deutschland hat sich sein Verfassungsgericht hat sich nicht Europa rechtskonform verhalten.
Peter Huber nur noch sagen wird wahrscheinlich so kommen auch wenn ich es mir anders wünsche.
Das ist so wie wenn wir dem Bundestag immer vorwerfen dass dort Verfassungsrechts widrige Gesetze wohl wissend dass es so ist verabschiedet werden.
Es dreht sich mittlerweile alles ist völlig Banane. Wie irre es ist der Stefan Haber der neue Verfassungsrechts Präsidenten.
Hat er jetzt auch sein erstes Urteil gesprochen zum BND Urteil zum BND Gesetz dürfen die ausländische im Ausland Journalisten überwachen und hat gesagt nee hier überschreitet der Bundestag seine Kompetenzen dieses Gesetz war verfassungswidrig.
Stellt sich raus. Er war ja 2016 als das Gesetz verabschiedet wurde selbst nach Bundestags Mitglied und hat auch für dieses Gesetz gestimmt.
Er hat sozusagen sich selbst widersprochen mittlerweile aber das auf so vielen Ebenen so verdreht dass es wirklich so.
Jetzt müssen wir mal dieses Durcheinander. Was ist das für ein Durcheinander.
Olaf Scholz der Bundesfinanzminister der nun dieses Geld einnimmt was die Bundesbank Ihnen da durch Anleihekäufe beschafft hält von diesem Urteil absolut gar nichts.
Es war wirklich auch ein bisschen eine Freude zu sehen wie er seine. Ich halte davon gar nichts. In Tagesthemen verteidigt.
Das Gericht sagt die EZB hat viel Geld. Wir reden hier von 2,6 Billionen also 2600 Milliarden Euro.
Dieses Geld hat die EZB ausgegeben nur um die Euro-Zone zu retten.
Was daraus für die Sparer die Unternehmen und die AktionärInnen folgte war erst mal ziemlich egal. Sehen Sie das auch so.
So habe ich das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts nicht verstanden das hat erst einmal klargestellt dass das was die EZB gemacht hat wie übrigens die anderen Zentralbanken in der Welt auch keine monetäre Staatsfinanzierung ist.
Und Sie haben gesagt dass es aber notwendig ist wenn man solche Entscheidungen trifft sie sehr sorgfältig zu begründen und einen Zeitraum eingeräumt in denen diese Dinge geschehen können.
Das ist etwas mit dem man umgehen kann. Wir haben das ja auch heute gemerkt Es ist niemand beunruhigt gewesen nach dieser Entscheidung und wir werden das jetzt nicht nur sorgfältig lesen das Urteil Wir haben das ja schon,
mehrfach heute getan sondern wir werden natürlich auch dafür sorgen dass entsprechend dieser sehr überschaubaren Vorgaben gehandelt werden kann.
Meines Erachtens hat das Gericht diese Mahnung sehr wohl ausgesprochen. Es hat auch gerügt dass die Bundesregierung Sie persönlich die Verhältnismäßigkeit nicht kontrolliert haben also auch ihnen der Sparer und Kleinanleger egal war.
Beides ist nicht gesagt worden. Richtig ist dass die Bundesregierung genauso wie der Deutsche Bundestag eine Verpflichtung haben die übrigens immer existiert genau hinzuschauen was europäische Institutionen machen und dann daraus die notwendigen Schlüsse abzuleiten.
Und der Wunsch des Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist hier sehr klar.
Sie sagen es ist solche Entscheidungen getroffen werden die möglich sind und die nicht im Prinzip zu beanstanden sind.
Notwendig dass man sehr genau versteht dass alles bedacht ist Welche Konsequenzen hat das z.B. für Immobilienmärkte in Europa.
Welche konkreten Konsequenzen hat das für Staatsfinanzierung. Welche konkreten Konsequenzen hat das für Spareinlagen und was ist daraus zu bedenken.
Das Gericht ist nicht der überzeugung dass es jetzt selbst oder irgendein anderes Gericht sagen muss Das ist richtig und das ist falsch sondern es möchte gerne verstehen dass all diese Dinge in den Entscheidungen eine Rolle gespielt haben und wohl bedacht sind.
Ich glaube das ist in einem demokratischen Gesellschaft auch kein vertretbares ansehen.
Also komplett runter auf Yak. Kleine Hausaufgabe.
Total. Er hat den Satz vielleicht einfach nicht gelesen nicht verstanden. Man weiß es nicht genau.
Eine kleine Hausaufgabe aber es ist schon erstaunlich dass er auch nochmal sagt auch wenn übrigens aller Welt das keine monetäre Staatsfinanzierung stattfindet durch Zentralbanken meint er da kannst du dir das erklären.
Die anderen Notenbanken.
Er sagt Da findet das auch nicht statt,
aber die machen das ja.
Ja aber es ist wie bei Carsten Schneider Wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt irgendwo in dem Urteil Es ist keine verbotene monetäre Staatsfinanzierung dann ist das so dann ist das ein unfehlbare Satz.
Dann gilt der egal ob Deutschland jetzt Hunderte Milliarden durch Zinsersparnis darüber nicht ausgeben musste oder indem sie eine einbehalten hat oder nicht. Es ist halt einfach kein.
Ich meine da muss man ja nun mal an den Satz erinnern Wir hatten ihn schon mal hier im Podcast We print the money.
Das ist aber auch etwas wo man wieder sagen muss Da ist vielleicht einfach gar nicht noch viel weniger Wissenschaft dabei als jetzt.
Oder mehr vielmehr Ideologie dabei viel vielmehr Glaubensfragen sind dabei entscheidend.
Als jetzt bei den Virologen also Virologen streiten sich ja bin ich das jetzt gerade richtig überblicke über verschiedene methodische Ansätze.
Erhebungen von Infizierten zahlen welche Maßnahmen werden besser soll man mal mehr Tests machen weniger Tests machen.
Was weiß ich eher lokaler Vorgehen eher in Ländern denken was auch immer.
Und man hat es aber hier tatsächlich mit so Glaubensfragen zu tun dass es jetzt bei Scholz ganz deutlich zu,
spüren dass er eigentlich sagt Nein ich glaube nicht daran dass das so sein kann dass die Notenbanken Geld drucken um dem Staat Geld zu geben,
und die moderne Monetary Theory und nicht nur die sagt Natürlich funktioniert das.
Das macht dann natürlich aus einer gewissen Notwendigkeit heraus denn all das was wir jetzt besprochen haben findet ja in einer echten Weltstadt in der es echte Probleme gibt es,
echte Wendung gibt weshalb wir den dritten Akt kommen nämlich die unerwartete Wende die nun wirklich alles auf den Kopf stellt.
Und wir fragen uns warum Scholz dieses Urteil so runter.
Wurde doch beauftragt im Zweifel in drei Monaten fünf Milliarden zurückzahlen zu müssen die er nicht hat.
Also so viel Steuererhöhung wäre gar nicht möglich. Gerade jetzt nicht.
Warum. Warum wendet sich Scholz hier schon bestimmt aber sehr deutlich zurückhaltender sehr deutlich gegen dieses Urteil. Stellt sich raus.
Ja klar weil die Realität drückt würden wir hier eine zeitlich passende Meldung so eine Stunde vor Mitternacht noch Weeke meldet bei Deutschlandfunk Das war der Tag.
Die heutigen Nachrichten zu den Steuereinnahmen die können eigentlich niemanden mehr wirklich überraschen und auch die Dimension war ja weitgehend klar.
Also knapp 1000 Milliarden das ist Stand heute wird den deutschen Steuerbehörden werden den deutschen Steuerbehörden fehlen das ist viel keine Frage,
aber man muss es richtig einordnen das sind drei Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung insgesamt und etwas mehr als zehn Prozent der Steuereinnahmen das ist viel.
Aber viele Unternehmer müssen im Moment mit weniger als minus zehn auskommen.
Es ist tatsächlich so irre dass nach zwölf Jahren Amtszeit Voßkuhle in der die letzte Gelegenheit nimmt und es ist ein Zufall dass es jetzt Mai 2020 trifft um hier noch einmal seiner Eitelkeit.
Ich lasse ihm nicht alles durchgehen und als Thema liegt diese Entscheidung da.
Dass sie zusammenfällt mit NEE auch Scholz braucht jetzt Geld. Da ist jetzt auf diese Verschuldung angewiesen.
Da kann jetzt nicht einfach von diesem Programm Abstand nehmen. Auch wenn er der deutsche Finanzminister ist.
Er braucht jetzt Geld und er stellt hier in den Tagestief wieder eindeutig klar Steuererhöhung gibt's nicht und bleibt dann im Grunde nur eine zweite Möglichkeit.
Die Zahl die das Loch nun in etwa bemerkbar macht ist dann doch beeindruckend ein Rückgang von ein und achtzig komma fünf Milliarden Euro in diesem Jahr gegenüber 2019,
sagt die Frühjahrs Steuerschätzung voraus die Finanzminister Olaf Scholz heute vorstellte.
Können wir ein Minus von so vielen Milliarden einfach so wegstecken können wir.
Darauf haben wir uns ja auch gut vorbereitet in den letzten Jahren als wir die.
Wir haben uns gar nicht vorbereitet Die EZB hat uns den Arsch gerettet Bisher hat ein Programm entwickelt Herr Finanzminister eine.
Nee das wurde jetzt ja nochmal gesagt. Ich habe das gesehen.
Du weißt es hat noch jemand gerade einen Podcast begonnen und sein ehemaliger Sprecher der die Agenda 2010 verkauft hat.
Also es geht um Gerhard Schröders Ja und da hat er nochmal gesagt der jetzt mit ihm den Podcast zusammen.
Béla Anda Gerd Schröder.
Und man sieht ja gerade wie gut die Agenda 2010 war denn die ermöglicht uns ja jetzt dass wir überhaupt diese Ausgaben gerade machen können.
Also wir waren als Deutsche wieder ganz fleißig am Sparen. Und deswegen kommen wir jetzt auch so gut durch die Krise.
Das ist unglaublich. Das ist absolute Verlogenheit Das ist eine richtige Lebenslüge. Sowas begegnet einem wirklich nur selten. Aber das ist eine richtig liegen.
Wir haben 2008. Müssen wir jetzt sagen zum Glück ne Finanzkrise gehabt bei der die EZB schon mal erprobt und ausgetestet hat was zur Verfügung steht um eine Krise abzuwenden.
Und jetzt haben wir 2020 eine Krise die zehnmal so groß ist wie die Finanzkrise 2008.
Und zum Glück hat sich die EZB gewagt etwas Unerhörtes zu tun nämlich Billionen und Billionen zu schaffen und das Geld zu vermehren damit das Geld weiter fließen kann,
und dass jetzt die Deutschen kommen und sagen Wir sind ja gut drauf vorbereitet gar nichts haben die Deutschen gemacht.
Aber Olaf Scholz ist hier also Olaf Scholz ist wie zum Kuckuck.
Der setzt sich jetzt in ein gemachtes Nest. Das hat er selber aber nicht gemacht.
Er wird nämlich jetzt wir eine ganz vehement gegen Steuererhöhung argumentieren,
und das gelingt ihm überhaupt nur weil er weiß wie dieses Verschuldung funktioniert und es hat die EZB gegen den deutschen Widerstand eingeführt dieses Prinzip was er jetzt hier für sich nutzen möchte.
Wir hören jetzt was ganz ganz ganz verlogenes.
Staatsverschuldung so verändert haben dass wir nur noch weniger als 60 Prozent unserer Wirtschaftsleistung als Schulden hatten.
Das ist etwas was wir lange angestrebt haben und was uns genau bevor es losging mit dieser Krise gelungen war.
Und damit haben wir jetzt auch die Grundlage um eine solche große Herausforderung zu bestehen.
Wir werden wenn jetzt die Phase des lock down allmählich ausläuft jedenfalls in weiten Bereichen ab Anfang Juni auch ein Konjunkturprogramm auf den Weg bringen müssen damit wir Wirtschaft und Beschäftigung so schnell wie möglich wieder voranbringen.
Das klingt ein bisschen paradox. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel ein plötzliches Loch in der Haushaltskasse hätte dann schiebe ich bestimmte Ausgaben erst einmal auf.
Aber sie haben weniger Einnahmen und wollen trotzdem ab Juni nochmal kräftig Milliarden aufnehmen und ausgeben.
Genau das ist auch das Richtige. Alle die sich mit wirtschaftlichen Sachverhalten auskennen wissen dass man gegen eine Krise nicht ansparen kann sondern wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die.
Ich habe ich immer anders gehört als 2008 die Griechen die Italiener die Spanier sollten die nicht komplett ansparen gegen diese Krise.
Volkswirtschaft schnell wieder wächst dass Arbeitsplätze gesichert werden dass sie wieder Neueinstellungen stattfinden und alles das kann nicht gelingen wenn gewissermaßen alle nur noch vorsichtig bleiben Wir sind vorsichtig bei unserer Haushaltspolitik.
Aber gerade deshalb können wir jetzt auch das tun was man in einer Krise macht nämlich gegenhalten.
Mich interessiert wie sie das finanzieren würden habe ich Sie richtig verstanden keine Steuererhöhungen weder Vermögenssteuer noch irgendwas anderes,
als das mit der Krise losging einen sehr klaren Beschluss im Deutschen Bundestag gefasst,
nämlich eine Ausnahmeregel von der Schulden Begrenzung in unserem Grundgesetz in Anspruch zu nehmen haben 156 Milliarden Euro zusätzliche Kredit Ermächtigung uns vom Bundestag gewähren lassen damit wir jetzt zu handeln.
Das ist ja wirklich ganz erstaunlich aber auch von Seiten des Moderators.
Also man könnte ja mal ganz dieser Moderne Monetary Schiene auch in der Moderation fahren und sagen Wir drehen das mal um.
Also wäre das nicht schon immer viel wichtiger gewesen genau darauf hinzuweisen auf das was man gerade macht und hätte das nicht auch schon,
2008 doch die Luft aus vielen Debatten herausgenommen und müsste man nicht sagen dass die schwäbische Hausfrau immer schon idiotisch war.
Das wurde ja von Merkel 2008 eingeführt im übrigen ja in Stuttgart hat sie ja sich ganz deutlich darauf bezogen und hat gesagt Jahre Finanzkrise wenn man sich das ansieht,
hätte man nur mal die Regeln der schwäbischen Hausfrau hätte man die einmal beherzigt dann wäre es zu so einer Krise gar nicht gekommen.
Da war man schon dabei aus der Finanzkrise in der Schuldenkrise zu machen und es ist eigentlich unglaublich dass das jetzt auch seitens der Journalisten immer noch nicht so durchgesickert ist.
Vor allem deine Empfehlung ist genau richtig.
Warum sagt Ingo Zamperoni nicht einfach sie gehen jetzt 2020 voll ins Risiko mit Schulden und wollen gar keine Steuererhöhung.
Wieso haben wir denn nach 2008 nicht komplett die Unis durchfinanziert Wieso haben wir uns denn diesen prekären Nachwuchs Arbeitsmarkt da geleistet.
Wir hätten doch genauso gut 15 Milliarden Steuerschulden rein packen können,
das wäre doch gar nicht aufgefallen die Null stünden doch nur bei der EZB seit 2008 und 80 Milliarden sondern 2000 15 oder so.
Das hätte man doch alles machen können. Herr Scholz Das ist genau wer genau die richtige Frage gewesen.
Naja aber wir sehen zumindest schon mal den kleinen Wandel hin zu.
Wir werden jetzt keine falsche Vorsicht haben da wir ja auch ein kleiner Kulturpark sind hören wir uns doch noch mal Draghi an wir im Bundespräsidialamt ist im Schloss,
Bellevue und dort an seinen Vater erinnert der sich für deutsche Kultur interessierte und ein Götte Spruch irgendwo fand.
Berlin,
mein Vater Kus German values,
ändert an Twitpic in Italy Thomé Abarten Monument Germany,
Rippchen Attribute Götte,
Gut verloren etwas verloren musst dich rasch besinnen und Neues gewinnen,
Ehre verloren viel verloren musst Ruhm gewinnen,
da werden die Leute sich anders besinnen Myth verloren alles verloren da wäre es besser nicht geboren.
Aus Marnie Lost in.
Losmarschieren You can Genie Trouvé Roy viel los chorisch.
Sehr sehr gut auch schön interpretiert.
Ganz perfekt platziert. Ganz wunderbar platziert dort als Italiener auf Englisch und dann plötzlich ins Deutsche wechseln um das vorzutragen.
Ja man muss jetzt ins Risiko gehen und das war die Veranstaltung,
bei der Steinmeier Unser Bundespräsident auf Draghis Lebenswerk sozusagen schaut das Finale Stück in der EZB Chefetage und sagte Herr Draghi Sie haben es richtig gemacht.
Sie haben die Eurozone nicht erodieren lassen und wir haben noch ein Europa mit dem wir jetzt arbeiten können.
Gleichzeitig saß allerdings auch Angela Merkel in der ersten Reihe und als Brückenschlag hat Draghis Sie können unendlich lange über Geld reden.
Sie können den Herrn Gauweiler zur EZB zum Bundesverfassungsgericht schicken und da kann ihn irgendwas mit Geld argumentieren wenn sie ein bisschen Geld verlieren.
Sie haben nichts verloren das kriegen sie alles wieder ganz einfach herstellen wenn sie ihren Mut verlieren dann haben sie alles verloren.
Lieber nicht geboren also ohne Mut ist alles nichts.
Und jetzt gibt Steinmeier Merkel im Januar noch einen kleinen Wink mit.
Aber Ruhe auf dem Platz einkehrt liegt nicht allein in der Hand der Notenbank Es liegt an den Spielern auf dem Rasen den demokratisch gewählten Regierung.
Frau Bundeskanzlerin ich denke ich spreche im Namen aller wenn ich Ihnen für die weiteren Verhandlungen zur Vertiefung der Währungsunion eine glückliche Hand und vor allen Dingen viel Erfolg wünsche für Deutschland und für Europa.
So hätte ja keiner ahnen können dass zwei Monate später.
Schön. Ja er hatte ja eigentlich noch einmal gesagt Hör zu. Jetzt aber.
Du bist jetzt dran Du bist jetzt dran Draghi hat sein Werk gemacht Du bist jetzt dran.
So hätte keiner ahnen können dass zwei Monate später die Katastrophe passiert und wir die ganze Wirtschaft einmal ausschalten müssen.
Nun ist es so passiert. Die EZB hat 2008 Krisenbewältigung Mechanismen hergestellt die sich 2020 bislang voll ausgezahlt haben die Politik hat 2008 komplette Zeitverschwendung gemacht mit Austerität. Südländer Bashing.
Wir haben die Rückkehr der Diktatur in Osteuropa und so weiter.
Will man das auch nochmal wiederholen 2020 will man diese politische Geschichte nochmal schreiben oder,
lernen wir jetzt von Draghi von Steinmeier und so weiter kann man sich sozusagen,
zum Mouth kann man jetzt mutig sein und das ist ja dann wirklich erstaunlich denn jetzt kommen wir die Besinnung Herr Kommens zum Happy Ending der vierte Akt Auftritt Angela Merkels am 18.
Mai also zwei Wochen nach der Urteilsverkündung und sie steht mit Macron natürlich nicht an seiner Seite nur zugeschaltet via Bildschirm aber egal war es wert sagen Der große Akt gewesen beide hätten gleichzeitig in dem Raum wirklich stehen müssen aber gut.
Und Merkel sagt folgendes.
Wir müssen ernsthaft über das sprechen was Europa jetzt nichtausreichend konnte und was die Zukunft der Europäischen Union ausmachen wird.
Das kann auch Vertragsänderungen einschließen das kann ein sehr viel engeres Zusammenrücken einschließen.
Heute präsentieren wir sozusagen die kurze Antwort auf die Krise lange Antworten werden diskutiert werden müssen denn Europa muss weiterentwickelt werden.
Sie stellt mit Macron ein fünf Milliarden Recovery vor das allein über Verschuldung finanziert wird.
Ein absolutes Novum Sie stellt es als erster Schritt einer längeren Perspektive deren Programm Erfindung dar.
Sie schließt endlich wieder Vertragsänderung ein. Denn man traut es sich wieder zu. Das war ja lange wirklich ein No-Go.
Nach diesem Lissabons Desaster mit den nicht gegebenen Zustimmung in den Parlamenten und den Niederlanden da mehr Volksbefragungen und so weiter stehen jetzt wieder europäische Vertragsänderungen im Raum und das ist natürlich sensationell denn wir wissen in welche Richtung es geht,
die Vertiefung ist hinsichtlich einer Ermöglichung von europäischer Wirtschaftspolitik inklusive gemeinsamer Verschuldung.
Anderes wäre nicht denkbar dafür bräuchte man keine Vertragsänderung macht nur in der Hinsicht Sinn Macron steht neben ihr und bekräftigt.
Ich denke wir ziehen damit die Lehren aus der Vergangenheit. Zum Zeitpunkt der Wirtschafts und Finanzkrise die sehr asymmetrisch erfolgt ist sind einige Mitgliedsstaaten die bereits anfälliger waren die sehr harte Maßnahmen ergreifen und haben müssen Programme.
Und das hat zu einem geringeren europäischen Souveränität geführt denn dort wurden zum Beispiel große Transport Infrastrukturen oder Häfen privatisiert und das Ganze haben dann nicht europäische Kräfte übernommen.
Stromnetz oder die Hafen hätten jetzt zehn Jahre später stellt man fest dass geschwächt hat.
Markram stellt noch einmal heraus dass der Frankfurter Fraport jetzt in Griechenland zehn Flughäfen kauft das hat nun wirklich niemand in Europa irgendwo hin gerettet.
Das kann man auch anders machen. Man muss jetzt nicht nochmal ausbeuterisch. Sie liegen gerade am Boden einen schlang und nochmal drauf.
Nee da muss man jetzt daraus lernen. Macht ja ganz deutlich neben Merkel.
Und jetzt kommt wir diesen Plan nochmal kurz an Merkel deswegen Wir hören dass die Originaltöne die uns dann auch noch ewig beschäftigen weil es um ihr viel Geld geht und natürlich auch Widerstand natürlich.
Österreich und die CSU werden sich dann auch schön verbünden um gegen Merkel anzuwenden.
Aber Merkels Plan der EU-Haushalt der nun nicht besonders klein ist wird noch einmal erheblich erweitert.
Wir werden diesen Fonds in dieser Weise auflegen das heißt Die Kommission wird Geld aufnehmen,
das zusammen dann der Recovery Fund und die mittelfristige finanzielle Vorausschau den Gesamthaushalt der Europäischen Union ergeben und in den ersten Jahren nach der Krise deutlich mehr Mittel.
Diese fünf Milliarden Euro bereitstellen um im Rahmen des Haushaltes Unterstützung für die besonders betroffenen Länder und Sektoren bereitzustellen.
Und Macron führt jetzt mal inhaltlich an. Wie wird denn dieses Wie geht man mit diesem Geld jetzt um was man dann eingenommen hat.
Was sicher ist diese fünf Milliarden werden wir nicht von denen die von diesen 550 Milliarden profitieren zurückgezahlt werden sondern es gibt dann eventuell einen Verteilungsschlüssel,
für die Mitgliedsstaaten oder andere Mechanismen.
Aber das wird dann zusammen mit der Kommission entschieden wie schlussendlich diese konkret ausgestaltet wird.
Das Geld wird natürlich nach Bedarf verteilt und nicht mehr nach Schlüssel. Das war ja bei über Anleihekäufe auch ein Problem.
Deutschland braucht aber keine Nullzinsen Verschuldung und kriegt sie trotzdem hinten rein geschoben weil einfach ein und zwanzig komma vier Prozent der anderen Kaufes auf Deutschland entfällt.
Da wird jetzt ein bisschen nachjustiert und Merkel die sich dagegen ewig gewehrt hat stellvertretend für den Bundestag der sie da immer gehindert hat bekräftigt jetzt diesen Modus.
Dabei gilt der normale Haushalts Schlüssel der Mitgliedsstaaten wie beim Haushalts Verfahren,
bei der Verwendung der Gelder aber ist es selbstverständlich dass die Länder am meisten profitieren von diesen Mitteln die am stärksten durch die Krise getroffen wurden.
Also die 550 Milliarden werden nach Bedarf verteilt aber die Länder werden nach gemeinsamem Schlüssel an der Verschuldung beteiligt.
Stellt sich ja diese Frage Wieviel Geld muss denn Deutschland jetzt an den 500 Milliarden also 27 Prozent wäre der Schlüssel das ist ja ganz schön viel das sind ja so,
Merkel sagt dann kümmern sie sich nicht darum es wird sehr sehr sehr lange zurückgezahlt.
Frau Bundeskanzler. Eine ganz kurze Frage an Sie Was wird dieses fünf Milliarden Euro Paket denn Deutschland kosten. Es muss ja auch den Bundestag.
Fangen wir mit der zweiten Frage an das heißt es wird kosten es wird.
Wir haben einen bestimmten Anteil an der Finanzierung im Haushalt das sind etwa 27 Prozent glaube ich.
Für die mittelfristige finanzielle Vorausschau und dann auch für diese Mittel das bedeutet dass wir dann diesen Anteil natürlich auch zurückzahlen werden über die lange Periode.
Das heißt wir können uns daraus genau ausrechnen welche welche Summen dann in jedem Jahr wenn wir uns auf die Dauer der Rückzahlung geeinigt haben das wird eine lange Zeit sein.
Dann wird man kann man sich ausrechnen was die jährlichen Begleit also die Rückzahlungen Beträge sind die werden sind dann Teil des Haushalts.
Das begleitet uns dann über viele Jahre das auch so eine Rückzahlung Teil des Haushalts ist.
Sie wollte nicht genau sagen aber es ist eine sehr lange Zeit viele Jahre.
Die 550 Milliarden aufgeteilt Der deutsche Anteil werden 15 Milliarden oder so nur gestreckt. Und da fragt man sich Was sind eigentlich viele viele Jahre.
Und österreich hat jetzt eine Anleihe aufgemacht und 99 Jahre 99 Prozent. Das ist so als würde man,
eine Milch für einen Euro bei Rewe kaufen und man gibt einfach jedes Jahr am 1.
Januar bringt man einen Cent dahin und so nach hundert Jahren ist hier Milch bezahlt.
Wir sind jetzt in einer völlig neuen Realität. Also eigentlich schon lange aber so langsam kommt es ja auch in Deutschland an wo dieses Geld einfach wenn man es denn braucht zur Verfügung steht weil wir nur noch auf Inflation achten müssen und auch sonst,
fast gar nichts auf Haushalte jedenfalls recht wenig weshalb.
Wissen wir das vielleicht noch einschieben weil doch immer die Frage kommt auch aus meinem Bekanntenkreis immer wieder mit der Inflation Warum tun wir das so ab.
Also Inflation entsteht jetzt nicht einfach weil man viel Geld gedruckt hat.
Inflation. Wir kennen das aus Ländern aus Südamerika oder auch in Afrika entsteht zum einen wenn eine große politische Instabilität vorherrscht.
Das ist natürlich eine Gefahr die kommen kann aber die würde kommen von denen die ohnehin eine instabile EU haben wollen oder eben.
Sie kann kommen dadurch dass totale Misswirtschaft getrieben wird dass man sagt Wir hauen jetzt das Geld nur so raus wir sind eigentlich schon reich wissen kaum noch wohin damit.
Und jetzt schlagen wir nochmal was obendrauf.
Also jemand wie Hans-Werner Sinn der spricht ja dann immer von Liquiditätsschwemme und tut gerade so als seien unsere Konten jetzt mit Geld überflutet worden.
Und dem ist aber nicht so. Das wird jeder zu Hause in seinem Portemonnaie nachvollziehen können und es ist ja vollkommen klar dass jetzt einfach,
Geld in die Hand genommen wird das nicht entstanden ist durch Wirtschaftsleistung die jetzt brach lag lag einige.
Wochen und Monate wird das ja noch dauern bis das wieder so ist es.
Gibt es eigentlich gar keine Inflationsgefahr jetzt wenn jetzt alles prächtig laufen würde und wir hätten ein unendlich großes Wirtschaftswachstum und dann würden jetzt Macron und Merkel sagen So und jetzt hauen wir nochmal fünf Milliarden drauf oder so.
Dann kann es tatsächlich zu einer Inflation kommen.
Aber in einer solchen Krise in der man vernünftig investiert und vielleicht ja auch so investiert dass man auch dann wirklich so eine europäische Zukunft bildet.
Mit Blick auf Green Deal ist überhaupt nichts.
Was dafür spricht dass wir es mit einer Inflation zu tun bekommen.
Inflation. Das ist wirklich interessant weil bei Inflation denken immer viele an so ein theoretisches Konstrukt dann schlägt man die Bücher auf und liest.
Die Geldmenge wurde erhöht vor hundert Jahren und deswegen gab es eine Hyperinflation.
Das stimmt natürlich wenn man Geld druckt dann wirft man es auf den Markt dann ist es einfach da und wenn dann der Supermarkt man feststellt hier kommen jetzt lauter die Leute und kaufen mir die Milch weg und ich habe dann gar keine mehr aber die Leute haben immer noch Geld und wollen zu mir aber ich habe gar keine Güter mehr.
Dann kommt es natürlich zu über Inflation weil man dann das geht schlägt sich nieder in Erwartung Erwartung und stellt sich dann den Wecker drei Stunden und geht schon mal einkaufen und so weiter und so fort.
Dann ist haben es satt und da gibt's auch kein guter Nachschub.
Um dieser Geldmenge zu entsprechen nur das Geld was wir jetzt über diese Geldmenge Erhöhung zwei Billionen Euro über die EZB in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Dieses Geld kommt auf den Markt nur eben nicht in den Konsum sondern das fließt einmal so als Gehaltszahlung dann Konsum im Supermarkt.
Dann sammelt sich das bei den Supermarkt Besitzern oder wem auch immer. Den Autoherstellern.
Die haben natürlich mega viel Geld nur die bringen es nicht zum Konsum sondern die suchen Anleihe Möglichkeiten finden die dann bei Staatsanleihen zum Beispiel.
Und somit dreht sich das Rad weiter. Man muss dann natürlich irgendwann mal überlegen Es gibt da schon die Assia Kalkulation wenn die Entwicklung so weitergeht hat Jeff Basis mit 62 Jahren nämlich im Jahr 2036 eine Billion Dollar Privatvermögen.
Fragt man sich so ein bisschen hat das Sinn dass das Geld nicht mehr im Kreislauf ist sondern aus der Notenbank heraus flutscht einmal durch die Wirtschaft strömt und sich dann bei diesen superreichen sammelt hat das eigentlich Sinn.
Oder könnte man nicht so wie man so wie wir sagen.
Die EZB kann die Schulden auch einfach vergessen könne man nicht Chewbacca sagen komm wir bauen jetzt ein Denkmal da steht drauf Du warst der reichste Mann hast in dem eine Billion besessen.
Wir vergessen das jetzt einfach Wir vergessen dein Vermögen einfach und ich kann nichts machen es ist einfach Wir streichen es aus der Geschichte Wir markieren es nochmal du hast es geschafft.
Du bist der Superstar aber Jeff Basars geht mit diesem Geld nicht zu Rewe und kauft anderen Leuten was weg.
Dadurch kommt es nicht zu einer Inflation die Inflation ist ja im Grunde Gütermenge. Und diesen Gütermenge den wird es nicht kriegen.
Da muss man ganz deutlich sagen und da sind die Virologen gerade wieder so vorbildhaft Inflation da kann man sich unendlich Gedanken machen nur man kann sie einfach messen.
Wenn man als EZB wissen will was machen man jetzt mit der Inflation einfach messen.
Diese ganzen Gedanken kann man sich trotzdem noch machen. Aber man kann einfach den Warenkorb bei Rewe sich anschauen sich fragen Was kostet da denn.
Und dann geht man im nächsten Monat wieder hin und fragt sich wieder was kostet denn dann weiß man was er kostet.
Die Theorie dahinter ist erstmal gar nicht so ausschlaggebend auch wenn immer alle mit diesem Geld müsste man gleich mal erklären was es damit auf sich hat.
Einfach messen wieso Virologe losgehen und sagen Wir wissen die Seuche mit Geld kann man einfach wissen ob hier irgendwo Güter knapp sind oder nicht.
Da muss man natürlich ein feines Sensorium haben da braucht man auch eine gute freie Wissenschaft die dann beispielsweise wie in Amerika jetzt mal feststellt also dieses ganze Kurzarbeiter und die Unternehmen machen erst mal zu und sammeln die Hilfen ein und genießen dann erst mal,
auf der Chefetage ihren Urlaub das führt dann doch dazu dass dann im Mai 2020.
Keine TIFF Kühlschränke mehr zu kaufen gibt und dann wird es natürlich problematisch wenn sowas also wenn man auf der Seite sozusagen keinen Nachschub hat also wenn die Leute Geld haben aber da finde ich nicht bekommen was sie brauchen dann wirds problematisch.
Aber solange das in Europa null Gefahr dafür ist einfach die Kompetenz in Bundesbank und EZB auch einfach viel zu hoch und da so eine Angst haben zu müssen dass da etwas außer aus aus dem Ruder laufen kann,
kann man das glaube ich super super super entspannt sehen.
Und Merkel merkt hier noch einmal an der Bundestag Wir haben es ja gerade noch mal gehört vom Herrn Voßkuhle und so weiter Wir werden jetzt mal transparent.
Mit Blick auf die Urteile des Bundesverfassungsgerichts war es immer ganz wichtig dass nach dem Demokratieprinzip der Deutsche,
Bundestag der das deutsche Parlament die Entscheidung über die Mittel hat die nach Europa gegeben werden.
Insofern ist das ein sehr transparenter Prozess.
Das ist natürlich ein folgerichtige aber auch ein bisschen folgenlose Satz denn ihr großes Mantra an diesem Tag war folgendes.
Die Antwort heißt Europa muss gemeinsam handeln.
Der Nationalstaat alleine hat keine Zukunft. Und ich sage es für Deutschland Deutschland wird es auf Dauer nur gut gehen wenn es Europa gut geht.
Das ist vollkommen klar und zwar im Blick auf Frieden und Freiheit und im Blick auf Wirtschaft und Wohlstand.
Da geht es also historisch um etwas mehr als einfach nur Geld sagt er.
Wenn Sie Geld verlieren. Keine Sorge Sie sollten auf den Rest allerdings achten.
Und da fragt man sich so ein bisschen ja wie findet man einen Modus der Modus ist noch nicht gefunden und das ist vielleicht das größte Problem.
Auch 2008 alle aufeinander eingeschlagen und den Arsch gerettet und leider begingen begannen auch dieses Programm wieder mit einem gewissen Formfehler Macron stellt das mal kurz dar.
Wir haben in den letzten Stunden natürlich auch unsere Partner über diese Initiative ins Bild gesetzt.
Wir haben in den letzten Stunden unsere Partner also die anderen EU-Mitgliedsstaaten ins Bild gesetzt und das ist natürlich überrumpelung das sind dann auch alle zu Recht sauer und kurz.
In der Tat Das kann man geschickter angehen.
Sebastian Kurz hat in zwei Tagen ein zwei Seiten Ding als Gegenprogramm entwickelt und auf den Markt geschmissen.
Das sind natürlich Schönheitsfehler. Ich weiß auch nicht genau warum sie nicht auf die Reihe kriegen wenn sie sich mal wieder treffen können.
Eine Videokonferenz führt da auch nicht viel weiter.
Aber naja das ist jedenfalls Klipp mäßig die große Geschichte des Mai.
Was das Geld angeht gewesen und da wir jetzt um diesen Punkt abzuschließen doch nochmal auf die deutsche Debatte denn wir brauchen eine neue deutsche Debatte Wir können nicht nochmal zehn Jahre Hans-Werner Sinn und so weiter uns irgendwie erklärt auch die Griechen müssen nur aus dem Euro aus.
Es ist ein bisschen so Deutschland übernimmt ja im Juli die EU-Ratspräsidentschaft.
Sie kann also durchaus ein bisschen inhaltliche Agenda setzen. Und Ursula von der Leyen hat sich am 27.
Mai also vor zwei Tagen schon hingestellt hat gesagt dass mit den fünf Milliarden dass sich die Europäische Kommission selbstverschuldet kann es schon ganz gut.
Ich will aber selber nochmal ein Programm vorstellen mit 750 Milliarden die nochmal auf der Merkel Macron Plan sondern sie hat wirklich parallel daneben nochmal 750 Milliarden über die gleiche Verschuldung.
Die EU-Staaten haften also die Eurostaaten haften sozusagen aber langfristigen.
Mal gucken wie diese Diskussion weitergeht. Es sind jedenfalls so viele Forderungen im Raum dass man irgendwo eine Richtung muss es gehen.
Was Verschuldung angeht weil diese 1,2 Billionen die jetzt nicht bei Peter Gauweiler als Steuern eintreiben Das ist glaube ich ausgeschlossen.
Diese Refinanzierungen Idee die EU-Kommission mitbringt ist beispielsweise die Ausweitung des europäischen Emissionshandels.
Da sieht man schon Grenadier steckt da drin eine digital Steuer absolut notwendig da im Silicon Valley immer ein bisschen Einhalt zu gebieten und eine Plastik Abgabe.
Solche Sachen diskutieren wir jetzt da müssen wir Deutschen natürlich sagen Bitte Emissionshandel ab sofort Plastik Abgabe warum nicht. Sind doch genau die Regelung die wir wollen.
Markus Preiß hat allerdings zu diesem 57 Milliarden Plan auf Twitter der Korrespondent in Brüssel schon geschrieben.
Lustig wenn EU-Kommissar kennte Johnnie im Handelsblatt sagt er wolle keine Zahlen des Recovery nennen.
Nach meinen Informationen kennt er sie auch nicht in der EU-Kommission ist nur ein ganz ganz enger Kreis an der Ausarbeitung beteiligt sagt viel über Stimmung und Vertrauen dort und dann noch hinterher geschickt.
Wir sehen so ein bisschen Es müssen sich alle selber überrumpeln damit es zu so etwas kommt. Es ist natürlich nicht der goldene Weg aber wie auch immer.
Auf Twitter hat Lars Weißbrot den führt kommt aus einer Zeit hat die Zeit Countys übernommen.
Da ist einmal eine Woche ein Redakteur zuständig. Er hat dann am 21. Mai.
Da sieht man ja immer noch eine große Zeitung mit 500000 Auflage also Liebe Follower Mein Name ist Lars Weißbrot Ich bin Redakteur,
der ZEIT und übernehme für eine Woche diesen Account zusammen mit Ihnen möchte ich einer spannenden Frage nachgehen die mich seit kurzem umtreibt Was ist eigentlich Geld.
Wo kommt es her. Diese Frage kann man jetzt.
Aber war diese Frage von ihnen wirklich ernst gemeint hat er das dann da debattiert oder war das einfach mal so Ich mache mal was Lustiges. Aber freue mich am Ende doch auf den neuen Roman eines schlecht gealterten Literaten.
Du kennst das Weißbrot. Ich dachte erst das ist so.
Ist. Ich dachte erst das ist ein Joke. Also wenn er schreibt Liebe Follower dann ist es eigentlich immer so eine satirische Anmerkung.
Dann habe ich aber erst gesehen es ist ja gar nicht seine Countys Es ist ja wirklich die Zeit.
Und er meinte das tatsächlich ernst. Es war ein ganz ernst gemeinter und er hat dann auch die Woche lang die einen oder anderen Fragen da und er hat ja auch die Autorin im Hause zum Beispiel Marc Shiraz.
Der hat ja schon am 5. Mai also am Tag des Urteils getitelt konfus europaskeptische ökonomisch fragwürdig.
Zu dem Urteil sind dann die überschriften Die wandern dann auch in die Deutschlandfunks Presseschau am Abend rein und dann hat Macchia Ritts Olaf Scholz interviewt und er hat in der überschrift standen.
Jemand muss vorangehen wenn mir jemand Olaf Scholz schon gehört. In welche Richtung er denn so vorangehen will.
Und er hat noch dieses spektakuläre Interview mit Adam Toulouse oder Thust oder wie er heißt Das habe ich bei dir auch twittert gesehen.
Ja
Für Donald Trump ist Geld etwas das die Banken zaubern. Und da habe ich ja.
Ein hervorragendes Interview und der Titel meint jetzt so Ach ja der verrückte Trump wieder. Aber es sagt ja er hat das verstanden der Trump.
Ich habe 26 Anmerkung in diesem Interview leider weiß ich nicht genau wie ich die Teile wenn ich das verlinkte.
Wir verlinken einfach dieses Interview weil das muss einfach jeder lesen. Also da wird wirklich mal erklärt was Sache ist.
Selbst in der FAZ da hat Holger Schmieding ehemals Chefvolkswirt Merrill Lynch und Bank of America und jetzt bei Berenberg vom Irrtum der Richter geschrieben und ein Zitat aus dem Text Das Urteil ist mehr als fragwürdig.
Es ruht auf Zitat unvollständige und somit falschem Verständnis von Geldpolitik,
Die EZB gibt genügend Infos wie Pressekonferenzen und so weiter und hat mit den Aufsätzen Reden und berichten mit denen sie ihre Geldpolitik einschließlich der Wirkung und Folgen erklärt hat lassen sich ganze Regale füllen.
Da ist sehr wenig Luft noch eine Voßkuhle Ja da ist mittlerweile eine neue Diskussion irgendwie da.
Hans-Werner Sinn dürfte dann gerade nochmal im Spiegel ein Interview geben mit dem Zitat im Titel Es ist viel zu viel Geld im Umlauf.
Ja nur ist es ein Problem kann man ja mal neu diskutieren im Handelsblatt Peter Bofinger keine Angst vor Crooner Schulden die Tilgung muss vertagt werden.
Im Handelsblatt hat Hans-Werner Sinn gerade noch und zwar nur gemeinsam mit Marcel Fratzscher Pro und Kontra bekommen.
Also durfte er gar nicht mehr selber ins Ziel kommen.
Titel also überschrift des Gesprächs. Wir dürfen die Coruna Schulden nicht zurückzahlen das ist eine.
Das ist richtig cool das ist jetzt eine neue Diskussion. Sie kommt nochmal auf Twitter als Abschluss hier.
Staatsverschuldung belasten kommende Generationen. Dieses altbekannte Argument wird im Zuge der Diskussion um die Schulden auf jeden Fall kommen.
Aber es ist ökonomisch falsch und sollte deshalb aus dem politischen Raum verschwinden.
Hierzu ein kurzer Thread und dann hat er stundenlang aufgeschrieben warum das alles Blödsinn ist was wir die letzten zehn Jahre Deutschland gemacht haben.
Das ist wirklich eine fröhliche Wendung nach dem Green Deal der EZB im Januar haben wir jetzt glaube ich und zwar diesmal mit aktiver deutscher Beteiligung.
Merkel und Scholz an dieser Stelle eine EU-Ratspräsidentschaft vor uns in der dann vielleicht doch mal ein bisschen neu diskutiert wird.
Der Ansicht gute Nachrichten.
Gute Nachrichten. Wir gehen zu einem anderen Thema über das ich aber noch gar nicht ankündigen will.
Um welches es sich da handelt sondern ich will erst einmal ankündigen dass es einen Text gab mit dem wir einsteigen.
Und zwar war dieser Text von Samira El Basil eine liebe gute Freundin von mir. Sie ist Kolumnistin nicht nur für den Spiegel sondern auch für über Medien. Und das ist jetzt aus ihrer über Medien Kolumne.
Da steigt sie folgendermaßen Ich habe ein klein bisschen gekürzt in ihre Kolumne ein.
Die aber sich diesmal ganz anders liest als ihre sonstigen Betrachtungen zu irgendwelchen medialen Phänomenen und so.
Und da haben wir mal rein. Ich habe gelesen.
Während meiner Grundschulzeit wohnte ich in der Nähe des Münchner Hauptbahnhofs.
Das was dort heute ein Galeria Karstadt ist war früher Hertie das größte Kaufhaus am Ort.
Es hatte die tollste Spielzeug Abteilung der Welt eine ganze Etage voller bunter Dinge die blinkten und leuchteten und nach Plastik rochen.
Der magische Ort dieses Stockwerks war ein separater Bereich ganz hinten links in der Ecke wo die Videospiele verkauft wurden,
lebensgroße Puppe Aufsteller der Videospiele Helden und mächtige Ake Türme in denen die Fernseher und Konsolen Diebstahlsicherung verankert waren bildeten einen Wall gegen das restliche Spielzeugland.
Es war ein eigenes kleines Arenal der coolen Kids und Schlüssel Kinder.
Man trat aus dem Pink von Mattel und dem Gelb von Duplo Bausteinen heraus und hinein in diesen Bereich eines vermeintlich Erwachsenen Spielens dominiert von futuristischen Silber,
Fernseher schwarz Sega blau und Nintendo Rot.
Nach der Schule bin ich sofern es der Stundenplan zuließ allein oder mit Freunden dorthin gegangen.
Vor allem donnerstags weil man zwei Stunden länger als sonst bleiben konnte.
Hastig und aufgeregt rannte ich die Rolltreppe hoch in den vierten Stock hinten links regelrecht hingen hechtet bin ich mit meinem wippenden Scout Schulranzen.
Ich war besessen von der Notwendigkeit in Donkey Kong Country oder Sonic voranzukommen.
Das ist der wunderbare wirklich literarische einstieg und man würde sagen den Roman kaufe ich mir.
Vor allem hätte man damals ja auch so ein bisschen diese Altersklasse wo man Donkey Kong nach der Schule Rolltreppe hoch gespielt hat man hätte damals ja wohl nicht geglaubt dass jemand der darum steht und die Zeit dort so verschwendet dann plötzlich.
Ja
Bei Ebay so schreibt.
Überhaupt Texte schreibt er dass der Text noch eine Rolle spielt und dass man das nochmal so aufgreift.
Genau. Und dann ist es aber so dass,
es in diesem Text eine Wendung gibt dass es jetzt nicht ein Erinnerungs Text der einfach sagt wie schön es damals im Kaufhaus war sondern,
dieser Text Der handelt davon dass das Mädchen Samira dort spielt und plötzlich hinter ihr dann ein Fremder auftaucht und sie hat vorher beschrieben dass,
es so einen groben Rahmen bei diesen Fernsehern gab auf denen man das Ganze dann spielen konnte.
Und jetzt schildert sie dann was man dort was sie dort beobachtet hat.
Als jedoch plötzlich dicht hinter mir dieser Fremde auftauchte musste ich einmal genauer in die Spiegelung des Monitors Rahmens schauen weil mich etwas an seinem Auftritt irritierte.
Ich nahm in der Kromm Reflexionen etwas wahr das mein Gehirn nicht einzuordnen vermochte weil es nicht verstand was es da sah.
Ich erinnere mich dass ich es auf kindliche Weise interpretierte.
Der Mann hinter mir streichelte eine rosafarbene Banane.
Zwar begriff ich nicht was es war aber ich fühlte was es nicht war. Normal.
Und dann beschreibt sie im Folgenden wie Sie als Kind dort sexuell belästigt wurde von diesem Mann der hinter ihr stehend onaniert.
Und das ist ein Text der wirklich einen erschüttert.
Es ist ein Text der eben dieser unglaublich literarische Qualität hat.
Und es ist ja ein Text aber der wie sie selbst sagt Vor ein paar Wochen noch nicht entstanden wäre und jetzt überspringen wir also diese Schilderung Ich kann nur jedem empfehlen.
Die Kolumne ist online frei verfügbar um über Medien den Text einmal ganz zu lesen ist sehr lang sehr schön.
Aber Wir springen jetzt ein gutes Stück weiter und erfahren warum dieser Text ausgerechnet jetzt entstanden ist.
Noch vor einer Woche hätte ich mich nicht getraut diese Geschichte aufzuschreiben und zu veröffentlichen weil ich auf abstrakte Weise Angst hatte dass sie sich vor mir ekeln könnten,
weil ich mich für die Geschichte auf unergründliche Art schäme weil ich es für einen persönlichen Einzelfall halte von dem ich dachte dass er für die öffentlichkeit keine Relevanz besitzt.
Dass ich Pech hatte dass es trivial sei dass es durch das darüber sprechen und schreiben ungewollt zum Trauma Kitsch oder Opfer Porn verkommt.
Auch weil ich sie nicht damit belästigen wollte weil ich mich nicht wie ein Alien fühlen wollte und weil ich mir nicht sicher war ob das was da passierte überhaupt ein Missbrauch ist.
Dann kam am vergangenen Mittwoch zur Primetime auf dem Privatsender ProSieben plötzlich Männerwelt.
Das ist der Anlass Männerwelt ich haben alle gehört eben diese Aktion 15 Minuten bei ProSieben.
Das Joko und Klaas diese zerstrittene Sendezeit freigegeben haben um das Thema sexuelle Belästigung Missbrauch thematisieren zu lassen.
Nicht sie selbst haben das getan sondern prominente Frauen haben das getan.
Und ich steige mit diesem Text ein weil ich ihnen so unglaublich aufrichtig halte weil ich ihnen auch,
insofern wichtig finde als er sagt Ja das hat dann selbst auch bei mir die ich ja medial erfahren bin die ich ohnehin weiß um diese Dinge dass so etwas eigentlich kein Einzelfall ist.
Nochmal etwas einen Auslöser wenn so etwas so breit thematisiert wird dass ich auch über meine eigenen Erlebnisse nochmal reflektieren darüber nachdenke und ich,
bringe diesen Text auch weil ich von einer Bekannten angerufen wurde und ich sage Besser einer,
Freundin angerufen und die diesen Text gelesen hatte und sagte dass er,
sie sehr bekräftigt hat darin.
Das zu tun was sie vor paar Wochen getan hat nämlich einen Kollegen anzuzeigen der sie belästigt hat und,
dass sie auch diese Männerwelt insofern wichtig fand als sie beobachtet hat bei Facebook.
Und wenn wir Facebook sagen dann sehen wir schon wir haben es hier auch mit einem großen Publikum zu tun das eben nicht der Journalisten Twitter unterwegs ist.
Dass durch diese 15 Minuten auf dieses Thema hingewiesen wurde dafür sensibilisiert wurde auf eine Weise die es vorher so zumindest noch nicht gegeben hat.
Und das ist irgendwie ein sehr erstaunlicher Effekt denn man kann ja sagen es ist ja keineswegs zum ersten Mal so dass darüber gesprochen wird.
Wir hatten jetzt jahrelang auch die Methode Battke.
Dass aber offenbar solche 15 Minuten nochmal ein ganz großer Auslöser sind.
Und ich habe hier eine ganz kurze Passage von Guanin Michael sondern dass es bei WDR aktuell gelaufen und dort wird.
Michael das nochmal ein bisschen einordnen und wir hören dann auch in diesem Clip noch so zwei drei äußerungen die dort getan wurden dann in diesen 15 Minuten auf Pro7.
Die Wirkung die da gestern Abend erreicht wurde so durchschlagend war dann wahrscheinlich auch weil es geschafft wurde zu zeigen dass zu diesen Geschichten Menschen gehören die das wirklich erleben und denen das wehtut körperlich seelisch,
Schäden hinterlässt Narben hinterlässt.
Was hattest du an. Diese Frage wird Frauen die vergewaltigt wurden häufig gestellt. Männerwelt präsentiert echte Antworten,
ich vergewaltigt wurde dunkelblaues Top.
Nichts Außergewöhnliches nicht mal Make up Sandalen. Eigentlich wollten wir nur abhängen.
Und 13 Jahre alt war. Mit 17 hatte ich einen Pyjama an. Die Dunkelheit ist heute meine größte Angst.
Ausschnitte aus 7.
Das waren Ausschnitte aus ProSieben und das waren eben nicht Stimmen prominenter Frauen sondern das waren anonyme Opfer die sich da zu Wort gemeldet haben.
Und das fand ich auch in dem Beitrag das Interessanteste.
Und damit kommen wir auch schon zu Problemen die das mir auch macht dieser Beitrag.
Zum einen gab es eine Kritik daran.
Die sagen es waren nicht genügend Pixie,
Frauen dort die sich geäußert haben zu dem Thema oder Transgender Fragen wurden gar nicht gestellt oder Menschen mit Behinderungen die eben oft solchen,
Missbrauchsfällen vielmehr noch ausgeliefert sind da sie Pflege bedürfen oder so.
Und dann gab es noch die Kritik daran dass man mit ihm zusammengearbeitet hat weil die eine sehr schwierige Haltung zum Kopftuch haben also für ein Kopftuchverbot tendenziell sind sich da manchmal sehr reaktionär.
Positionieren auch was Sexarbeit betrifft.
Das ist aber jetzt gar nicht mein Thema sondern was eigentlich zu fragen ist.
Wir haben jetzt hier zwei Beispiele einmal Samira Sils Texte und auch das Anekdotische was sich jetzt von einer Freundin berichtet habe dass so etwas tatsächlich eine Wirkung entfaltet.
Und doch muss man fragen Wo leben wir eigentlich wenn es tatsächlich diese 15 Minuten geballte Aufmerksamkeit mit virales Marketing.
So kann man das ja nennen Man hat ja dazu Influenza Persönlichkeiten auch,
mit dabeigehabt braucht um dieses Thema dann mal kurz in die Timeline zu spülen und auch die Frage ist Wie wird dann,
das einen nachhaltigen Effekt haben wenn man eigentlich hier so eine Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie hat die ganz kurz ist die alles geballt hat die auch mit diesen Schockmoment arbeitet.
Wir haben das jetzt ein bisschen durch diese musikalische Untermalung durch diese Soundkulisse schon gemerkt Männerwelt.
Das war dann auch wie eine eine Ausstellung die aber zugleich auch das Gefängnis artiges etwas Finsteres hatte dargestellt.
Wir haben hier alle Mittel der Emotionalisierung.
Des Spektakels auf die zurückgegriffen wird.
Und die Frage ist ob das dann überhaupt am Ende etwas bewirkt.
Ob das jetzt gerade einmal diese 15 Minuten Ruhm sind die man nicht nur wie Andy Warhol einzelnen Personen zugesteht oder ob das jetzt auch die 15 Minuten Ruhm sind die jedes.
Ich nenne es mal Soziales gesellschaftspolitisches Thema mal erfahren kann wenn man es nur richtig aufmacht wenn man es nur so tut wie es die Logik der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie verlangt.
Ich würde sagen es ist doppelt. Es verdoppelt sich das Thema.
Denn diese Aufmerksamkeit spielt natürlich eine Rolle hinsichtlich.
Ich habe es beispielsweise gar nicht mitbekommen. Ich habe das erst als zweiter Hashtag Ich bin so weit vom Fernsehen weg dass selbst wenn der Unitymedia hier ist sage ich ihm nicht dass mein Receiver nicht funktioniert weil selbst das wäre mir zu viel um wieder zurück zum Fernsehen zu kommen.
Ich habe nur auf Twitter mitbekommen und zwar über diese Kritik da waren ja zu wenig People of Color also sozusagen eine ohnehin schon sich kritisch mit einem Thema auseinandersetzen.
Die Sendung wurde für mich nochmal über eine weitere Kritik Bande geöffnet als Thema.
Da habe ich wieder einmal ganz schön viel. Dazu habe ich kurz nachgelesen.
Ich habe allerdings nicht nachgeschaut. Ich weiß jetzt nicht von der Anmutung her was es damit auf sich hat. Ich weiß aber noch von früher.
Bei der FAZ oder so. Wenn du da morgens in die Konferenz rein gehst spielt es eine Rolle was medial in Deutschland am Abend vorher stattfand oder am Morgen im Deutschlandfunk Wer wurde da interviewt und so weiter.
Weshalb alle Politiker morgens um sieben Zeit haben selbst wenn sie erst am Bett sind wenn der Deutschlandfunk morgens um sieben anruft fürs Interview.
Alle haben eine Zeit da kann man echte Themen setzen und dann ist ja so dass so ein Initial Moment ein Epizentrum 110 Minuten Sendung selbst die strahlt dann medial aus.
Und das hat dann sozusagen über Bande wieder Effekte bis hin zu Richtern im ganzen Justiz betrieb.
Menschen die sich eh schon damit befassen und dann nochmal eine neue Wendung A also eine neue Legitimation erfahren irgendwie ist doch Thema Wir arbeiten ja nicht im luftleeren Raum sondern es gibt sozusagen auch einen gesellschaftlichen Drang das zu machen.
Gerade beim Kindesmissbrauch oder bei Gewalt allgemein hat man ja schon in Deutschland so eine neue juristische Sensibilisierung erfahren die kam vor allem durch diese Neuerfindung,
von Familien als Zentrum der Liebe und so diese neue Kindererziehung dass man seine Kinder nicht schlägt wie das vor 50 Jahren noch gang und gäbe war sondern,
nur noch in Jahrzehnten gerechnet aber es gab sozusagen einen sozialen Wandel und auch ein Einstellungs Wandel was das angeht.
Da würde ich sagen zahlt sich doch schon sehr aus.
Solche medialen Epizentren zu machen weil sie irgendwann dann doch Effekte zeigen in der beispielsweise juristischen Welt oder wenn Erwachsene grundsätzlich drüber nachdenken.
Ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt wie wir es geschafft haben Corona weniger durch politische Maßnahmen sondern mehr durch eine Bewusstwerdung.
Da ist jetzt eine Gefahr in der Welt Ich gehe jetzt mal nicht in die Kneipe Ich fühle mich unwohl wenn ich einkaufen gehe.
All das schaffte es an Infektionsherd so herunter zu dimmen.
Dieses ganze mitlaufenden Bewusstsein spielt doch schon eine große Rolle deswegen würde ich sagen ich habe es jetzt sozusagen medial selbst nicht verfolgt aber ich merke so richtig wie es so mitreißend,
Strömungen verursacht hat auch da wo ich mich so medial befinde,
würde ich sagen Es ist schon nicht so schlecht 15 Minuten ich bin immer noch rätselt immer noch wie es dazu kommt zu diesen 15 Minuten. Da gibt es eine Spielshow einen Gewinn.
Eine Spielshow mit Joko und Klaas und die treten gegen den Sender an.
Die müssen irgendwelche Aufgaben bewältigen die auch fragwürdig sind.
Man hatte jetzt bei den letzten 110 Minuten die sie erspielt haben in denen sie sich dann mit Verschwörungen Mythen auseinandergesetzt haben.
Da haben Sie dann auf so einer Streckbank liegen müssen und werden dann quasi so ein bisschen,
gefoltert und wenn sie das alles durchstehen und dann noch irgendwelche Fragen beantworten können dann können Sie diese 15 Minuten sich erstreiten gut Fernsehen Wir wissen,
die gewinnen nicht immer gut. Stefan ist das Fernsehen nicht.
Naja es gab ja. Es gab ja von der GSF auch schon einiges über Joko und Klaas und diese unglaublichen Aktionen die sie machen und da weiß man dann auch so ganz unglaublich ist das nicht und man kann ja auch mal denken wie im Fernsehen so.
Andre sag ich nur.
Wieviel Kulissen Heftigkeit da ist aber da sind wir vielleicht schon bei diesem Problem auch die Aufmerksamkeit entsteht ja wodurch eigentlich hier.
Es gibt ja ganz viele Sendungen die sich mit dem Thema sexueller Missbrauch schon auseinandergesetzt haben es gibt ja auch Frauenmagazine zum Beispiel im Fernsehen die das tun in Kulturzeit ist das regelmäßig Thema gewesen.
Alle Künstler Sparten hindurch. Also ist es sehr sehr präsent.
Man kann sagen MiTo ist auch ein bisschen präsent durch diese Prominenz. Das war ja auch immer wieder Kritik.
Auch der berühmte Ronan Farrow der ja derjenige ist der dann auch gegen den da,
angeschrieben hat und der auch da Woody Allen seinen Vater dort beschuldigt der ist selbstverständlich auch so bekannt weil er der Sohn von Woody Allen und Mia Farrow ist.
Diese Prominenz spielt schon eine Rolle das hatten wir also hier auch wieder Wir hatten hier nur sehr prominente Persönlichkeiten mit einer riesen Followers Schar.
Und hinzu kommt aber noch was was man vielleicht ein bisschen den Rizzo Effekt nennen darf um das verständlich zu machen.
Wieso hat ja jahrelang bei YouTube Quatsch gemacht.
Das sage ich jetzt wertfrei in dem Sinne Es ist so Unterhaltungs Quatsch den er gemacht hat und kommt dann mit einem Video und sagt Hier ich zerstöre die CDU.
Und ähnlich ist es jetzt auch bei ProSieben. Da kann man sagen da kommt nie irgendein seriöses Format findet dort einfach nicht statt.
Das Beste ist wirklich noch wenn sie mal den Michael Bay Film zeigen dann wird es mal anspruchsvoll und da sagt man jetzt machen wir jetzt mal so was.
Das ist ein Effekt der damit erzielt wird.
Den könnte man zum Beispiel jetzt nicht in der ARD erzielen als würde man das.
Selbe Format so ausstrahlen in der ARD würde das sicherlich auch noch für eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit sorgen weil das doch verwirren würde wo ist die Pilcher die bei uns doch eigentlich versprochen.
Aber es würde nicht das auslösen was man jetzt bei ProSieben hat.
Und das ist in gewisser Weise schön dass man so einen Subventionsempfänger erreichen kann darüber zeigt aber auch wie limitiert das Ganze ist.
Es geht eben mal die 15 Minuten wenn ansonsten alles immer in diesem Unterhaltungs Wahnsinn verbleibt und es geht dann auch mit ebenso einer starken Verkürzung was dann auch dafür sorgt dass es eben diese Kritik gibt was alles fehlte.
Also warum nicht zwei Stunden dafür 15 Minuten gönnt man sich gerade noch.
Und es hat dann und damit kommen wir dann eben weg von einem Rizzo Effekt nochmal etwas ganz anderes nämlich.
Es geht hier ja auch darum dass ein Sender sich jetzt noch etwas hinzu.
Kauft damit was er eben nicht besessen hat nämlich Seriosität und auch noch ein gesellschaftspolitisches Bewusstsein.
Denn wenn man sich einmal die Formate ansieht und da ist Joko und Klaas sicherlich noch das angenehmste und beste auch wenn dort fragwürdige Dinge geschehen und es auch da um körperliche Schmerzen geht.
Dass da eigentlich so Foltermethoden dann salonfähig gemacht werden.
Insofern man sie alle als Unterhaltung deklariert und in abgeschwächter Form natürlich zeigt müssen wir ja mal daran uns erinnern was eigentlich ProSieben für ein Sender ist.
Ich weiß nicht ob du überhaupt dann noch Fernsehen schaust.
Ich schaue ja auch nur noch im Internet Ich hab glaub ich das gar nicht mehr im Fernsehen so angeschlossen.
Also ich weiß gar nicht ob mein Fernseher noch ProSieben erreichen kann da ich mit meinem Fernseher nur DVDs und Blu rays mir ansehe.
Aber zum Beispiel gibt es dort immer noch Germanys Next Top.
Ja das läuft gerade wieder. Ich habe.
Wenn wir mal dran denken was dort für ein Frauenbild hergestellt wird wozu Frauen dort gezwungen werden und dass sie auch dann,
immer wieder die Tränen irgendwelcher Jungen recht hilflosen Mädchen ausstellen die sich gar nicht,
souverän verhalten können gegenüber einer Heidi Klum oder diesen Herren die aus der Modebranche.
Da sitzen dann muss man sich schon fragen sollten wer jetzt,
ProSieben allzu viel applaudieren dass sie diese 15 Minuten uns präsentieren und vielleicht als kleine Erinnerung zu Germany's Next Topmodel habe ich nochmal eingelesen was Roger Willemsen,
seinerzeit in der taz über Heidi Klum und ihr Format schrieb Es sind wenige Zeilen aber die haben es in sich.
Eine unschöne Frau mit Laub gesenktem Gouvernanten Profil bringt kleine Mädchen zum Weinen,
indem sie ihre orthodoxe hochgerüstete Belanglosigkeit zum Maßstab humaner seine Erfüllung hoch schwindelt,
über Persönlichkeit redet sich aber kaum mehr erinnern kann was das ist und sollte die sie je zum Vorschein kommen sie mit Rauswurf bestraft.
Der Exzess der Nichtigkeit aber erreicht seinen Höhepunkt.
Wo Heidi nationale mit Knallchargen Pathos und einer Pause in der man die Leere ihres Kopfes wabern hört Ihre gestrenge Entscheidung mitteilt und Wertes von Unwert im Leben scheidet.
Da möchte man dann elegant und stilsicher wie der Dichter sagt sechs Sorten Scheiße aus ihr raus prügeln wenn es bloß nicht so frauenfeindlich wäre.
Ich denke damit ist das Format recht gut zusammengefasst und.
Es fehlt leider in so einer Kritik immer der Antrieb solche Formate kann man richtig gut kritisieren wenn man sie richtig viel guckt.
Das hat ja gerade vorgemacht. üblicherweise ist es ja so dass man sich abwendet wenn man es nicht mag oder wenn man es nicht erträgt und dann wirklich nur noch die blöden zu gucken die es auch nur als Happening verstehen und man dann nicht mehr so eine Kritik reinkommt.
Aber das zeigt ja auch den Verlust von Roger Willemsen dass man solche Leute die sich dann einfach mal hinsetzen und das alles gucken.
Ich weiß noch Stefan Niggemeier hat ja mal eine Zeitlang diese ganzen Anruf Spielshows die nachts kommen einfach mal geguckt und so eine Kritik fehlt jetzt leider sehr aber immer immer gut daran zu erinnern.
Ich habe aber etwas geguckt. Ein neues Format bei ProSieben war ich dann dachte ich finde man sollte ProSieben wurde jetzt so viel gelobt auch dafür dass die so etwas machen und zeigen.
Ich denke man muss wirklich sagen was ist eigentlich bei ProSieben los.
Und es ist furchtbar was da passiert ist. Ich möchte das auch ganz deutlich so sagen menschenverachtende Dinge geschehen da und das ist wirklich ein Feigenblatt.
Diese 15 Minuten sind nichts weiter als ein Feigenblatt.
Die mögen zwar jetzt auch für einiges Gutes gesorgt haben aber es ist ein Feigenblatt und es ist nach wie vor der Feind wenn man so möchte.
Und ich habe mir eine Sendung angesehen die neu ist diese Sendung heißt Bolts.
Was würdest du für Geld tun oder Wie weit würdest du für Geld gehen.
Und dort gibt es sehr viele Kandidaten die sind auf so einer Tribüne.
Es gibt auch noch zugleich Zuschauer und Kandidaten auf der Tribüne.
Die bekommen Fragen gestellt was sie bereit wären zu tun und dann können sie auf einen Bassa klicken.
Ob sie das noch machen würden oder nicht.
Und es gibt dann vier fünf Fragen und dann wird das natürlich immer weniger. Wer möchte so.
Wer ist dazu noch bereit das zu tun und dann gibt es dann jemand der übrig bleibt und der macht das dann auch.
Und ich habe hier einen ganz ganz kurzen Auszug mal von drei verschiedenen Folgen.
Was für Fragen dort so gestellt werden Seid ihr bereit dies oder das zu tun. Da haben wir mal gerade rein.
Wer sagt denn Bauaufgabe Nummer vier. Da wäre ich auch mit dabei denn das ist der Pistole an Blowjob geben.
Wenn ihr da sagt Ja da bin ich nur mit von der Partie. Dann drückt jetzt 21 noch mit von der Partie und wer von euch würde sich denn auch noch selbst lachen.
Ihr könnte es schon fast ahnen. Wer würde sich denn auch genüsslich an furzen lassen. Wer würde das machen. Jetzt,
Wer von euch würde denn knurrend und bellend auf allen Vieren hier herumlaufen.
Wer würde das denn auch machen wenn hier im Kostüm auch noch natürlich Futter. Ganz klar Wer von euch würde denn dann auch noch eine Dose Hundefutter essen.
Bei solchen Fragen frage ich mich bei solche Sachen freilich immer wie Sie Wie sieht die Konferenz aus in der man sich so etwas ausdenkt.
Wie viel Zynismus geht.
Also sowohl konzeptionell als auch in konkreter Vorbereitung für die nächste Ausgabe. Welche Fragen denkt man sich aus Wie diskutiert man das durch.
Da muss man schon. Da muss man schon ziemlich abgestumpft sein vom Management auf die Kennziffern getrimmt sein auf die es am Ende ankommt.
Man muss völlig damit einverstanden sein dass es wirklich nur noch um das Generieren von Werbeplätze geht und alles andere dem untergeordnet ist inklusive der beteiligten Menschen.
Unter der Menschenwürde. Es ist wirklich ein ein ein so dummes Format wie wir es jetzt gerade hier hören konnten und dann wird das dann,
vollzogen und man hat dann immer so eine hohe rororo machen das Publikum dabei und es ist aber auch glaube ich so das trainieren.
Das ist eigentlich so dass das Trainingscamp des neoliberalen Subjekts was lässt es noch alles zu. Was lässt es noch über sich ergehen.
Also wozu ist es auch noch bereit um irgendwie ein bisschen Geld zu verdienen. Wir reden hier auch im übrigen nicht von besonders hohen Beträgen.
Also wir reden hier von 2000 2500 Euro. Das ist jetzt hier nicht die Show bei der man reich wird bei der man sich zum Affen gemacht hat und dann kann man sich aber gut mit Geld absetzen sondern hier wird eigentlich gezeigt,
Schau Du tust ja auch noch selbst weh und du bist auch noch Hundefutter um 2000 Euro zu bekommen und das ist eigentlich die ideologische Vorbereitung auf das was dann eben Leuten,
in irgendwelchen Jobs droht dass man ihnen sagt ja und du bekommst jetzt ein bisschen Geld dafür dass du den ganzen Tag da stehen musst nur lächeln muss immer freundlich sein muss und,
das möchte ich noch hinzufügen und tun dich dann auch nicht daran stört wenn dir der Messebesucher auch mal ein Klaps auf den Po gibt.
Also das sind diese ganzen Gewöhnungseffekt die da sind.
Im übrigen ist das ja auch wieder aufgetaucht dann von Joko und Klaas aus einer älteren Show einige Jahre her dass sie irgendeine Messe besucht haben und ein eine Chello stand darin bestand,
dass einer der beiden eine Messe Hostess betatschen sollte.
Das ist dann ein Klepp der jetzt auch wieder aufgetaucht ist.
Wobei man auch sagen muss naja das hätte man jetzt auch vor schon wissen müssen können sollen. Dass man das nicht macht.
Es ist vor allem auch ein Fitness-Studio für die Zuschauer da kann man ja sehr genau abmessen an den Einschaltquoten. Was wollen die Leute sehen.
Wann schlägt sozusagen die Sensationslust in meine Abneigung um.
Das kann man ja an Einschaltquoten sehr gut messen so etwas in der Hinsicht wirklich fatal auch hinsichtlich allem was ich auch meinte.
Doch eine gewisse Ausstrahlung von solchen Sachen sind schon Bühnen für Menschen die dann auch nacheifern.
Auf der anderen Seite ist wahrscheinlich der Druck aus dem Internet auch sehr hoch.
Ich habe jetzt Snapchat nicht Naivität sondern tick tack wieder gelöscht weil es einfach zu senden war.
Man kann sich tatsächlich auch bei youtube einfach einmal die Woche das Best of Video angucken dann sieht man alle.
Denn wenn man so einfach durch diesen Vietz kreuzt sieht man doch recht viele Menschen die einfach sterben sich indischer Straßenverkehr oder was auch immer diese ganzen Kletter Heinis die da die Gebäude rufen wie man sagt,
Es ist gar nicht so ungewöhnlich dass man bei Tec-Dax durchs scrollt und plötzlich so Todesfalle sieht natürlich nur im Panorama.
Aber man weiß bestimmt keiner überlebt.
Bei der Szene die man da gerade gesehen hat und wenn man da im Fernsehen mithalten will muss man sich natürlich Gedanken machen.
Und es folgt auch der YouTube Logik der Challenge.
Dort haben wir ja unglaublich viele erfolgreiche Youtuber die die ganze Zeit sich gegenseitig betteln und so etwas machen wie Wer kann am schnellsten Topf Hundefutter essen und solche Dinge werden ja da alle gemacht.
Wer legt sich in der Badewanne mit Maggi oder sonst was,
ist eigentlich diese Logik die von diesem Format übernommen wird und dieser,
Effekt der Ausstrahlung der ist dann am Ende auch weil es eben dauerhaft ist weil das eigentlich 24 Stunden pro ist viel größer als diese 15 Minuten und doch möchte ich noch einmal,
ganz kurz Palina Rojinski zitieren die spricht nämlich hier über Dick Picks und das ist nochmal ein Phänomen das man auch ein bisschen losgelöst von den Männerwelt sogar betrachten kann.
Ich finde es einfach unter aller Sau und ich finde das verstörend und ich finde das grenzt an virtuellen Missbrauch und ist passiert ohne Zustimmung und du kriegst du gehst halt in so ein Postfach auf einmal kommt da Genital mit und ich frage mich auch was sich die Männer denken.
Ich denke mir auch immer Es scheint ja doch ein erhebliches Problem zu sein.
Wahrscheinlich habe es wieder mit einem Problem zu tun wo zwei Prozent der Männer für 89 Prozent aller dickköpfig verantwortlich sind. Aber das ist mir völlig fremd. Meine.
Ich glaube nicht. Es ist ganz eigenartig.
Wir sprechen ja hier tatsächlich über eine Belästigung über den digitalen Weg dass Leute ungefragt DE-CIX von Männern zugeschickt bekommen.
Aber wir haben ja das große Phänomen Wir haben schon öfters darüber gesprochen Dating Plattformen Apps und wir haben es schon damit zu tun dass es heute nicht ungewöhnlich ist,
in Italien zu fotografieren und hin und her zu schicken ehe man sich zum Date trifft.
Das ist ein ziemlich weit verbreitetes Phänomen und das ist also wenn man Umfragen dann auch so,
liest oder wenn sich Leute dann in solchen Jugendmagazin zu Wort melden Zett oder sonstwas dann ist das ganz geläufig dass man natürlich beim Date vorher beim Sex Date dann ja meist,
vorher informiert sein will wie denn jemand genau beschaffen ist.
Und dann werden diese Dinge hin und hergeschickt was ja auch heute durch die Möglichkeiten gegeben ist dass man es eben selbst fotografieren kann.
Früher hatte man keine Nacktbilder von sich weil man sie entwickeln lassen.
Es ist sehr doppeldeutig auf der einen Seite diese anekdotischen Geschichten die vor allem dann so journalistisch gut aufgebaut werden können aus der Wissenschaft bekommt man dann doch immer wieder diese Hinweise dass die Jugend,
gerade so eine richtige Vernunft Wende durchmacht dass auch die Alters die die,
Alters zahlen beim ersten sexuellen Kontakt wieder ansteigen und so dass die ganze Pornografie dann doch nicht dazu führte dass so eine allgemeine Verlotterung stattfand.
So kann man auch mal keinen Reim darauf machen. SWR 2 Forum zum Thema Liebe oder so..
Da klickt man einmal klar die Botschaft Ja es gibt diese Anekdoten aber,
in der Realität sieht es dann doch ganz anders aus als in der Masse hat man es nicht mit so einer sexuellen Rechung zu tun sondern mit sehr viel Aufgeklärtheit und Vernunft und auch klarer,
klarer klarem Willen und klarer Willensbekundung und so.
Ja das mit Sicherheit. Ich glaube es wird sowieso Vertrags mäßiger durch diese Plattformen auch dass man vorher schon aushandelt was man denn überhaupt vor das findet statt was ja auch das ganze dazwischen minimiert.
Auch diese ganze Erotic die eigentlich entsteht auch aus den Zufällen heraus dass es eigentlich schon alles vorweggenommen.
Ich muss nur darauf hinweisen dass wir eigentlich ganz viele große Plattformen Dating Plattformen haben,
die ja zum Beispiel alle möglichen Zentimeter Angaben gestatten zu machen und die auch die Möglichkeit haben dass man quasi nochmal,
so ein Bonos abschließen kann oder jemanden das freischaltet oder gibts verschiedene Modelle.
Dass man dort dann sich nochmal nackt ganz nackt präsentiert während man sonst irgendwie immer so halb bekleidet dann eher ist so oder so.
Und dass man also sehr viel Blöße auch zeigt also bei denen bei Plattform die jetzt noch nicht nur auf Sex raus sind also nicht nur auf.
Es gibt ja solche solche reinen Sex Plattformen jetzt sondern alles was dazwischen ist wie Tinder oder so.
Dass dort auch schon extrem viel Haut gezeigt wird und es ist auch eigenartig und damit wäre man schon wieder sehr nah beim Porno dran dass man.
Eben sagt Ich muss jetzt auch alles wirklich einmal erst vorher sehen also es geht gar nicht mehr um die Idee dass man.
Eine Verhüllung hat die eigentlich erst die Erotik hergibt und diese muss dann losgelöst werden aber es und damit verändert sich aber auch das,
Bild vom Körper selbst wenn es glaub ich so ein paar alles dann werden kann sodass man die einzelnen Körperteile in Stücke zerhacken kann.
Das hatte etwas vom Close up das war ja lange Zeit auch so eine feministische Kritik an der Pornografie dass man sagte ja es wird nicht mehr der ganze Mensch also die ganze Frau als Objekt gesehen sondern sie wird in kleine Stücke durch die Close ups zerhackt.
Das findet jetzt gleichermaßen auch bei Männern statt. Und wir haben ja auch ein bisschen Trend kann man wohl da nicht sagen aber es gibt zumindest vermehrt Menschen die sich auch Schönheits,
Operationen unterziehen lassen für Geschlechtsteile und ich hab hier mal ein Zitat von Freud das hab ich eingelesen aus einem Text 1912 der heißt über die,
allgemeinste Erniedrigung des Liebeslebens und der sagt etwas über die Geschlechtsteile hier.
Das Experimentelle ist allzu innig und untrennbar mit dem sexuellen verwachsen.
Die Lage der Genitalien bleibt das bestimmende unveränderliche Moment. Man könnte hier ein bekanntes Wort des großen Napoléon variierend sagen.
Die Anatomie ist das Schicksal die Genitalien selbst haben die Entwicklung der menschlichen Körperformen zur Schönheit nicht mitgemacht sie sind tierisch geblieben.
Und so ist auch die Liebe im Grunde heute ebenso animalisch wie sie es von je her war.
Das ist natürlich sehr gut denn Freud damals heute dieses ganze Wir haben Bilder Videos und so dazwischen haben wir natürlich wieder diese schöne Phase von Text.
Der Roman der Film der sich nicht alles erlauben darf weil er öffentlich gezeigt wird und so weiter.
Vielleicht war das auch ein bisschen zu romantisch.
Notgedrungen sozusagen durch technische Limitierung. Denn warum sollte man Texten wenn man auch genausogut picken kann mit Bildern arbeiten kann liegt natürlich irgendwie auf der Hand auf der anderen Seite muss man wahrscheinlich auch feststellen,
Jeder hat seine spezifischen Lebensphasen,
die passend zu einer spezifischen historischen Entwicklung sind und schon zehn Jahre später sieht Jugend ganz anders aus und man wird als Teilnehmer niemals erfahren wie es tatsächlich ist weil so viel dazugehört,
eigentlich wissen zu wollen wie sie sich anfühlt. Und da gibt's Neuzugänge.
Deswegen ist das immer ein Mysterium damals bei Freud schon diese ganze Lustigkeit und jetzt wieder.
Das Verschicken von DE-CIX ist scheint mir kein Jugend Phänomen zu sein.
Ich habe da aus bekannten Kreisen schon schon anderes gehört aber was Freud hier anspricht ist eine hochinteressante überlegung der ich auch zustimmen würde nämlich dass Italien an sich nicht schön sind.
Er sagt ja sie haben diese evolutionäre Entwicklung hin zur Schönheit nicht mitgemacht. Und das stimmt.
Und er bringt ja auch noch einmal diese Nähe zum experimentellen die wir ja haben da es sich auch um Ausschaltung der Organe handelt.
Und das heißt also das zeigt auch nochmal diese Größe dieser Belästigung die durch diese aufgefordert einen gesendeten DE-CIX stattfindet.
Wir haben es bei diesen Geschlechtsteilen nicht mit an sich schönen Dingen zu tun sondern nur wenn sie mit einer Lust mit einer Begierde aufgeladen sind.
Und diese ist meistens dann doch an die gesamte Person gekoppelt und an eine gewisse Fantasie und all das und auch an ein wollen dann nur werden Geschlechtsteile als schön empfunden.
Denn sonst würde man hätte man kein Sex und würde sie nicht anfassen nicht den Mund nehmen was auch immer damit tun und das heißt diese Belästigung ist deshalb besonders groß.
Würde man jetzt einfach sagen Ich schicke jemandem unaufgefordert mein Gesicht dann ist das das eine aber das Geschlechtsteil kann also von dem anderen gar nicht als,
schön empfunden werden und ist deshalb in besonderem Maße eine Belästigung weil Geschlechtsteile gar nicht schön sind.
Aber genau da kann man ja wieder fragen warum die Verknüpfung zur Schönheit sind wir da sozusagen einer,
entsprechenden durch technische Limitierung gezwungenermaßen so und so gestalteten kulturellen Aufarbeitung zum Opfer gefallen.
Vielleicht ist es vielleicht gar nichts verloren wenn man dann jetzt wieder feststellt.
Aber es ist halt was anderes das dick Pick zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass es nicht inhaltlich.
Da würde man das Selfie nehmen wenn man sozusagen inhaltlich zeigen will wer ist man eigentlich.
Das kann man ja dann schlecht am DKK festmachen da müssen wir uns nicht nehmen sondern das dicke Pic zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass es eben doch etwas Verbotenes ist was eigentlich verstecktes was zu enthüllen ist was aber hier einfach mal so enthüllt wird obwohl,
das eigentlich darf die Zweisamkeit ankommt dass man sich gegenseitig einhüllt und so weiter und das Werturteil Schönheit.
Würde ich sagen kann in der Liste natürlich auch auftauchen.
Ich würde es ein bisschen höher ranken als du aber es ist jetzt nicht Das massgebliche sondern da geht es tatsächlich um etwas anderes.
Genau. Man kann übrigens einführen es gibt jemand der das getan hat was auch für Irritationen gesorgt hatte und zwar hat ja Fritz J.
Raddatz der große Literaturkritiker der Zeit also der Antipode Reich-Ranickis,
Tagebuch geführt sehr ausführlich und diese beiden Tagebuch Bände sind sehr lesenswert und Fritz Raddatz hat wenig anbrennen lassen und hatte immer sehr viele junge Männer,
im Bett gehabt und gerne vermerkte er im Tagebuch,
dass dieser oder jener einen eleganten Schwanz hatte.
Da war die ästhetik schon wichtig. Was nicht heißt dass dieser Weg zur Schönheit was Freud hier beschreibt ist natürlich nicht dass man sich vor Geschlechtsteilen Eigentlich ekelt.
Und ich wollte auch nicht das damit ausdrücken wenn ich sage Sie sind nicht schön sondern dass sie nicht in der Form den Weg zur Schönheit gemacht haben.
Man könnte ja sagen Warum tragen wir sie nicht im Gesicht.
Das nicht. Es ist etwas sehr Eigenartiges was ja auch für Freud nicht ganz auflösbar ist dass es eben mit einem etwas experimentellem zusammenhängt dass es nicht,
das ist was man sagt als Form funktioniert das so in der Schönheit wie zum Beispiel,
ein muskulöser Bauch oder auch ein Busen oder so ist er etwas was man in anderer Weise als schön empfindet.
Aber wie soll ich sagen wenn Wenn wir jetzt durch diese Digg Bäckerei wieder feststellen wird auch medial technisch wieder erschlossen was vorher nicht sichtbar war.
Wir hatten ja jetzt sagen wir mal so auf fünf Jahre oder zehn Jahre I-Phone oder so.
Da kam die Kamera ans Telefon und seitdem gibt es dick Picks die Jahrzehnte davor hatten wir schon so eine durch Ironisierung des Körperlichen.
Und zwar volle Kanne auf Bezug Schönheit.
Es gab einen sehr schönen Spruch Ich weiß ja heute noch bringen kann aber Claudius Seidl meinte in einer F.A.Z.
Mal Haupttext erfreut sich eigentlich immer auf den Sommer denn es ist die Zeit in der Hand über all die Bademode ausstellt und dann läuft man die Straße lang und läuft an einer schönen Frau nach der anderen vorbei weil einfach jede Bushaltestelle so ein,
Bademoden Motel irgendwie präsentierter.
Da hat man ja schon so eine wie soll man sagen Man kann jetzt sagen.
Claudius Seidl aber voll ins falsche Register und reduziert die Frau wieder auf ein körperliches rein sexuelles Objekt er interessiert sich ja gar nicht dafür was die Frau sonst noch kann außer schön aussehen.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir eben nicht diese Reduktion auf Geschlechtsteile die dann auch noch für Ausscheidungen zuständig sind sondern wir haben eigentlich so eine,
ganzheitliche Erotik die sogar im Straßenbild funktioniert.
Das wird ja gerade auch wieder ein bisschen zurückgedrängt dadurch dass das Silicon Valley so rigoros,
jede Form von nackten Brüsten und so weiter einfach eiskalt weg zensiert sodass man wieder eine klare Trennung hat zwischen der angezogenen Person die wir so begegnen und dem radikalen dickköpfig auf der anderen Seite und der Zwischenraum dazwischen geht halt gerade wieder verloren.
Der war allerdings schon so eine gewisse kulturelle Errungenschaft. Ich glaube diese ganzen.
Ich glaube das ist auch das was du da gerade beschrieben hast.
Auf der einen Seite die zensierte Brust auf der anderen das sind die beiden Seiten einer Medaille die wir da gerade erleben und genau dieses,
Ich will das ganzheitlich nennen nicht im anthroposophischen Sinne aber so dass der,
ganze Mensch da war im übrigen ja auch der Mann der ja durch,
diese ganzen Mode Kampagnen in den 90er Jahren auch viel stärker ironisiert wurde auch durch die Werbung wie zum Beispiel,
die Cola light Werbung also die man auch als sexuell begehrenswert ausstellte und so hatten wir das gehabt und ich jetzt haben wir,
eine ganz eigenartige Trennung dadurch und,
hinzu kommen eben diese Belästigung die damit einhergeht und auch,
ein ganz eigenartiges,
Verständnis von Sexualität. Das ist schon genau das was jetzt auch ein Herbert Marcuse kritisiert hat in Der eindimensionale Mensch dass es also überhaupt,
nur noch so einen Trieb Leben gibt das auf die auf die Genitalien ausgerichtet sind aber den Rest vollkommen aussparen will. Und das zeigt sich daran.
Vielleicht erleben wir. Vielleicht erleben wir hier vielleicht gerade einem stillen Kulturkampf auf der Spur.
Denn ich habe mich erinnert dass ich bei Google News zuletzt wieder so einen typischen irgendwas eingeschneiten zeigt nackte Brust auf Instagram aber irgendwie prominent ist wo man es nicht so einfach weg zensieren konnte.
Und wenn man jetzt auf Google immerhin noch nackte Brüste Instagram schaut dann tauchen da doch ganz schön viele Namen auf.
Also Supermodel Alessandra Ambrosio zeigt nackte Brüste bei Instagram Heidi Klum zeigt nackte Brüste auf Instagram Cara Delevingne oder wie sie heißt.
Ich habe Ihren Namen noch nie ausgesprochen wird mir nackte Brüste auf Instagram der nächste Veer,
nackte Brüste. Na gut es geht also durch meine ich natürlich nackte Brüste Instagram.
Es gibt immer wieder diese Versuche diesen Raum dann doch mal wieder fruchtbar zu machen für nicht ganz so rigoroses und damit eben auch besondere Betonung dieser Digg Bäckerei.
Dass man es vielleicht mal aber Stefanie Liesinger Oben ohne Dekolleté Hammer weiß.
Man merkt schon dass die die auf das hätte jetzt in den 70er Jahren nicht stattgefunden.
Dass man daraus eine Headline machen konnte. Wenn sich jemand oben ohne zeigt.
Ich kenne kaum einen 70er Jahre Film in dem auch das männliche Genital durchaus hin und wieder zu sehen ist wenn auch nicht wie jetzt bei den dick.
Ich würde noch zum Abschluss eine kurze Passage bringen aus Roland Barthes Buch Die helle Kammer da setzt er sich mit Fotografie auseinander und Roland Barthes war ein wichtiger,
französischer symbiotisch oder Philosoph.
Und der schreibt eben auch etwas über das pornografische Bild.
Ein anderes eiförmige Foto ist das Pornografische Foto.
Ich sage nicht das Erotische das Erotische ist ein gestörtes riesiges pornografisches Bild nichts homogenes als eine pornografische Fotografie,
wie ein Schaufenster in dem angestrahlt nur ein einziges Schmuckstück gezeigt wird geht sie vollkommen in der Zurschaustellung einer einzigen Sache auf,
des Geschlechts nie ein zweites unpassendes Motiv das halb verdeckt verzögert oder ablenken würde.
Eine Gegenprobe Mapplethorpe lässt seine Großaufnahmen von Genitalien vom pornografischen ins Erotische übergehen indem er den Stoff der Unterhose aus nächster Nähe fotografiert.
Das Foto ist nicht mehr einförmig da ich mich für die Struktur des Stoffes interessiere.
Ja das ist ein bisschen hin gebogen. Ob das bei Robert Math ja ob das bei Robert Mapplethorpe wirklich so ist bzw.
Clever über Bande gespielt.
Ob er überhaupt da ein erotisches Foto schaffen wollte oder ob er nicht eher dort sehr abstrakte Werke macht.
Es gibt diese Serie Kox Flowers und er fotografiert eben Genitalien und,
Penisse und Blumen und diese stellt er dann noch immer so aneinander.
Das sind aber eher Fotos die auf so eine abstrakte Weise glaube ich eher zu rezipieren sind als dass man sie erotisch,
empfinden sollte ich glaube dass da Roland Barthes sich ein wenig irrt.
Ich glaube aber was stimmt ist das tatsächlich das Pornografische Foto.
Ein Geheimnis loses ist das auch dieses dickköpfig versenden.
Irgendwie versucht eine Wahrheit sichtbar zu machen irgendwie das reale an sich zu machen was er aber gar nicht herstellbar ist weil das Ding auch etwas vollkommen Banales ist was dann auch zu entsprechendem stoppt Spott,
für entsprechenden Spott auf widerum sorgen kann.
Wir haben das ja Anfang des Jahres hier erlebt wir haben das nicht thematisiert gehabt nämlich beim Wendler gab es ja das Gerücht dass das ein dickköpfig von ihm sei das es nicht bestätigt worden.
Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall wurde das dann sogar ein Twitter Trend für einen Tag lang das heißt wir haben dann auch damit gleich diese Peinlichkeit die damit verbunden ist und auch etwas was wir nicht vergessen sollten.
Es ist ein bisschen so das Kokettieren damit dass man damit unter Beweis stellen will dass man potent ist dass man,
den Phallus hat aber der Phallus kann nur dann wirklich auch als ein solcher begriffen werden dass man eher einem gehört wenn er bestätigt wird.
Die Frau soll in irgendeiner Weise darauf reagieren.
Da könnte Freud da könnte auch Lacan sehr viel für drüber sagen.
Aber es ist wirklich ein sehr abstruses Phänomen und es ist glaube ich für alle Beteiligten am Ende furchtbar.
Ja aber da kommt mir gerade noch ein Gedanke den will ich am Ende noch anführen.
Das versende der Digg Pec hat so wie immer wenn es so sexuell wird natürlich wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel mit Macht zu tun mit so einer Machtdemonstration,
die korrespondiert mit versende das dickköpfig also bin ich in der machtvollen und ich setze drauf und dazu zählt auch der Nervenkitzel dass die Empfängerin meistens eine Frau,
damit er eine Machtposition gesetzt wird nämlich vor Scham nicht mal.
In ihrem nahen Umfeld das Recht nicht öffentlich darüber zu sprechen.
Samira ist ja nun sehr viele Jahre mit sich getragen um dann mal an die öffentlichkeit zu gehen sie hätte sich ja auch damals sofort umdrehen können fragen Waren Sie nie Sind Sie bescheuert oder was.
Es wäre auch eine denkbare Reaktion warum sie nicht kam hat sie ja gut beschrieben und es ist ja schon interessant.
Dass wir diese Erwartung bei Männern haben dass Frauen darauf ohnmächtig reagieren.
Es gab kürzlich habe ich Richard Gutjahr gehört der wurde ja nun auch dieser Journalist sehr angefeindet und mit Verschwörungstheorien und so weiter belästigt und bedroht.
Und er hat seinen Tipp Wenn man wenn man so eine Post bekommt die klar auf ein gemünzt ist und die sozusagen ging es nicht um die dickköpfig sondern klare Anfeindungen juristisch also digitale Gewalt.
Dann auf jeden Fall einen Screenshot machen und zwar so Polizei sich ja dass man die komplette Ulme drauf hat und so weiter und auch wieder veröffentlichen und zwar an der Stelle wo sie hingehört beispielsweise auf den Twitter-Kanal desjenigen,
Man bekommt eine DM und poste die dann aber öffentlich zurück unter die aktuellste Tweet Sache oder so die da aufgekommen ist sodass dann derjenige unter Zugzwang ist sich dafür erklären zu müssen.
Und das ist natürlich bei De-Cix auch eine Strategie dass man den Frauen einfach sagt Naja juristisch wäre es wahrscheinlich so dass wir es hier mit einer.
Persönlich identifizierbaren Informationssuche zu tun haben also mit dem Datenschutz eigentlich.
Aber erstens diese Person hat ja zugestimmt dass das das eigene Handy verlässt das Bild ist ja angekommen und es ist ja kein Gesicht drauf.
In der Hinsicht sollte man könnte man ja durchaus umgehen damit dass man es einfach veröffentlicht dass man einen wirklichen Pranger schafft.
Also ein Penis Pranger den man einfach öffentlich einrichtet.
Ich hoffe es wird nicht Twitter. Sonst kann man gar nicht mehr auf Twitter gehen.
Das wäre natürlich bei Twitter. Bei Twitter wird es Zwitter verweigern aber so als Projekt dass man einfach sagt Wir machen jetzt Twitter Prange und dann einfach dass Frauen einfach mal vielleicht so eine Kunstprojekts eine Einladung machen.
Das wäre eine schöne Seite ja.
Schaut doch dahin ob ihr den kennt und wenn ja sagt uns doch wer das ist.
Dass man so eine Verknüpfung schafft wieder um die Person wieder ganz ins Bild zu holen die sich da so illegitimen partiell veräußert hat dass man irgendwie so Strategien findet dazu gehört,
dass man als allererstes an dieser Machtposition arbeitet und wie bei Samira A eine gewisse mediale,
Formgebung erlaubt dann doch sich in der Rolle des mächtigen zurückzubringen und beispielsweise darüber zu schreiben,
und darüber dann auch Unterstützung zu generieren oder vielleicht tatsächlich diejenigen die sich in dieser machtvollen Rolle sehen also die Versender des Diktats,
einfach in eine Ohnmacht Position zu bringen indem man zeigt gut du kannst dich ja gerne auf dieser Pinnwand verewigen.
Aber dann hast du es halt nicht mehr an der Hand. Du kannst nicht darauf setzen dass die Frau jetzt voller Scham das Bild dann möglichst schnell löscht und der Effekt den du wolltest sozusagen bei ihr bleibt und sonst nichts sondern dann Nebenfolgen wer möchte schon viel über Nebenfolgen gesprochen.
Dann hätte man dann so eine Nebenfolgen mit der man dann wenn man die einkalkulieren muss. Es werden vielleicht weniger verschickt.
Vielleicht das wäre ganz schön Maple 2.0 oder dann auch gesellschaftspolitisch gewendet denn das waren diese Fotos doch eher nicht.
Und es ist ein bisschen Warhol dann auch wieder wo wir ja schon über Warhol sprachen bei den 15 Minuten Warhol hat ja selbst auch dick Picks gesammelt und zwar seiner ganzen,
Herren mit denen er dort zusammen gearbeitet und geschlafen hat oder geschlafen weiß ich gar nicht ich er war da sehr eigenartig.
Man ist unterwegs auf jeden Fall hatte er dort eine große Sammlung gehabt also das Gehörte auch für ihn zur künstlerischen Auseinandersetzung und jetzt könnte man das nochmal wie du es beschrieben hast wenden ins Gesellschaftspolitische Ja das,
haben wir doch wieder eine schöne Idee geliefert für ein Künstlerkollektiv das vielleicht gerade nicht auftreten kann.
Seien Dosen Wänden.
Haben wir ihn auch noch untergebracht sehr gut passt sehr gut dann reden wir doch mal über Verschwörungstheorien.
Verschwörungstheorien sind besonders interessant weil es jeder Verschwörungstheorie eine Verschwörungstheorie Theoretiker gibt der diese Verschwörungstheorie gleich wieder als Theorie entlarvt und das natürlich nur mit einer eigenen Theorie.
Es dreht sich also immer im Kreis. Deswegen fragen wir uns alle.
Verschwörungstheorie gibt es nicht ein schöneres Wort Albrecht von Lucke hat jetzt von Ideologie gesprochen.
Das präferierte ich sehr finde ich sehr gut. Verschwörung.
Genau weil Ideologie auch bedeuten kann falsches Bewusstsein.
Also Es gibt verschiedene Ideologie kritische Ansätze. Manche sagen Naja jeder hat eine Ideologie und wir alle sprechen von ideologischen Standpunkten aus aber man kann den Begriff Ideologie auch durchaus negativ,
verwenden und sagen Ideologie ist falsches Bewusstsein und das macht dann der Kritiker der Verschwörungstheorie oder der Theoretiker der Verschwörungstheorie zu sagen.
Wo liegt denn das falsche Bewusstsein welchen Schleier muss man da wegziehen.
Genau. Dann noch im Angebot ist Verschwörung Mystic. Man würde dann diffamiert als Verschwörung,
und was ja all diesen Ideen anhängt ist dass man einer Verschwörungstheorie einer Verschwörung Mystic eine Ideologie mit einem Gegenentwurf begegnet weshalb die Debatten immer Banane sind.
Irgendwer erzählte was von Bill Gates und sagst du ne nicht Bill Gates. Aber andere Namen in die Diskussion ein.
Fragt man sich Hat man Wasser mit Feuer bekämpft und am Ende löscht sich alles aus oder heizt sich erst richtig an.
Wie auch immer Es ist jedenfalls schwierig über Verschwörungstheorien zu reden weshalb ich dachte wir machen mal neuen Dreh hier zum einen,
möchte ich da verweisen auf den Salon Wir werden das Buch von Katharina Nocun und Pia Lamberti Fake Facts lesen.
Ich kenne es zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht ist aber auch nicht so schlimm denn wie gesagt Wir kommen darauf zurück und ich will vorher nochmal nach anderen.
Themen Einschlag machen für den ich wieder in Anspruch nehme dass dieser Podcast ein gewisser Safe Space ist wo man das einfach so machen kann.
Denn es ist so die Verschwörungstheorie wird ja abgelehnt egal welche. Man kann jetzt querbeet egal welche.
Die werden ja im Grunde wenn sie auf aufgeklärte Gemüter treffen abgelehnt weil ihnen eine Realität gegenübersteht.
Und jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen Was ist das für eine Realität.
Was hat es damit auf sich.
Verschwörung. Glaube kann man in eine Verschwörung glauben mit einem nicht Glauben begegnen oder geht man bei jeder Diskussion immer in die Falle.
Eine an einen glauben gegenüberzustellen. Nein es ist nicht Bill Gates natürlich Angela Merkel die entscheidet was jetzt gewonnen.
Wenn man so darüber spricht und das du mir in diesen Clip geschickt dann kann man ja zum Eingang durchmischte durchaus mal spielen wie Joko und Klaas.
Wenn sie denn mal einen hellen Moment haben wie ihn unterstellt wird nämlich Sie haben 50 Minuten gewonnen und das ging ja noch nie so richtig schief das ist dann das Feigenblatt.
Da kann man ja mal das eine oder andere versuchen und in dem Falle wie es ist das die aktuelle Sendung die jetzt diese Woche zum Thema Verschwörungstheorien so wie es,
geht. Also sind wir auch noch aktuell. Ist ja nicht ganz verkehrt.
Wir hören mal am Ende in 50 Minuten rein so gegen Ende als sie eine Frage aufwerfen und ich würde dann gerne nur ein Wort einfach kritisieren wodurch dann so ein ganzes Gedenk Gebäude zusammenfallen kann.
Unsere Frage 150 Euro. Was glauben Sie wer weiß mehr über Coronavirus A.
Ein weltweit anerkannter Experte auf dem Gebiet der Virologie der knapp 20 Jahre speziell im Bereich der Coruna Viren forscht.
Jochen Thee von Facebook der sich mit Viren beschäftigt seitdem er seine Wurst nur mit Maske im Supermarkt kaufen darf hat geschrieben nach der neuen Medizin gibt es keine Viren und man kann sich nicht anstecken gerade das wird weltweit proklamiert.
Kann jemand die Diskrepanz erklären.
Zugeschlagen.
Christian Rost oder Jochen T.
Professor Dr. Christian Moment Moment Moment es ist noch nicht klar es ist noch nicht klar. Stimmt das wirklich.
Professor Dr. Christian Drosten weiß er mehr über das Thema.
Wir schauen mal nach ist das richtig.
Okay Modus einer Spielshow und so weiter. Sie stellen am Anfang die Frage Was glauben Sie wer weiß mehr ist natürlich entlarvend.
Man kann es nur glauben. Woher will man wissen was glauben sie und dann ruft jemand an und zögert noch kurz bevor die Antwort einhüllt denn es muss erst von der Maschine enthüllt werden.
Ich will es nicht zu tiefgehend aber er muss erst auf den Knopf gedrückt werden und die Maschine enthüllt dann Ja es ist Christian Drosten der mehr weiß.
Man hätte es natürlich auch einfach korrekt machen könnte. Wem vertrauen Sie mehr beim Sohn so glauben sie ihm vertrauen sie mehr denn wenn man richtigen Modus und am Ende hätte man dann endlich die Maschine entscheiden lassen sondern eine ehrlich sagen müssen wie wir alle wissen,
ist es Christian Drosten. Weil mehr Anhaltspunkte gibt's auch nicht.
Es ist doch ein Abwägen und auf summieren und Unterstützung und Zustimmung bekunden dass am Ende dazu führt dass man eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit dann doch als solches anerkennt oder nicht. Es gibt genug Moody.
Hier sind wir wieder bei diesem Phänomen das wir schon einmal angesprochen haben dass die Moderne eben doch auch ganz viel auf Vertrauen basieren muss dass sie auch darauf basieren muss dass wir gar nicht alles genau wissen können.
Wir könnten selbstverständlich jetzt sagen Wir ziehen uns jetzt zwei Jahre zurück und lesen uns in biologische Forschungsgebiete ein.
Und wir können dann in zwei Jahren vielleicht annähernd wirklich eine Fachdiskussion verfolgen ob wir sie dann auch schon bewerten können sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber wir müssen darauf vertrauen eigentlich auf jemanden wie Drosten.
Wie wir darauf vertrauen dass der BMW morgens anspringt der uns auf die Arbeit bringt.
Vertrauen ist ein. Wie soll man sagen Ein soziologischer Grundbegriff der sozusagen zwei Ausprägungen kennt System vertrauen.
Also man vertraut in den Fahrplan des Busses Institution des Rechts und so weiter.
Dass es die gibt und dass sie auch tun was sie sagen. Oder es Personen Vertrauen und hier in diesem Maße bei der Virologie.
Da fällt System vertrauen so ein bisschen aus Wir können natürlich Wissenschaftlern.
Wir müssen Wissenschaftlern glauben und ihnen vertrauen wenn sie uns sagen,
Ich habe beim Peer Review teilgenommen und das Verfahren hat dies und jenes Ergebnis Wir können nicht in die Institution selbst rein blicken dazu fehlt uns die Kompetenz und auch die Kapazität.
Wir können jetzt nicht das Labor von Christian Drosten angucken sondern wenn der aufzählt wieviel Viren er Wo findet und das publiziert.
Dann ist es Aufgabe der Wissenschaft.
Das Wissen abzusichern das Wissen zu erhärten und dann fallen wir leider wieder darauf zurück dass wir einer Person vertrauen.
Das ist glaube ich das Allerwichtigste Wir vertrauen hier Personen bei Verschwörungstheorien wo sie anfallen das hat meistens irgendwas mit der politischen Sphäre zu tun.
Da gilt noch umso mehr was in der Wissenschaft schon gilt Wir müssen ja Personen Vertrauen.
Deswegen haben wir ja ein großes Glück in Deutschland dass wir jemanden wie Christian Drosten haben der in seinem Podcast,
genau dieses Angebot macht nämlich Vertrauens Anker zu sein in einer Kommunikation die wir inhaltlich auf gar keinen Fall dadurch steigen können es muss uns alles erklärt werden und dann müssen wir uns entscheiden,
wem vertrauen wir eigentlich und das finde ich,
ganz herausragend wie Drosten selbst darüber spricht weshalb wir hier noch einmal kurz in sein 41.
Podcast reinhören wie er über seine eigene Postkarte Podcast Arbeit spricht.
Es ist auch das was mich hier am stärksten antreibt trotz aller Angriffe weiter bei der Sache zu bleiben einfach um,
bestimmte wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse zu übersetzen für eine erfreulicherweise vorhandene sehr breite Bevölkerungsgruppe von Interessierten und Informationen suchenden Hörern die mir auch sehr viel Bestätigung geben.
Er kriegt sehr viel Bestätigung von Hörern für seine Leistung die er bringt und das sagt er ausdrücklich seine übersetzung.
Er bietet uns nicht die Wissenschaft selbst obwohl es gute Argumente gibt.
Moritz Klenk Blot kürzlich bei einem Podcaster gegeben.
Diese Kommunikation die Drosten macht durchaus selbst schon Wissenschaft ist und da hänge ich auch ein bisschen an.
Aber gut seine Selbstbeschreibung ist eine übersetzung.
So weit so nachvollziehbar und so richtig. Und für diese übersetzung brauchen wir einen guten Lehrer.
Das ist wichtig es ist ein guter Lehrer erforderlich.
Dieser gute Lehrer muss nicht gleichzeitig ein guter Forscher sein.
Diese Verbindung von Forschung und Lehre hat einen gewissen institutionellen Sinn und dieses ganze Humboldtsche Ideal aber hierfür reicht es völlig.
Ein guter Lehrer zu sein gute Erklärer jemand der versteht was geschieht.
Er muss nicht die Erkenntnisse die er lehrt selbst hervorbringen sondern es reicht völlig wenn er nachvollziehen kann.
Die Methoden zum Beispiel die andere Wissenschaftler verwenden. Das macht beispielsweise diesen Streit zwischen Alexander Kekulé und Drosten.
Streit kann man nie richtig sagen sondern Kekulé hat in einer ungünstigen Zeit eine Antwort geschrieben auf eine Frage die sich journalistisch stellte eine journalistische Publikation die daraufhin von Drosten,
massenmedial zurückgewiesen wurde ohne nochmal inhaltlich nachzulegen.
Man hat da komplett die Wissenschaft verlassen in diesem Moment und sich da so verfangen gestern nicht.
Das macht so etwas zum Beispiel besonders interessant weil man kann jetzt nicht einfach kommen und sagen Drosten ist ja ein besserer Biologe als Kekulé.
Das gelingt ihm auch die übersetzung des verständlich zu machen besser.
Denn was diese übersetzung angeht würde ich jetzt Privatmeinung privat Urteil Riches Werturteile.
Würde ich sagen gelingt es eigentlich Kekulé besser sich verständlich zu machen.
Also ich verstehe was Drosten manchmal so nicht gerne höre ich Kekulé und dann fällt der Groschen ja da verstehe ich so ein bisschen worum es da geht verdreht sich da einiges und man sollte nicht zu schnell urteilen mit natürlich Trossen weil der forscht er auch.
Also da muss man erstens die übersetzung Schulleistung als eigene Leistung und dann vertrauen hier Personen die uns etwas Inhaltliches erzählen.
Und jetzt möchte ich dass wir alle gemeinsam mal zurückschauen denn Verschwörungstheorie hat ja immer damit zu tun dass jetzt gerade was im Gange ist.
Jemand hat sich verschworen hat ein politisches Anliegen das er nicht öffentlich offenbart sondern bleibt damit im Verborgenen aus Gründen die dann ermittelt werden von den Verschwörungstheoretikern,
und wir können natürlich auch einfach sagen Bevor wir jetzt erinnertsich die bei irgendeiner Idee können wir uns auch.
Die Anliegen von Verschwörungstheorien anschauen und mal nicht Verschwörungstheorien nehmen die im Raum stehen.
Es wird ja auch sehr viel Gerede über Kuroda gesprochen ohne dass da Verschwörungstheorie drin steckt und gleichzeitig schauen wir mal auf die schon geschriebene Geschichte zurück.
Also wir blicken sozusagen auf die drei Monate zurück die dreiMonate Geschichte Corona die wir jetzt alle live miterlebt haben.
Beim letzten Mal war er kurz angesprochen wie das Bewusstsein da jetzt beteiligt ist bei diesen ganzen Prozessen.
Da gab es natürlich ein sehr interessantes Video von Mai.
So ist der Youtube-Kanal von der jungen Chemikerin die hat sechs Millionen Views über 6 Millionen Views. Das Video ist vom 4.
April ist also nicht besonders alt ist aber ein historisches Dokument weil seitdem natürlich sehr viel passiert ist und wir schauen hier nochmal kurz rein wie wir am 6..
Am 4. April zwei Tage nach dem Peak am 3.
April gab es in Deutschland mehr als 6000 Coruña Nachweise.
Das ist eine ganz andere Zeit als wie wir in dieser Hochzeit als wir noch die exponentielle Kurve aufsteigen gesehen haben und sie war schon bedrohlich hoch wie wir da drüber gedacht haben.
Das Denken inhaltlich hat sozusagen Mailath vorgegeben und wir haben uns vertrauensvoll an Sie gewendet.
Und das ist genau so gemeint so wie wir auch uns an Merkel gehalten haben diese Empfehlung hat sie ja nicht ohne Grund gemacht. Man kann dann über die Methoden der 15 Minuten kann man streiten aber es war ja.
Die Hütte brannte ja ganz schön so eine exponentielle Kurve. Da weiß man zwei Tage länger und zack steht wirklich alles lichterloh in Flammen.
Und unter diesem Eindruck wurde natürlich im April ein bisschen anders diskutiert als jetzt und jetzt können wir nochmal in diesen vierten April rein.
Orientieren wir uns mal an dem Tag an dem Jens Spahn sagte dass man Veranstaltungen mit mehr als tausend Menschen absagen sollte spätestens dann gab es offenbar ein Problem mit der nachverfolgt an diesem Tag gab es in Deutschland ungefähr 1000 Fälle.
Nehmen wir es einfach mal an tausend wäre jetzt die Fallzahl die noch handelbar wäre ohne dass wir jetzt irgendwelche drastischen socialiste Maßnahmen für alle bräuchten.
Das haben wir heute circa 70000 Fälle können wir hier einstellen dass wir ab dem Tag wo die Epidemie 70000 Fälle hat die Reproduktion,
von zwei auf 0,5 herunterdrücken Revolutionsjahr 0,5 Das ist volle Kanone das ist Wuhan Shylock und so muss man sich das vorstellen und unter diesen Annahmen,
würde es 56 Tage dauern bis wir wieder weniger als 1000 verletzen also fast zwei Monate.
Das sollte jetzt natürlich keine Prognose sein sondern nur ein Beispiel Szenario um ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen wie lange das noch dauern könnte.
Am 4. April haben wir gedacht wenn wir volle Kanne lock down machen wie sie sagte brauchen wir 56 Tage um wieder unter den Wert von 100 täglichen Fällen zu kommen weil wie sie meinte,
ich nochmal extra ausgeklammert.
Nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal an tausend wäre jetzt die Fallzahl die noch handelbar wäre ohne dass wir jetzt irgendwelche drastischen socialiste Maßnahmen für alle bräuchten.
Ist schon interessant dass wir nicht 56 Tage brauchten um wieder auf unter 1000 zu kommen.
Denn tatsächlich lagen wir schon am 8. Mai also seit dem 8.
Mai durchgängig unter 00:00 nachweisen am tag täglich nachweisen und der erste Tag unter tausend war sogar der 26.
April mit 702 nachweisen.
Also wir sind ohne Wuhan lock down.
Hab ich jetzt gar nicht ausgerechnet aber in einem Monat und drei vier Tagen ungefähr 56 Tage sondern mehr 35 36 Tage also 20 Tage vorher sind wir zurück auf diese tausend Fälle gekommen.
Das ist das eine. Wir waren in der pessimistischsten oder bzw. optimistischsten aber was die politischen Folgen ob pessimistisch.
Niemand darf mehr raus und so weiter.
Das haben wir sozusagen unterboten und gleichsam akzeptieren wir derzeit nicht mehr als tausend.
So eine wie sie sagt sehr schwammiger aber eben doch mal eine Zahl bei der man sagen kann Bei 000 Fällen am Tag kann man braucht man keine allgemeinen Maßnahmen mehr für alle beispielsweise Schulschließungen.
Und ich finde es schon interessant dass wir auf der einen Seite so eine krasse Ablehnung von Verschwörungstheorien und Riches Diffamieren von Verschwörungstheorien begucken Gaspar Jakobiner oder wie das neue Magazin können sich da eher Jakobiner oder Jakobiner.
Jakobinischen wenn dann die englische Sprechweise übernimmt.
Also,
man soll nicht auf die Demonstranten schauen und lachen sondern sich ernsthaft mit dem befassen.
Und gleichzeitig würde ich sagen wenn wir denn lachen wir können durchaus uns Verschwörungstheoretiker jetzt vornehmen und denen einfach sagen Das ist ja alles Banane was du erzählst.
Gleichzeitig haben wir aber wenn wir zurückblicken auf unser Denken der letzten zwei Monate auch die eine oder andere Revision also wenigstens im Denken sagt keiner.
Dass die Maßnahmen falsch waren oder sogar sondern man hat ja nicht mal die Krisenmaßnahmen genommen aber es ist tatsächlich so dass wir,
auf weniger als 100 Fälle pro Tag kamen in der doppelten Geschwindigkeit wie Mailath das in der krassesten Version.
Und sie hat sich da am Imperial College in diesen Kalkulationen orientiert. Annahmen.
Und trotzdem sind beispielsweise in Hessen immer noch die Grundschulen zu.
Und da ist es finde ich irgendwie verständlich dass sich Menschen jetzt Gedanken darüber machen warum ist das eigentlich so.
Weil das eigentliche denken der nicht Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Dieses gar nicht hergibt. Dass die Schulen immer noch zu sind denn wir sind unter den tausend Fällen viel besser funktioniert als prognostiziert und so langsam kommt jetzt das Denken.
Es war nicht ganz interessant das Drosten gestern im Podcast mal meinte Ja wenn wir einen Ausbruch von Kona in einer Schule haben müsste gar nicht mehr die ganze Schule in Quarantäne sondern es reicht das Cluster zu isolieren.
Für eine Woche hab ich mir gedacht Na ja. Dazu müssten Schulen wirklich erst mal offen sein.
Wenn man jetzt schon Gedanken an Macht. Ich bin ja auch persönlich so ein bisschen natürlich mit zwei Schulkindern und den Kindergartenkind betroffen.
Aber es wundert mich ja trotzdem dass wir da keine gute Aufarbeitung jetzt auch rückblickend sei es beispielsweise eine gemeinsame Wir haben es wirklich mal geschafft.
Merkel hat gesagt Wir schaffen das und dann haben wir es aber wirklich geschafft. Also wenn Sie wirklich etwas geschafft.
Und ich bin mal gespannt wie über das Oktoberfest dann gesprochen wird wenn der Termin da ist aber kein Oktoberfest stattfindet und dann aber tatsächlich über Wochen keinen Knaller Corona weil in Bayern oder so auftrat da gabs gestern zwei oder so ganz Bayern.
Mittlerweile sind es wirklich erstaunliche erstaunliche Zahlen und.
Es ist nun mal so dass wir hier ein politisches Thema haben bei dem man sich fragen muss wenn ich Verschwörungstheorien blöd finde was wir alle finden weil schon alleine inhaltliche Zeitverschwendung ist,
lehnen wir dann alle Sprecher ab die nicht unserer Meinung unsere Meinung teilen sondern,
einfach machen wir es uns eigentlich alle immer so eine Verschwörung Ecke zu drängen.
Da hab ich jetzt mal einen O-Ton rausgesucht von wie vorhin schon bei Trossen Wem vertraut man eigentlich.
Die Person steht jetzt voll im Mittelpunkt wer spricht und das ist zum einen ein amerikanischer republikanischer Senator.
Also jemanden aus Trumps Partei den wir nicht mögen.
Ist zum zweiten jemand der selbst Trump auf der Bühne zurechtgewiesen hatte Ding Dong Mister Präsidentschaftskandidat.
Wir finden Singleplayer Holzkern nicht gut.
Du bist hier in der falschen Partei der Trump damals noch zuviel demokratisches Denken unterstellt hat,
der allerdings selber erster covert Patient im amerikanischen Senat war und sowieso so ein bisschen eigenbrötlerisch ist nämlich Rand Paul den der eine oder andere kennen und Fauteuil war bei einer Anhörung.
Und da hat nun Rand Paul aus der anderen politischen Lager aus dem anderen politischen Lager und gleichzeitig erfahren weil selbst covert 19 Absolvent.
Sich mal ganz geruhsam hingesetzt und gesagt Ich weiß es ist eine Anhörung und Herr VTG ist eigentlich der Typ den wir vertrauen sollten.
Er ist ein Wissenschaftler er kennt sich aus. Er macht seit 40 50 Jahren das Zeug.
Trotzdem nutze ich meine Redezeit nicht um eine Frage zu formulieren und eine Antwort Mir abzuholen sondern ich mache jetzt mein Statement.
Zweieinhalb Minuten die ihm zugestanden ist und ich fand dieses Statement ganz interessant weil man vielleicht doch langsam Anknüpfungspunkte finden muss auch an die politische Gegenseite.
Falls dort mal etwas Vernünftiges aufkommt denn das Wichtigste bei einer Verschwörungstheorie ist die andere Seite dann vielleicht nochmal ernst zu nehmen.
In Punkten wo es erfolgsversprechend ist und für alle auch ein kleiner Gewinn drinsteckt.
Und da fand ich diesen Redebeitrag von Rand Paul im Senat am 12. 5. 2020 ganz interessant.
Nederlands.
Also klare politische Haltung und so. Aber dass man ausgeklammert.
Klare Ansage Wenn wir hier so viel mit wissenschaftlichen Vorhersagen arbeiten dann müssen wir die selber evaluieren an die wir uns gehalten haben die aus denen echte politische Entscheidungen folgten.
Kann man da nicht drüber hinweggehen und sagen Guckt man uns mal später an oder so,
kann man natürlich machen aber dann kann man nicht gleichzeitig auf die andere Straßenseite blicken und sagen Aber eure Verschwörungstheorie die arbeiten wir mal inhaltlich so richtig durch sondern dieses Kriterium muss dann auch für die eigene Theorie keine Verschwörung.
Es bleibt dann nur noch die Theorie die eigene Theorie die man hatte die muss genau so revidiert bleiben.
Und klar die Geschichte kann man da nicht neu schreiben aber dann muss man zumindest das Zugeständnis machen und ehrlich damit sein.
Dann weckt man auch wieder Interesse auf der anderen Seite der Straße wo sich die Leute inhaltlich und kognitiv eingebunkert haben weil dann gibts wieder Anknüpfungspunkte.
Mich wundert das ja unglaublich bei Twitter Ich bin ja in diesen wie urologischen Diskussionen nicht so drin aber wie dort irgendwelche Feuilletonisten die höchstens wissen dass wenn man Husten hat den Saft nehmen muss,
sich plötzlich in einer Vehemenz positionieren können dass sie sagen dass,
dann wenn Kekulé Drosten widerspricht der eigentlich auch schon ein Verschwörungstheoretiker ist oder Streeck auch da schon ein Verschwörungstheoretiker ist für dies und das Es,
mag sein dass diese drei Herren da alle in gewissen Dingen irren und mag sein dass einem der eine sympathischer ist weil er immer Fahrrad fährt durch Berlin oder so.
Aber das ist für mich absolut unglaublich wie sich da Leute positionieren.
Und das beurteilen können und wir haben das ja da konnte es am ehesten noch nachvollziehen weil ich mich ein bisschen dann doch interessiert hat,
bei der Masken Debatte erlebt das ist ja gerade die Waren die am lautesten bei Twitter sich über alle lustig gemacht haben die an Masken gedacht haben und diese gekauft haben am Ende wieder die Ersten waren die die.
Leute fotografierten die ohne Maske unterwegs waren.
Also da muss man schon sehr ehrlich bleiben dass man da sich entweder man kann dann sagen Gut ich hab mit der Zeit gelernt aber man kann nicht so tun als hätte man es immer schon gewusst.
Dann kann man sagen Man hat immer sein Fähnchen nach dem Wind gehangen und dann war man immer gerade in dem drin was der Zeitgeist verlangte aber eben war es so dass man eine Zeit lang z.B.
Nicht an die Wirkmächtigkeit von Masken geglaubt hat oder man hat nicht das so So ernst genommen.
Oder man hat auch muss man auch dazusagen ja aus politischen Gründen auch erst mal etwas damit abgewartet bis überhaupt genügend dann zur Verfügung gestanden haben.
Es gab ja dann auch schon aus Regierungskreisen und auch aus Leuten die jetzt ein bisschen da intern mit zu tun haben durchaus die Ansage Ja so in zwei drei Wochen etwa wird die Masken Pflicht eingeführt und so kam es ja dann auch.
Und das finde ich schon erstaunlich mit welcher überheblichkeit jetzt da Sympathien vergeben werden.
Das kann man ja machen. Sympathien vergeben aber dass man wirklich da auch gleich mit diesem Schlagwort Verschwörungstheorie kommt finde ich auch unglaublich Problematisch deshalb weil wir es zum einen mit.
Internet Leuten zu tun haben.
Bei Youtube oder was die tatsächlich so ein Unsinn erzählen von da sind Kinder in Minen versteckt und Trump und Putin noch hättendie oder sowas.
Das ist eine Verschwörungstheorie das man aber jetzt schon,
an eine Kritik an empirischen Studien mit anderen empirischen Studien formuliert oder sagt Ja,
es gibt aber noch die und die Faktoren mit zu bedenken plus diese ganzen Folgekosten oder Kollateralschäden die ein lock down und so weiter hat.
Wenn man das dann auch als Verschwörungstheorie deklariert dann braucht man eigentlich nicht mehr zu diskutieren.
Genau das sind die klassischen Totschlagargument die vor allem viele so ein bisschen in Angst hüllen sich auf Twitter dann wirklich zu äußern meinen Namen fallen zu lassen Kekulé Streeck oder so.
Das war eine Zeitlang ganz schön schwierig weil man schon wusste Okay da kommen jetzt ganz viele die das versuchen wieder einzufangen und was Jean Paul II.
Also nicht nur vorhersagen wenn die eigene Vorhersagen nochmal überprüfen vor allem wenn sie nicht eintreffen wie beispielsweise das im April noch gemeint.
Masken sind untauglich im Alltag braucht man nur im Krankenhaus stellte sich dann doch heraus es war anders herum und dann wurden viele aufs Glatteis geführt.
Ich habe auch zum Beispiel am Anfang immer ein Podcast im Parkas vom Supersportler Kind gesprochen und dann hat sich diese Studienlage sehr verändert.
Bis man jetzt feststellt von Kindern geht wahrscheinlich überhaupt gar keine Gefahr aus.
Da gab es dann auch die Vorwürfe wieso ich denn ich habe doch auch von Super-Star gesprochen.
Was ist das für eine Idiotie jetzt plötzlich meinen die Schulen kann man durchaus mal aufmachen.
Aber ich würde sagen es gehört eben auch dazu und Pauls zweite Sache wenn politische Forderungen im Raum stehen während gleichzeitig Vorhersagen nachweislich revidiert werden müssten.
Eine Evaluierung anders ausfällt als der tatsächliche Verlauf dann muss man einer politischen Forderung auch mal entsprechen.
Dann muss man auch mal Zugeständnisse machen da kann man nicht immer in dieser Logik bleiben. Ich will keine Verantwortung übernehmen.
Ich mich an der krassesten Virologen Meinung weil dann kann mir keiner später vorwerfen ich hätte dabei noch dieses und jenes Argument übersehen das ist ja auch das Problem. Da beißt sich die Schlange in den Schwanz.
Es gibt jetzt keine guten Studien zu Kindern. Kein Wunder Sie waren die ganze Zeit im Kinderzimmer fand natürlich keine Infektion statt. Zwingen kann man nichts über Kinder sagen.
Deswegen bleiben die Schulen geschlossen weil niemand in die Verantwortung gehen will da dieses Feld jetzt mal zu öffnen.
Sie haben es mittlerweile in Sachsen und so weit aber in Hessen ist es eben weiter ein rigoroses schließen erster zweiter dritter Klassen 5 6 7 9 und den relevanten Abschlussklassen.
Das finde ich schon erstaunlich vor allem wenn dann das ist nämlich auch ein wichtiger Punkt hinzu kommt die ganze Diskussion dreht sich ja darum dass wir im Grunde so eine Gemeinwohl Schutz Maßnahme durchhalten wollen.
Die Frage ist ja immer noch was ist eigentlich mehr wertig dass Menschen es einfach einsehen oder wie der Gouverneur von New York sagt Maske tragen ist cool.
Oder dass wir einfach sagen Es ist Pflicht der Maske cool ist oder nicht ist egal. Wenn sie nicht aufpasst kostet 50 Dollar natürlich.
Es gibt da sozusagen zwei Lehren und das fand ich sehr bezeichnend wie Fouché hier in diesem Gespräch mit Journalisten nochmal darauf hinwies.
Es passt eben sehr. Es ist sehr wichtig jetzt für die Verschwörungstheorie die Leute immer zu versuchen mit zur normativen Argumentation Platz zu machen.
Also einfach Kekulé gesagt du spinnst ja wohl nichts Weiteres zuzulassen.
Sollte man nicht doch versuchen mehr auf so eine inhaltliche verständnisvolle empathische sondern empathischen Zugang zu Menschen zu suchen.
Diskurs wirklich voranzutreiben denn der VTG sagt Rein normativ und vor allem der Virus Bekämpfung rein normativ schaffen wir es nie.
Das kann man sehr gut umdeuten was er hier sagt denn er bezieht jetzt ganz konkret auf die massgeblichen.
Wenn sie wollen wenn sie wollen dass alle eine Maske tragen. Wieso machen Sie es nicht per Gesetz.
Was soll denn Gesetz drin drinstehen dass wir sie töten wenn sie keine Maske haben dass es 1000 Dollar kostet. Wer soll denn dieses Gesetz durchsetzen.
Das ist natürlich die relevante Frage wenn wir Gesetze haben das einfach alle Menschen immer betrifft.
Wir haben keine 80 Millionen Polizisten Wir haben nur 250 000 in Deutschland das ist nicht besonders viel.
Der Staat kommt sehr schnell an seine Ressourcen. Wenn eine Maßnahme für alle Menschen gleichzeitig beschließt dann wird es einfach knapp.
Und ich finde da muss man auch in Deutschland das werden wir im Salon machen. Nächste Woche.
Es gibt diese Idee von Helmholtz dem Helmholtz-Zentrum das sich da sehr um diese epidemiologische Ausbreitung von Infektionskrankheiten kümmern.
Jetzt gerade das Institut ist das sich darum kümmert.
Und die hatten ja lange vorgeschlagen und das auch in Tagesthema ausdrücklich gesagt Wir brauchen einen richtig harten lock down sodass wir ganz niedrige Zahlen haben weil dann können wir wieder ein bisschen freier öffnen.
Also Freiheit wenn wir diesen Hammer und Danske machen wo man nicht genau weiß was ist.
Und die haben ja eine ganz ganz große Revision drin gehabt indem sie nämlich davon abgewichen zu sagen Der Zielwert ist Null also das war ja wirklich eine Ansage dass,
das Virus wirklich ausmerzen austrocknen und haben eine Revision hingelegt hinsichtlich dass sie mit dem Ifo-Institut,
meinten ja eine Anpassung ein idealer erwehrt liegt bei 0,7 500.
Sehr weit weg von Null. Ein Eingeständnis im Grunde genau Sie haben sozusagen die Realität gesehen der letzten zwei Monate in der wir wie wir eben schon gezeigt haben sehr viel besser dran waren als alle prognostizierten.
Das was wir gerade haben.
Und haben dann gesagt Das ist ja schon krass.
Dann sollten wir diesen Weg weitergehen weil der ist nämlich nicht nur normativ wünschenswert sondern er ist auch realistisch weil das haben nämlich sehr viele jetzt übersehen.
Klar kann man einfach den Leuten sagen Wir müssten ja alle nur zwei Wochen nach Hause zu Hause bleiben und zack wäre das Problem gelöst.
Nur Wir sehen in Amerika Wer von so einer Maßnahme besonders betroffen ist.
Und das sind die ganzen unterbezahlten Dienstleistungsberufe die dann einfach ins Bodenlose fallen während jeder Büroangestellte natürlich auch von zu Hause telefonieren kann zwei Wochen in denen es gar kein Problem ist einfach eine sehr,
große soziale Balance in einer überlegung die Reihen Virologe argumentiert.
Das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem und warum wir in diesen Text dann nochmal reinschauen sollten hat ausgerechnet Drosten wunderbar formuliert.
Ich halte das für extrem wichtig dass es eine auf Deutsch geschriebene Studie die wir hier im Podcast auch in die Referenzen einstellen werden.
Ich halte es für extrem wichtig dass Leute die das aufbringen können die die Zeit haben das zu lesen sich das mal zu Gemüte führen.
Das ist von der qualitativen Aussage her ein sehr wichtiger Beitrag der Wissenschaft.
Leider habe ich rausgeschnitten worum es da ging. Er bezieht diesen Spruch ja komplett auf diesen Helmholtz Ifo Text den wir dann noch mal reinschauen.
Zum Abschluss von Verschwörungstheorien Ich will grundsätzlich ein ganz neues Denken anbieten zum Thema Verschwörungstheorien.
Wir sind ja der neue Zwanziger Podcast und ich habe Gesehenem aufwachen Podcast war Albrecht von Lucke zu Gast der ja in den neuen Blättern auch etwas über die Verschwörungstheoretiker geschrieben hat.
Besonders dieses Wiederstand 2020 diese merkwürdige Partei die sich da gerade gründet mit diesen Massen auflaufen in Stuttgart.
Und er hat im Gespräch mit dir und Paul Gäbler ja auch Hermann Hesse erwähnt und hat ganz kurz nur so am Rande mal auf die Zwanzigerjahre hingewiesen,
und wir sollten als neuer Zwanziger Podcast doch auf die alten Zwanziger mal ganz kurz eingehen,
nämlich Wir haben es tatsächlich hier mit einer Beziehung zu tun die man wirklich einmal vergleichen kann nicht in dem Sinne Wir erleben jetzt genau diese 20er Jahre noch einmal aber es gab ja nach dem,
zweiten nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg,
ein großes wirtschaftliches Problem es gab eben auch diese nationale Kränkung und all das was dort war.
Es gab die Angst vor einer Inflation die dort auch berechtigt war das zeigte sich ja dann auch sehr bald und es gab mit dieser Inflation auch,
Inflations Heilige so nannte man die allerdings erst im Nachhinein und dieser Begriff ist doppelt zu verstehen also Inflation einmal die wirtschaftliche Inflation und dann gab es inflationär viele solcher Heiliger,
Wanderprediger die durch Deutschland marschierten.
Die esoterisch waren die anthroposophisch zum Teil waren die sich als Verkünder eines großen Heils einer neuen Volksgemeinschaft was auch immer sahen.
Zu nennen wäre da Luise Heuser oder Leonard stark. Und die haben auch Marktplätze gefüllt.
Die haben zum Teil in Kirchen predigen dürfen und haben sich dann eben auch als die überbringer von tieferen Wahrheiten gesehen.
Und hier sehen wir auch diese ganz besondere Komponente die jetzt für viel Spott bei Twitter gesorgt hatte aber ich glaube auch weil viele Leute das nicht einordnen konnten was sie da sehen.
Es gab ja da Leute auf Yoga decken Leute die merkwürdige.
Ausdrucks Tänze hingelegt haben und zugleich aber eben gegen Merkel Diktatur oder weiß ich da angeblich auf die Straße sind und die dann eben diesen anderen Verschwörungen Ideologen dann auch nachlaufen.
Aber wie kam diese besondere Beziehung zur Esoterik. Die liegt da in den Zwanzigerjahren schon begründet bzw. die kann noch weiter zurückgeführt werden.
Wir haben ja nach der Aufklärung im 18. Jahrhundert in Deutschland eine sehr starke Gegenströmung in England auch ein bisschen auch in Frankreich aber in Deutschland sehr stark nämlich die Romantik.
Man kann das an einem berühmten Lied sehr gut festmachen nämlich der Mond ist aufgegangen und da gibt es ja diesen diese Passage seht ihr den Mond dort stehen.
Er ist nur halb zu sehen und ist doch rund und schön.
So sind wohl manche Sachen die wir getrost belassen weil unsere Augen sie nicht sehen.
Das ist eine Strophe die setzt sich damit auseinander dass man nicht alles empirisch erforschen kann. Ich sehe den Mond nur halb.
Das heißt aber nicht dass nicht doch noch was da ist also dass der Mond eigentlich ganz ist und die Romantik die kommt dann und sagt Wir wollen wieder das Ganze.
Wir wollen zur tieferen Wahrheit und die es jenseits von wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis jenseits von Zahlen und all diesen Dingen die ist könnte man sagen über das Faktische hinaus irgendwo zu finden.
Die blaue Blume wird dann das Symbol und das findet man draußen in den Wäldern bis heute ist ja bei den Deutschen immer dieses mit der Funktion Miyake oder mit dem Juwi.
Hinausfahren ins Land die blaue Blume suchen das ist immer noch sehr stark da das zeigt sich dann selbst in unseren Produkten die wir.
Genau und diese da raus aus diesem ganzheitlichen Denken entsteht auch eine Spaltung nämlich Wir haben auf der einen Seite die Zivilisation.
Das ist etwas was man gern als nicht deutsch dann unter Romantikern und dann auch unter Esoterikern im 20. Jahrhundert darstellte.
Das ist das was man technischen Fortschritt nennt. Aufklärung positivistische Wissenschaft und auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Kultur das ist das tiefe das deutsche das Wahre und so weiter.
Und das ist dann etwas was immer wieder gegeneinander ausgespielt wird oft dann zum Beispiel in den,
Jahren antisemitisch gewendet also Zivilisation das sind die Juden weil die nicht weil sie keine Wurzeln haben aber wir das deutsche Volk wir sind verwurzelt Wir haben noch Kultur und das finden wir jetzt gerade wieder.
Man sagt ja alles merkwürdige Wissenschaft die da betrieben wird und das ist aber auch gleichzeitig internationalistische.
Diese Verschwörungstheorien sagen Ja wir werden von Bill Gates gelenkt oder von sonst irgendwelchen Thinktanks internationalen.
Das ist Zivilisation. Aber wir hier in Stuttgart auf dem Marktplatz.
Wir vertreten die Kultur und Wir knüpfen an an diese Wanderprediger an.
Dieses Wahre und Gute und das zeichnete sich.
Und ich bitte das nicht mißzuverstehen Ein bisschen schon ab bei diesen Antti Stuttgart Protesten damals gegen diese Infrastrukturmaßnahmen der Bahn.
Das ist natürlich alles schlimmer gelaufen und das hier soll keine Verteidigung der Mappus Regierung oder so werden.
Aber es gab dort auch schon so ein paar merkwürdige Strömungen die gingen jetzt weit darüber hinaus ob das jetzt ein sinnvolles Infrastrukturprojekt ist sondern das ging schon sehr mit Ja wir wollen die Ganzheitlichkeit der Natur erleben und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ist nicht untypisch nicht untypisch deutsch dass wir jetzt gerade diese esoterischen Strömungen dass wir dieses Wanderprediger Dasein,
wiederfinden und dann auch nochmal in besonderem Maße im viralen Zeitalter,
wo ja jetzt dann auch eben diese Figuren die da als Verschwörer auftreten.
Ich will diese ganzen Namen jetzt gar nicht nennen. Durchaus etwas Guru.
Zum Teil haben auch so eine besondere Art des Sprechens oder dass sie anfangen zu weinen wenn sie über die Kinder in den Minen reden oder so.
Das ist etwas was bei diesen Inflations Heiligen schon so war und das ist eine ganz große Gefahr.
Und ich will nur auf eine auf ein Buch hinweisen der Historiker als Linse der hat über die Inflations Heiligen als erstes gesprochen geschrieben das war in den 80er Jahren.
Das ist sehr lesenswert und es gibt ein großes Feature dazu im Deutschlandradio Deutschland Radio Kultur.
Im Dezember gab es das 2009/10 über Inflations Heilige.
Wenn man das Google findet man das sofort. Und da werden eine Stunde lang drei solcher Inflations Heiliger Heilige porträtiert.
Und das sollte man sich einmal anhören um die Parallelen ganz ganz deutlich zu sehen. Zu unseren neuen 20ern.
Ja sehr gut. Dann würde ich die Klammer einmal schließen. Die alten 20er die neuen 20er. Ich hab mir extra einen Ausdruck gemacht um es unbedingt noch unterzubringen.
Aus der Zeitung Leviathan Berliner Zeitschrift für Sozialwissenschaften ihr 2080 nähert sich besonders aktuell aber Jenny bricht ziehen Sebastian Schindler Titeln warum es ein Problem ist immer hinter die Dinge blicken zu wollen.
Damals hat man die Heiligen gehabt heute hat man die Wissenschaft kann uns dabei sogar helfen.
Ich lese mal den Anfang aus der Zusammenfassung dieses Textes der ist irgendwie schon 30 Seiten lang ordentlicher Text.
Ausgangspunkt unserer Argumentation ist die Feststellung dass die systematische Untersuchung zwischen Verschwörungstheorien und sozialwissenschaftlichen Theorien eher Unterscheidungen also die,
systematische Unterscheidung zwischen Verschwörungstheorien und sozialwissenschaftlichen Theorien erstaunlich schwierig ist.
Beide gehen von der Annahme aus dass sich die Welt durch Kräfte und Mechanismen erklären lässt die hinter der Oberfläche sichtbar sichtbare Erscheinungen wirken. Die Dark Side Of The Moon.
Wie tief diese Erkenntnis Figur des dahinter in viele Theorie Architekturen eingelassen ist und damit zugleich wie wirkmächtig sie ist rekonstruieren wir anhand der Gegenüberstellung von ein paar Theorien die sie ja gegenüberstellen.
Aber das ist natürlich ein besonderes Problem und wir haben ja in der Systemtheorie Luhmann der nicht ohne Grund seinen Abschluss Vorlesungen nach 35 Jahren Systemtheorie hielt und meinte Der Titel war dann was ist der Fall. Und was steckt dahinter.
Die Antwort war diesmal überhaupt nicht verschwurbelt im Vergleich zur ganzen restlichen Arbeit einfach nichts.
Da kann man natürlich jetzt ewig darüber rätseln eine große Einladung.
Ob es reicht die Vorlesung alleine zu lesen weiß ich nicht aber es ist sozusagen dieser heimliche Humor den er hier noch einmal die ganze Theorie Arbeit eingebracht hat und deswegen mein Denk Angebot.
Wenn wir es mit Verschwörungstheoretikern zu tun haben die wir mit unserer Verschwörungstheorie Theory Ticker Heftigkeit als solche entlarven,
kann man sich darüber lustig machen weil ihr Wissen einfach in dieser Story ist nichts dran und es werden auch nicht irgendwo Millionen von Kindern das Blut ausgesaugt um an frisches Geld zu kommen oder so was ist alles Blödsinn. Wissen wir alles.
Die Frage ist allerdings sollten wir so darüber diskutieren so besserwisserisch einfach zu sagen Es ist alles blöd.
Wir wissen ja nicht mal ob dies wirklich glauben oder nicht einfach einem Happening anhängen ganz egal welche Party da gerade gefeiert wird.
Hauptsache mal wieder eine Party und da gabs bei einem Podcaster ja nun völlig unverdächtig ist.
Das ist die Seite die uns erklärt also statistisch hochrechnet wer gewinnt beim Basketball wird nächster Präsident und so weiter.
Nate Silver und so gab es ein Gespräch mit,
Kinski der selber Ich habe irgendeine Professur es spielt alles gar keine Rolle denn diesmal ist nicht wichtig wer spricht sondern die Idee ist einfach wichtig und er schlägt hier mal einen neuen Begriff vor.
Verschwörungstheorie Verschwörung wie auch immer die Ideologie erschlägt einen ganz neuen Begriff eröffnet unglaublich viel.
Fischer warnt,
Kerns,
Infektion so Make up.
Gab es.
Fan Fiction,
Wir kennen den Umgang mit Fan Fiction Wir wissen was das ist. Wir wissen worauf sie sich bezieht. Menschen reden gern über irgendwelche Sachen.
Leider gehört dann allerdings Rowling auf nach dem siebten Buch soll man jetzt nicht mehr Harry Potter nachdenken. Wir können es auch selber was ausdenken und warum sollten wir dieses Denken nicht festhalten. Also schreibt irgendwer eine fan fiction Geschichte an dann reden alle darüber.
Also Fan Fiction. Das finde ich Fan Fiction für Nachrichten. Das finde ich.
Ja wenden wenn es nicht so gefährlich wäre dann wäre das sehr putzig aber man muss auch sehen,
und ich verweise hier nochmal auf einen Text der nicht in den 20ern 1930 erschienen ist nämlich Mario und der Zauberer von Thomas Mann.
Und da geht es eben darum wie so ein solcher Zauberer der hypnotisieren Kräfte auf das Publikum hat es dann schafft alle in den Bann zu ziehen und es ist nicht schwer das dann,
mit dem Faschismus zu lesen dem aufsteigenden dann was Thomas Mann uns damit sagen wollte dass eben diese große Farbe steht wenn es auf so einer merkwürdigen Ebene bleibt.
Ja es gibt wohl Außerirdische und die waren auch schon mal in Texas.
Ja solche Theorien gab es ja auch immer wieder und die haben ja auch dann irgendwelche Sendungen immer mal wieder forciert und dann waren dann entsprechende Leute da zu Gast.
Dann hat das was Putziges aber man muss halt dann doch aufpassen wie sehr sich das verselbstständigt und das ist ja gerade jetzt nochmal.
Viel stärker als in den 20er Jahren durch die sozialen Medien gekommen dass jetzt auch Leute auf Dinge Aufmerksamkeit werden,
die aufmerksam werden die vorher vollkommen unpolitisch waren die sich gar nicht damit auseinandergesetzt haben die vielleicht die Nachrichten ein bisschen stumpf kommenden konsumieren aber eigentlich nur weil es den Wetterbericht dort gibt und nun aber plötzlich,
merkwürdigen Leuten vertrauen die hinten in Putin Poster hängen haben oder so.
Und dann irgendwas erzählen das ist schon ein erstaunlicher Effekt der da eingetreten ist und momentan versuchen ja die sozialen Medien ein bisschen gegenzusteuern aber nicht zu viel.
Mike Elgin hat es gestern getwittert Facebook selbst ist sich ziemlich sicher jedenfalls haben sie es öffentlich so kommuniziert dass 64 Prozent der Mitglieder von irgendwelchen Verschwörungstheorie Gruppen,
diese Gruppe vorher in den eigenen Empfehlungen hatte die Facebook gemacht hat.
Das ist wie bei YouTube wieder so ein selbst erhaltende System was sich da einfach ernährt und nährt,
mit sowas auf der anderen Seite Altrichter Lucke meinte ja auch da geht eine riesige Gefahr es könnte durchaus sein dass der deutsche Staat daran kaputt an diesen Leuten kapitulieren muss weil es dann doch mal überhand nimmt.
So Blick Amerika Wer glaubt eigentlich alles ist alles nur noch fake news. Und wenn das zu viele sind Großbritannien gefährlich.
Auf der anderen Seite steckt in diesem Fan Fiction Bild vielleicht eine Idee dafür wie man damit umgeht wenn jemand konkret aus der Familie am eigenen Küchentisch plötzlich so anfängt den man nur alle halbe Jahre mal sieht irgendwo einen Onkel oder so..
Typischer Fall ob man mit dem nicht einfach so darüber sprechen kann das es ist eine Fiktion was haben es nicht.
Kann man ja die Theorie Saubermacher er fortentwickeln die Story einfach der Fiktion gegenüberstellen ob die nicht noch viel glaubhafter ist und so aktiv,
sozusagen nicht in die Richtung Aufklärung sondern wenn dann schon richtig machen.
Die echte Bill Gates Story wohl wissend allerdings wurde gerade hier erfunden so plausibel ist aber die wurde erfunden.
Irgendwelche Strategien müssen gefunden werden die ein bisschen davon abkommen haben wir jetzt ausführlich kritisiert dass man da immer so despektierlich rüber schaut und meint Ich glaube an die Wissenschaft und du dass man da so ein bisschen Intelligenz reinbringt.
Aber du hast Facebook schon angesprochen. Und damit kommen wir zu einem Thema das auch die ganze Zeit stattgefunden hat wenn auch nicht so breite Aufmerksamkeit gefunden hat.
Aber Facebook ist keineswegs die Weltmacht am Abgrund wie der Buchtitel noch heißt.
Aber das Buch ist sehr lesenswert von Lévy Ich bin dabei und lese das mit großer Begeisterung weil man einen schönen überblick darüber bekommt wie Mark Zuckerberg das Unternehmen vor allem in den vergangenen Jahren aufgestellt hat wie er sehr schnell erkannt hat Oh,
da ist zum Beispiel Instagram.
Da muss ich sehen dass ich das kaufe koste es was es wolle.
WhatsApp genau so gelaufen die Geschichte dass man,
immer versucht weiter zu wachsen dadurch dass man eben aufkauft und dass man zunächst einmal so tut als könnten die Gründer dieser Unternehmen dann frei weiterarbeiten und dann aber,
nutzt man irgendwann doch die Gelegenheit und sagt so Danke das war's und jetzt machen wir es genauso wie ich es wollte und was heißt das bei Mark Zuckerberg Werbung Werbung Werbung.
Denn das war ja für die Gründer jetzt bei Instagram und so.
Anfangs sehr wichtig dass das eben nicht so diese Werbeplattform wird dass Werbung so dominant ist auch bei WhatsApp und all das.
Und tatsächlich ging es aber am Ende dann doch immer darum erst das Produkt so weit zur Reife zu bringen dass es überall verbreitet ist das es wirklich unschlagbar ist und dann kann man es öffnen für alle möglichen Formen der Werbung.
Und Facebook expandiert das kann man wirklich sagen in einem unglaublichen Maße also.
Die Aktien stehen ohnehin nicht schlecht aber wenn man sieht was da jetzt alles gerade passiert ist dann wird einem fast schwindlig Libra.
Das hatten wir ja schon mal im vergangenen Jahr breit diskutiert. Die wollen eine eigene Währung.
Dann sind MasterCard und so weiter abgesprungen davon und dann hat man gesagt Gut Libra ist tot.
Nein man muss sagen das kann man auch bei Lewy noch nachlesen am Ende des Buches.
Es ist ganz wichtig für Zuckerberg darüber nachzudenken ob nicht mit einer digitalen Währung noch eine ganz neue Machtfülle entstehen kann.
Und er hat da schon lange Leute engagiert die sich nur um diese Fragen kümmern und es war vollkommen klar dass jetzt nicht nach so einem Dämpfer Facebook zurückzieht und sagt dann vergessen wir das jetzt mit Libra,
die Bra ist jetzt wieder im Kommen.
Man hat eine Reform von Libra jetzt vorgestellt will das jetzt einführen und wir hören jetzt von Deutschlandradio Nowa eine kurze Einschätzung von einem Experten zu Libra,
nur damit wir einen kleinen überblick haben über das was da ist.
Was hat sich denn da geändert bei der neuen Version Meridiane was das Libra Konsortium zu dem Facebook und auch rund zwei Dutzend weiterer Konzerne gehören jetzt offiziell bei den Behörden beantragt hat.
Das ist eine stark abgespeckte Variante der Digitalwährung.
Die unabhängige Weltwährung von der viele Beobachter gesprochen haben die wird es demnach so nicht geben.
Denn Facebook wird keine eigenen Digitalwährung ausgeben sondern man wird nur noch verschiedene digitale Versionen der bisherigen Zahlungsmittel wie zum Beispiel US-Dollar oder Euro anbieten.
Ja man könnte sagen länderspezifische Libra. Ach das ist ja schon ganz anders als sie sich das eigentlich überlegt haben. Was heißt das für das Projekt.
Platt gesagt könnte man sagen dass Facebook auf dem Boden der Realität angekommen ist.
Nun müssen sich die Zentralbanken nicht mehr davor fürchten dass hier eine digitale Weltwährung entsteht die von staatlicher Seite nicht mehr zu kontrollieren ist.
Die Fed oder die EZB hier deutlich an Macht verlieren also der Anspruch von Libor der ist im Grunde geblieben kann man sagen man will ein weltumspannendes Zahlungssystem aufbauen Man soll also mit Libra irgendwann einmal im Supermarkt einkaufen können Libra digital von A nach B,
verschicken können oder auch Einkäufe,
am besten dann über die Facebook Plattform tätigen können.
Es hört sich für uns vielleicht nicht besonders spektakulär auf den ersten Blick an ist es aber zum Beispiel für wenig entwickelte Länder in Entwicklungsländern da haben viele Menschen derzeit überhaupt keinen Zugang zu solchen digitalen Zahlungsmöglichkeiten,
wie zum Beispiel online überweisungen mit Libra könnte sich das ändern und das wäre dann in der Tat eine kleine Revolution.
Daran ändert auch die abgespeckte Variante erst einmal nichts.
Hört sich jetzt erst nicht ganz so schlimm an wie im vergangenen Jahr. Aber die Frage ist ob das so bleibt.
Also erst einmal gab es ja jetzt ganz viele Einschränkungen oder ganz viele Bedenken und Mark Zuckerberg möchte jetzt selbstverständlich nicht dass dieses Projekt jetzt nur angegriffen wird.
Also geht er ein bisschen zurück lässt den Staaten eine gewisse Souveränität dadurch dass er also Diese Coins die da sind in Dollar und Euro hinterlegt sind.
Ja das ist eine ganz eigene Währung sondern das ist eine die sich immer bezieht auf die staatliche Währung dann jeweils Euro oder Dollar oder so.
Aber es ist damit ja zugleich eine gewisse Infrastruktur geschaffen die Facebook dann ausweiten kann.
Es ist nicht so dass man sagen kann Jetzt ist damit alles gut Es kann nicht mehr weitergehen.
Diese Idee beaufschlagt sagen Wir machen eine neue globale Währung einfach den Internet Dollar.
Amazon hat ja auch mal versucht seinen Amazon Keun zu machen mit dem man dann in China einkaufen geht und das alles irgendwie abgewickelt wird.
Und dieses Zugeständnis zu machen Wir behalten die Währung wie sie tatsächlich existieren bei uns duplizieren Sie nur digital.
Da finde ich da haben wir schon und zwar unter dem Radar irgendwie Paypal.
Ja genau das machen die genau diesen super rasanten Zahlungsverkehr ermöglichen.
Man kann Leuten das Geld schicken kostet dann in dem Fall auch nichts wenn irgendwie unter Freunden hin und hergeschickt oder so.
Die haben so einen Zahlungs Versicherungsdauer das es so treuhänderisch solange das Paket in der Post ist oder so dass man wenn man seine Güter bestellt irgendwie abgesichert ist.
Und die machen ja ganz rigoros auch dieses Du hast gerade Schweizerfranken bekommen und das sind dann eben auch Schweizerfranken in deinem Konto.
Die entsprechen eigentlich genau so zumindest oberflächliche Spezifikationen von Facebook Libra und da frage ich mich warum man es eigentlich noch braucht,
ob eine App noch eine Aufgabe erfüllt werden kann die PayPal nicht schon erfüllt oder ob Mark Zuckerberg sich da wieder einen Konkurrenten verknüpft den er mit einer gewissen Marktmacht einfach sagt.
Paypal kann man bei Facebook nicht einfach benutzen aber lieber kann man halt einfach integrieren.
Die Buttons sind dann schnell platziert und plötzlich kann man alles Mögliche abwickeln darüber ab ob das wieder so ein übername Ding ist wie wir es ja schon häufiger gesehen haben.
Ich glaube schon würde dazu jetzt gleichkommen würde nur gerade noch einfügen wo du das angesprochen hast.
Paypal ist ja schon etwas was auch wiederum kein europäisches System ist.
Also von Peter Thiel das Ding und es gibt ja Forderungen Wir haben heute schon einmal gehört von Fabio De Masi.
Der sagt ja Wir brauchen in der EU unbedingt eine Digitalwährung.
Wir brauchen einen digitalen Euro und zwar sagte er in einem Interview.
Immer mehr bezahl Vorgänge werden digital durchgeführt Bargeld tritt damit etwas in den Hintergrund.
Die digitalen privat Währungen wie Bitcoin sind aber nicht besichert und die Geldschöpfung von Banken bringt birgt ebenfalls Risiken.
Deswegen wird eine von der Zentralbank ausgegebene Digitalwährung diskutiert die wie Bargeld von der Zentralbank abgesichert ist.
Dazu müsste ein eigener technologischer Standard geschaffen werden um etwa internationale Zahlungen schneller abzuwickeln.
Dies würde auch vermeiden dass große Technologiekonzerne sämtliche Zahlungs Informationen der Bürger abgreifen und der führt dann eben die Vorteile einer solchen Digitalwährung aus.
Auch könnte ja damit die EU mal zeigen Wir sind fortschrittlich nicht so Peter Altmaier mäßig.
Im Jahr 2019 macht zu sagen Ach so ein Klout System wäre doch eigentlich ganz gut wo alle großen Konzerne inzwischen ihr Geld mit Cloud Services verdienen.
Und wenn man aber dann eben dieses Interview von Masi gelesen hat dann kommt man schnell wieder auf den Boden der,
wirtschaftspolitischen Tatsachen zurück wenn man dann Jens Weidmann in einem Interview liest der ist Präsident der Deutschen Bundesbank und der wurde im Handelsblatt Anfang Januar schon gefragt ob das nicht gut wäre wenn die EZB,
an einer Digitalwährung arbeiten würde.
Und dann sagt er Ich halte nichts davon immer gleich nach dem Staat zu rufen.
In einer Marktwirtschaft ist es zunächst an den Unternehmen für Kundenwünsche ein entsprechendes Angebot zu entwickeln.
Wettbewerb macht den Marktteilnehmern Beine.
Dann wird da noch nochmal darauf angesprochen Na ja mit Facebook haben wir ja selbst nicht mit irgendeiner Bank zu tun die mal ein bisschen was probiert sondern da haben wir es ja mit einem ganz starken Unternehmen zu tun.
Wie ist denn das mit dem Monopol was sehr schnell entstehen könnte durch Libra.
Und dann sagt er einfach in einer Marktwirtschaft sollten zunächst konsequent Regulierung und das Wettbewerbsrecht angewendet werden um fairen Wettbewerb zu ermöglichen.
Und da muss man sagen Na ja es gibt ja schon eine Verzerrung wenn Facebook das Ganze macht und selbst der,
Unionspolitiker Thomas Heilmann der ist Blockchain Experte,
der warnt ja genau vor dieser Monopolisierung des digitalen Geldes auch weil durch Libra dann einfach so viel Technik Standart eingeführt wird und dann sagt man irgendwann Na ja dann ist das halt so.
Das ist dann auch so quasi wie Naja Microsoft ist jetzt unser unsere Computer DNA quasi.
Und so kann das da dann gleichermaßen kommen dass man da noch so tut als hätte man da so ein Wettbewerb mit verschiedenen Marktteilnehmern und möge der Bessere gewinnen das ist ja vollkommen aus der Welt wie es wirklich ist.
Bei dem Waidmann. Also ich verstehe zum einen dass er so einen gewissen das kann der Markt ja mal machen. Kundenwünsche dafür ist der Markt zuständig.
Wenn wir jetzt überlegen die digitale Währung also einen digitalen Euro muss die Masi dafür erst die EZB oder irgendwen beauftragen oder können wir nicht einfach sagen Wir sind ja schon ziemlich digital,
Wir haben das Geld in unseren Konten die rufen wir auf dem Handy ab und mit den Handys haben NFC Chips kann man auch.
Bezahlen im Supermarkt und da ist nie Bargeld nie eine Rolle und man kann sich es auch hin und her überweisen und zwar ist alles schon ziemlich digital.
Nur wenn man dann sagt Da muss halt eine also ein Marktteilnehmer mal ein gutes Angebot machen.
Da frage ich mich ein bisschen was stellt er sich denn vor dass die Deutsche Bank jetzt ein besonderes Angebot macht wie man das machen kann weil hier geht es doch darum dass der ganze Markt sich digitalisiert.
Also die Banken sich zusammenschließen und dann kommt das Kartellamt und so weiter.
Aber eigentlich müssten ja die Banken alle zusammen Standart entwickeln.
Der in der Nutzbarkeit so praktikabel ist beispielsweise bei überweise jetzt und das Geld ist in drei Minuten später dann da der dann PayPal und Libra wie sie alle heißen in den Schatten stellt oder mindestens auf Augenhöhe ist.
Jetzt blockiert sich wieder alles gegenseitig. Eine Bank kann es einzeln nicht alle Banken zusammen dürfen nicht aber am Ende nutzen dann doch wieder alle PayPal und keiner fragt sich arbeiten 70000 Leute wusste ich nicht dass ich dachte das ist so eine Klitsche irgendwo,
da hat man wieder so eine Mark dieübernahme und ja alle nutzen Paypal.
Warum auch nicht oder demnächst an Libra wenn das einfach integriert ist so wie man zum Beispiel Apple jetzt sagt ihr dürft nicht nur für Apple Pay euer NFC Chip nutzen sondern das müsst ihr öffnen auch für andere Marktteilnehmer.
Die Commerzbank müsste diese physische Zahlungs Schnittstelle also das physische Gerät nutzen dürfen.
Also müsste man dann halt mit Facebook auch umgehen. Man darf da nicht mit Libra bezahlen wenn man nicht mit ebenso nur einem Klick beispielsweise auch mit dem normalen Euro den man auf einem Commerzbank Konto oder so hat bezahlen darf.
Das weiß man dann nicht die Politik auffordert da Waffengleichheit herzustellen sondern wieder die Marktteilnehmer irgendwo sieht und da ist man schon wieder in welche Richtung das läuft da geht dann wieder Usability ist alles dann hat Facebook jetzt schon gewonnen.
Und die können es ja auch schon mal im Ausland erproben. Was heißt im Ausland wo anders als in der EU zum Beispiel in Indien was vielleicht nicht alle mitbekommen haben.
Es gibt einen sehr reichen Inder das ist momentan der reichste Mann Asiens. Der ist jetzt noch reicher als der Alibaba Gründer Jack Ma das ist ein Bukett am Barney.
Und der hat auch ein digitalen Unternehmen Gio.
Und dort ist jetzt Facebook eingestiegen also war schon da ein bisschen drin ist aber jetzt der größte Minderheit Anteilseigner und wir hören uns jetzt mal an was Mikesch am Barney dazu sagt.
Was.
Facebook in London.
Ist Mark Zuckerberg auf Facebook. Ein.
Mädchen aus Indien nimmt Beinpaare,
Connectivity Plattform ein Facebooks in Indien will Offe innovativ,
auf.
Bio-Markt,
Plattform ein WhatsApp will Embacher,
Small Indien Shops sein.
In der Nematoden.
Ja also die Iraner Shops spricht er da anders sind also indische Läden.
Ganz wichtig für Indien für die Nahrungsmittel für die Nahrungsmittel Markt.
Sie haben ganz viele ganz kleine Läden und da wird man jetzt eben schauen wie kann man das auch jetzt digital nutzen.
Dieser Wert dieser Läden Es geht jetzt nicht darum dass man sagt Na ja was hat Mark Zuckerberg davon wenn da jetzt ein paar Buden irgendwie digital auch auftreten können.
Dieser Wert wird geschätzt dieser Läden also der der Umsatz im Jahr wird veranschlagt bei drei hundert fünf und siebzig Milliarden Dollar.
Das ist kein unerheblicher Markt und sonst gibts ja auch noch ein paar Geschäfte in Indien und dort eben versucht jetzt Gio zusammen mit Facebook solche,
Möglichkeiten zu etablieren wie über die Plattform und über WhatsApp das Ganze gemacht werden kann und man kann sich ja dann auch denken wie sinnvoll es dann wäre wenn man da die Digitalwährung schon weit vorangebracht hat.
Wenn dort dann gleich mit Libra gezahlt werden kann. Also dort wird schon einiges erprobt was dann hier blühen könnte.
Mark Zuckerberg auch wirklich. Da wurde ja mal aus Indien rausgeschmissen dann hat die Regierung auch gesagt Wenn du hier Facebook Ork alle kriegen kostenloses Internet solange sie nur Facebook in diesem Internet benutzen,
dann kommt das einer Invasion gleich und dagegen haben wir uns immer gewehrt beispielsweise auch gegen die Briten.
So wurde das ja eigentlich beobachtet. Jetzt hat er gesagt Okay dann rede ich nicht mit der Regierung darüber soll ich nehme mir einfach die wichtigsten Unternehmen dort und mache mit denen so eine Kooperation dann ist wahrscheinlich sein Traum dass er einfach weggeht.
Dieses chinesische Konstrukt danach baut inklusive.
Ich gehe los und bezahle damit auch mein Essen mein Mittagessen.
Ja wir hören uns mal an was er dazu sagt zu dem Investment.
Avedon.
Facebook ist ja,
schon was mit.
Facebook.
Bei,
Organisation.
Und.
Teaching.
Business.
SMS.
Business,
to
Business.
Business,
murmelnd.
Ja und das ist beängstigend. Es gab im Mai einen Tweet von dänn Seifert dass es ein Redakteur von D wird von dem Tech-Blog.
Unglaublich.
Und der hat ja.
Nach Tech-Blog weil das immer so als Tech-Blog Nachrichtenseiten die,
doppelte dreifache vierfache fünffache Reichweiten von FAZ Spiegel Online und so zusammen weil die einfach in diesem englischen Markt komplett alles bedienen aber die gelten immer noch so als Tech-Blog.
Blogger.
Und er hat auch etwas getwittert und zwar Instagram ist für Millennials heute das was für frühere Generationen der Teleshopping Sender QVC war.
Das hat eine besondere Aktualität oder Brisanz dieser Tweet deshalb weil Facebook und Instagram sich jetzt gerade ganz neu aufstellen sie werden nämlich tatsächlich Plattformen für Online-Shops.
Das heißt wir haben ja sonst bei Facebook Twitter erlebt dass dort Werbung gemacht wird.
Dann klicke ich irgendwo drauf dann kann ich auch zu einem Shop vielleicht noch gehen und kauf mir dann beispielsweise bei Hugo Boss den Anzug.
Aber jetzt haben wir eben gerade auch nicht nur in Indien sondern auch durch Corona hier,
diese ganz schnelle Entwicklung dahin dass man sagt Ja wir können doch selbst Shops integrieren auf unseren Plattformen können so auch kleinen Händlern anbieten dass sie sofort das hier bereitstellen können.
Und Instagram hat zum Beispiel schon zusammen mit der Zeitschrift InStyle in Deutschland ein erstes Small Business Festival,
im vergangenen Monat veranstaltet und da hat man dann eben schon mal gezeigt was man kann und wir hören uns da auch ganz kurz aus einem Interview mit.
Ich glaube CBS war das an was Mark Zuckerberg dazu sagt zu den Small Business.
Small Business.
Shops.
Facebooks Mark Zuckerberg.
Small Business,
to Business.
Facebook,
Business,
Insider.
Facebook.
Ich meine das Unternehmen weiß das alles das ist ja das Entscheidende ob das meine Freunde wissen dass wir eigentlich nicht das relevante sondern eine überwachungs Plattform funktioniert damit dass sie die Informationen sammelt.
Sie gehen damit jetzt wirklich in Konkurrenz zu Amazon weil Amazon Sagen wir so Amazon hat immer gesagt wir sind Amazon bei uns kann man das kaufen.
Wir sind der Laden und die Infrastruktur selbst hat man dahinter versteckt und irgendwann fuhren die Leute über die Autobahnen haben dann plötzlich riesige Lagerhallen gesehen Da ist Amazon okay.
Ich dachte es ist nur eine Seite und dann kann man sehr viele Unternehmen so in den Innenstädten halt ihre Douglas und sogar fürs Parfüm so ein kleiner Shop oder so.
Die hatten ja dann irgendwann zugeschlagen. Sie waren ja unter Zugzwang und die haben das Angebot bekommen von anderen Unternehmen die Amazon nachgebaut haben.
Die haben genauso große Lager gebaut und dann konnte man sich als Douglas und als ich Sport Scheck oder so einfach einmieten und an der die Dienstleistung übergeben und man hat man wurde selber sozusagen nur noch am Verkauf beteiligt das heißt wenn man dann.
Einfach im Onlineshop von einem Laden was bestellt hat war das dann genauso schnell wie von Amazon.
Am nächsten Tag geliefert weil das eben mit Bündelung aller kleinen Läden zusammen stand dann wieder so ein Großer ist und so eine große Lagerhalle da und die Post wusste genau da muss ich hin und dann wird da ordentlich Logistik gemacht und,
Amazon und Facebook scheint das jetzt zu sehen weil bisher vermittelt ja Facebook also Facebook schaltet diese Werbung und dann geht man eben zu diesen großen versteckten Unternehmen und kauft irgendwas bei Wer sich noch irgendwelche Namen nennen aber er kennt sie alle da und so weiter.
Kauft man da ein und da hat sich Facebook tatsächlich anscheinend gedacht das können wir auch direkt bei uns binden.
Wir sind dieses Unternehmen das diese bis hin zu Lagerhalle betreibt.
Und da diese direkt Konkurrenz macht.
Diese Unternehmen waren lange so im Schatten Man hat ja nicht gewusst wie das so funktioniert wo sich diese Kleinunternehmen einkaufen um den großen Versandhandel zu machen bis dann mal in Amerika eine Person während der Arbeit in einem Lagerhaus starb,
und dort einfach 12 Stunden liegengelassen wurde dann so ein Strich gezogen und dann hieß es geht mal außen rum und so oder die New York Times der Daily sondern sehr rührenden aufrüttelnden.
Podcast zugemacht wie das so ist für die Mitarbeiter wenn dann der Zeitdruck ist da Same Day Delivery also Amazon gibt das Tempo vor und die Konkurrenz muss natürlich mithalten.
Was bei Douglas bestellt soll das auch abends noch da sein und da gehört es dann eben dazu dass man um seine toten Kollegen Wagenrennen muss die ganze Schicht lang bis dann irgendwann mal die Polizei kommt und sich um sowas kümmert.
Also ganz ganz gruselige Arbeitsbedingungen abseits des Sichtbaren.
Das findet einfach hinter verschlossenen Türen statt.
Und Facebook wird so zum Krisengewinner. Auf eine ganz andere Weise nochmal.
Wir haben bei Amazon schon viel drüber gesprochen dass die sich als große Versorger aufgespielt haben.
Und jetzt lassen wir erst einmal die Bücher und DVDs liegen und kümmern uns um die Nahrungsmittel die die Menschen dringend brauchen.
Amazon das habe ich aber auch in dem Buch von Levi gelernt das du ja im Salon empfohlen hattest.
Ist ja auch ein Unternehmen das wirklich ganz genau schaut gibt es irgendwo aufstrebende Firmen die uns gefährlich werden könnten. Und da gibt es eine.
Die haben vielleicht auch noch gar nicht so viele gehört aber das ist inzwischen das teuerste Unternehmen Kanadas und zwar spielfrei Shopping.
Ist ein Unternehmen das Software anbietet für Online-Shops.
Das richtet Unternehmen Online-Shops an stellt also die Infrastruktur dafür her.
Die Aktie lag bei Jahresbeginn zu Jahresbeginn noch bei 300 Euro.
Die liegt inzwischen bei über 700 Euro.
Der Gründer und CEO von Zopfi heißt Tobias Lüdtke. Der kommt aus Koblenz.
Ich kenne hier übrigens den Vater ist mir aber jetzt erst aufgefallen ich darüber gelesen habe und die Arbeiten jetzt zum Beispiel auch mit Pinterest zusammen.
Bei Pinterest auch. Wichtig ist für diese kleinen Shops die da entstehen können.
Auch gibt es da einen unglaublichen Boom in den letzten Monaten und Shopping ist damit auch eine ganz ganz große Konkurrenz für Facebook bzw. versucht jetzt glaub ich Facebook da drauf zu springen.
Man müsste mal wissen ob es damals irgendwelche Gespräche gab zwischen Zuckerberg und Lüdtke ob man da was übernehmen kann oder nicht.
Jetzt wo es das teuerste Unternehmen Kanada ist ist es Kanadas. Es ist wahrscheinlich zu spät für eine solche übernahme.
Aber das ist hochinteressant. Dass das jetzt gerade geschieht und wir dürfen nicht vergessen Pinterest ist wohl auch eine wichtige Plattform für diese Shopping Sachen und auch für Otto Otto ist ja so eines der,
Versand riesen einer der Versand riesen der nicht untergegangen ist.
Wir haben ja da einige deren dicke Kataloge wir nicht mehr bekommen und den otto katalog bekommen wir auch nicht mehr aber Otto hat sich digital ja wahnsinnig gut aufstellen können und auch diesen zum Beispiel an Pinterest interessiert.
Auch die schauen jetzt gerade was macht da Amazon.
Müssen wir da mit denen kooperieren wie müssen wir uns da aufstellen. Und das wird also ein ganz großes neues Ding für Facebook werden und das kann nochmal das Unternehmen in ungeahnte Höhen katapultieren.
Es gibt aber noch ein anderes Thema bei Facebook. Was wir ansprechen müssen nämlich das Thema Fake News das ist ja jetzt etwas,
was gerade durch diese ganzen Verschwörungen bemühten nochmal wichtig geworden ist und bei CBS hat Mark Zuckerberg,
darauf angesprochen etwas gesagt wie sie mich mit Fake News umgehen und er verweist dann auch auf ein Beispiel auf das Beispiel Wolfson Haro.
Nein.
Mag.
Ja jetzt denkt man Aha man ist jetzt doch sehr verantwortungsvoll und das ist ja ganz großartig wir erinnern uns aber,
es gab ja in diesem Monat einen Vorfall bei Twitter und zwar hat ja Trump getwittert dass Wer Briefwahl macht vollkommen blöde ist.
Oder er hat das nicht nur getwittert sondern hat es anderen gesagt hat er es denn diese Briefwahl sei ja ganz klar dass die dann manipuliert werde und dass man nicht davon ausgehen konnte dass die Stimme dann noch aus ankommender und so weiter und so fort.
Und diesen Tweet den hat Twitter ja markiert als Achtung da stimmt was nicht so ganz da sollte man lieber nochmal das ganze Gegend checken.
Und darauf wurde Mark Zuckerberg dann einige Tage nach diesem CBS Interview angesprochen und zwar bei Fox News und vielleicht ist es ein bisschen so dass man da ein bisschen anders spricht als bei CBS.
Und da wird er gefragt was er denn von dieser Twitter Sache hält ob das auch ein Modell für Facebook wäre.
Haben wir eine lockere Zunge. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Je
mehr sie in.
Facebook B..
B..
Das verstehe ich nicht. Da gleichzeitig jetzt gerade seinen komischen hohen Verfassungsgerichtshof den er da irgendwie installiert hat der sich ja auch mit so Richtlinien wie geht man damit um und so weiter. Und der ist ihn auch überstimmen kann aber hier wollte wahrscheinlich ein klares Statement machen.
Trump muss vor mir keine Angst haben aber er soll mal wieder aus dem Weg räumen oder was.
Ja liebe liebe FoxNews Zuschauer Ich bin ganz bei euch.
Und das ist so unglaublich und ich habe auch ein Gespräch.
Das hat sie. A.
Das ist ein Think Tank geführt mit Mark Zuckerberg also ein Dialog zwischen Zuckerberg und Thierry Breton dem EU-Kommissar.
Und da ginge ja auch das habe ich jetzt nicht rausgeschnitten nochmal extra auch ganz ganz deutlich nochmal um,
wie wichtig jetzt Facebook das doch geworden sei dass sich alles anzusehen was es denn richtig und wie unabhängig man dort jetzt Leute beschäftigt hat die dafür sorgen Zuckerberg ist da in,
zig Interviews aufgetauchten denen er das sagte aber jetzt wenns gegen Twitter geht und wenn es vor allem für Trump geht dann ändert sich diese Haltung doch.
Deswegen sollte man da sehr sehr vorsichtig sein welche Lippenbekenntnisse da so kommen und dass man sich da mit Boyz zu Nacho anlegt ist auch ein bisschen einfacher als mit Trump und da sind wir jetzt bei diesem Gespräch mit Thierry Breton nämlich.
Er hört sich das alles geduldig an. Breton ist ja auch nicht ganz ohne Wenn man mal bei,
so Lobby Watch und all diesen ganzen Seiten nachgucken Bretons ja selber CEO eines großen französischen digital Unternehmens gewesen und naja jetzt ist er eben da EU-Kommissar.
Wir wissen aber dass er nur Plan B war. Macron hatte ja eigentlich da seine ehemalige Finanzministerin die ist ja dann über 10000 Dollar gestolpert.
Deswegen hat man dann so ein bisschen kaltschnäuzig in Frankreich auch einfach so einen relativ prominenten auch schon mal Minister aber dann doch Wirtschaftslenker. Auf diese Stelle gesetzt.
Ja der hat da schon sehr viel hinter sich was er aber vielleicht auch dafür sorgen kann in einem solchen,
Gespräch dass er in ganz anderer Weise nochmal mit Mark Zuckerberg redet er hört sich das da alles an und das wird immer wieder gesagt es ist schön wenn wir da zusammenarbeiten.
Wenn wir jetzt daran denken wie wir auch,
diese fake news Geschichten lösen können und all das hörte sich da auch schön an aber er macht dann nochmal sehr deutlich Mark Zuckerberg was hier eigentlich los ist und welche Verantwortung er selbst hat. Mark Zuckerberg.
Sich.
Stämmig.
Eine.
Plattform.
Body.
To help you.
You Tube,
an seinen.
Ja das ist ein guter Hinweis den sollte man nie aus den Augen verlieren. Es ist bei Facebook-Gründer Mark Zuckerberg für alles verantwortlich und schön zu hören dass auch in der neuen EU-Kommission so eine gewisse Grundstimmung herrscht Wir werden hier keine Freunde mehr mit ihr.
Mark Zuckerberg das hat er sich ja selber als eingelegt.
Bei dieser Anhörung war und Guy Verhofstadt ihn auch fragte Wie wollen Sie eigentlich mal in die Geschichte eingehen als.
Das ist sehr schön in den ersten 30 Minuten dieses Gesprächs ist das alles noch so ein freundliches Abnicken von gegenseitigem,
Verständnis und auch einem kooperativen willen aber er macht dann doch hier nochmal quasi so als.
Übervater oder als alter Unternehmer dem jungen Unternehmer noch einmal klar mag du du bist es der entscheidet und du musst die Verantwortung übernehmen und niemand anders.
Das ist sehr schön nochmal dazunehmen und Zuckerberg guckt ein bisschen irritiert mich irritiert ja am meisten immer seine Frisur.
Aber er macht dann am Ende Zuckerberg nochmal etwas auf das wir glaub ich auch im Blick behalten sollten denn wir haben jetzt gerade etwas was wir Ich weiß gar nicht wie man das nennen soll.
Also wir haben eine merkwürdige Nähe jetzt auch von Digital Konzernen mit Staaten und nicht nur durch Corona.
Sondern dass man ein bisschen denkt Gut wir brauchen jetzt wenn die Politik es auch alleine nicht mehr schafft mächtige wirtschaftliche Partner an unserer Seite Bretz.
Der Cielo von Microsoft hat ein Buch veröffentlicht Tools an weapons.
Dort schlägt er schon so etwas vor dass doch die digital Konzerne und,
Amerika und der Westen so Hand in Hand arbeiten sollten gegen das was da von der anderen Seite kommen kann und so eine ähnliche Idee die formuliert dann jetzt auch zum Schluss dieses Gesprächs Mark Zuckerberg und die sollten wir uns noch anhören.
In
Marokko.
Marokko,
Rucksack.
Auf.
Marokko.
Ernte der,
Saudis.
Aussiehst.
Brutal zu hören denn es ist verlogen wenn wenn er jetzt.
Wir wissen ja Facebook hat ja Hand in Hand mit der EU gearbeitet um die Datenschutzgrundverordnung zu bekommen.
Genau,
das ist. Es war eine große Niederlage für ihn dass es in Europa so kam und jetzt biegt er das hin.
Naja mir ist im Grunde egal wie wir es machen die Hauptsache der Status quo bleibt.
Von mir aus können wir auch Hand in Hand gehen. Dafür ist er jetzt groß genug,
um sozusagen diese Regulierung mit den Politikern zusammen zu machen mit der Politik um dann auch immer sicherzustellen dass von unten niemand nachwächst und ihm Konkurrenz machen kann und gleichzeitig,
im Widerstand zu Chinesen das als Modell noch an die Welt zu verkaufen.
Er blickt da wahrscheinlich auf Afrika und möchte dann die afrikanischen Länder vor die Wahl stellen Entweder er nimmt das chinesische Modell wo er dem Staat also dem chinesischen Staat ausliefert oder wir hätten hier dieses schöne,
privat öffentliche Konglomerat,
Facebook gestützt von den europäischen und amerikanischen von der Politik.
Könnte auch das installieren. Aber kommt nicht auf die Idee den dritten Weg zu gehen und eigene digitale Lösungen zu finden.
Das ist schlimm. Mark Zuckerberg wird immer gefährlicher was so angeht.
Wir müssen denn auf jeden Fall im Auge behalten. Das wird nicht so schnell verschwinden.
Wenn man Lewis Buch ernst nimmt was ich jetzt tue steht uns ja auch noch diese ganze Virtual Reality Geschichte bevor.
Daran arbeitet Mark Zuckerberg ja auch unaufhörlich seit vielen vielen Jahren.
Dass er da unsere Begegnung mit dem virtuellen noch einmal ganz verändern will beziehungsweise uns das virtuelle wirklich ganz in die Realität holen will.
Und das könnte dann nochmal eine ganz neue Stufe sein.
Und dann würde man doch wieder mal fragen müssen Ist da noch was dahinter Hier kann man auf jeden Fall jetzt gerade sagen Das sind alles öffentliche Dinge die wir ja hier gerade vorgespielt haben.
Wir waren jetzt nicht irgendwo auf geheimen Seiten oder so.
Wir waren aber jetzt dafür z.B. bei YouTube und wenn man dann manche Interviews mit Zuckerberg aufruft dann sieht man die haben wesentlich weniger Klicks als meine Filme Analyse Videos.
Und das ist vielleicht auch nochmal etwas was man den Verschwörungstheoretikern doch sagen sollte guck doch einfach mal in so ein Wirtschaftsteil oder guckt mal wieviel einfach da offenbar ist ihr sucht immer nach irgendwas dahinter.
Wichtig wäre vielleicht erst einmal zu sehen was könnte man dann wissen wenn man da nur mal drauf klicken.
Was ist der Fall ist aufzuklären was ist der Fall und wir können da die Klammer schließen zu Beginn da hatten wir ja die Idee.
Christopher Nolan zeigt seine Filme.
Der Traum von Mark Zuckerberg wäre natürlich gewesen dass er zu Corona schon seine Brille für 150 Dollar fertig hat die einfach den Eskapismus Fortner auf dem Sofa zu Hause anstatt rauszugehen. Da kann man jetzt auch noch Kino.
Und dann geht man da halt wirklich ins Kino und bezahlt die Eintrittskarte die virtuelle Eintrittskarte noch mit Libra und kriegt dann da den Christopher Nolan Film zu sehen.
In dieser Szenerie sieht er sie sieht irgendwie die Welt in zehn Jahren,
und das ist einfach gruselig. Ich finde es sogar die technische Vision irgendwie gruselig,
über diese Brille weil das ist ja nun wirklich Absonderungen der einzelnen Person und die komplette übernahme durch technische,
künstliche Welten.
Aber was mich noch mehr ärgert ist das was ja grundsätzlich ein Problem ist dass das alles von Facebook kommt. Das ist richtig.
Ich habe gestern wieder die Zeitung gelesen die Durchsetzung die durch mit Whatsapp in Deutschland beträgt wohl irgendwie 96 Prozent.
Es sind wirklich alle erreichbar außer sie haben kein Smartphone so wie du. Aber wer ein Smartphone hat ist wohl zu 96 Prozent über WhatsApp erreichbar.
Das ist natürlich auch wenn ich mich jetzt immer noch frage wie er das monetarisieren will im Sinne von Werbung. Da scheint ihm noch keine gute Idee gekommen zu sein.
Mit den Shops denke ich das hatte er jetzt wirklich in allen Interviews betont.
Small Business das ist das Wichtigste jetzt den Menschen helfen.
Und du siehst ja erst einmal gibt es von der EU,
keine Möglichkeiten dass man sagt Okay wir haben hier auch eine digitale Infrastruktur könnt ihr die nutzen bitte schön,
sondern es ist wieder so dass es wie bei der Ausstattung der Schulklassen mit allem Möglichen Equipment aus dem Silicon Valley jetzt auch da,
für alle möglichen kleinen Geschäfte Wichtig ist dass irgend jemand das anbietet und dann kommt halt Mark Zuckerberg oder dann kommt dann Shopping aus Kanada.
Das sollte man auch vielleicht ein bisschen im Blick behalten das wäre natürlich witzig wenn jetzt aus Kanada ein Deutscher kommt und Mark Zuckerberg ein bisschen zu bedrohlich wird.
Wir hatten das auch in Jena. In Jena steht ja der Uni Turm so das hohe Gebäude rund und verglast oben groß Intershop dran und Intershop ist so eine kleine Software Bude die vor 20 Jahren angefangen hat Onlineshops zu machen.
Die waren damit auch recht präsent. Aber ich weiß nicht genau was daraus jetzt geworden ist ob sie irgendwann gekauft hat oder sonst irgendwas.
Aber das ist genau so was ja. Im Grunde hatten wir so etwas immer schon mal irgendwo.
Aber wer den Erfolg abbekommt spielt dann doch wieder wird dann doch wieder anders entschieden als einfach nur an einer guten Idee aufgehangen.
Na ja da haben wir den Mai soweit uns die Sachen aufgefallen sind ausführlich besprochen.
Ich gucke mir im Grunde abhaken. Es gibt halt noch kleinere Clubs aber.
Es wird immer weniger Corona Man merkt das schon. Wir haben noch viel Coruna aber wir blicken jetzt schon ganz anders drauf. Also wir sind gar nicht mehr in diesem Modus.
Jetzt kann ich in diese Richtung noch Husten oder mache ich dies oder das sondern es weitet sich wieder der Blick was ja ganz gut ist.
Aber.
Und im Juni setzen wir uns wieder gegenüber.
Wir werden jetzt über Monate wenn nicht Jahre mit Kona Nachwirkungen zu tun haben.
Wenn ich schon sehe ich habe beispielsweise einen Clip von Steve Balloon dieses Pandemrix Radio was wir schon gehört haben Volkswagen wird ja ein Jahr gar keine Steuern,
ein Jahr die Leute absolut frei wirtschaften lassen und sie alles behalten lassen auch um Motivation wieder reinzubringen diskutiert. Es kommt darauf an.
Das sind übrigens gar nicht so dumme überlegungen. Ich will das mal sagen wenn ich mir anschaue was jetzt gerade mit Lufthansa passiert und mit den Automobilkonzerne,
wo da Gelder hingehen und dass man dann sogar noch nachdenkt dass man wirklich die schlimmsten Umwelt,
verpestet da auch noch mit irgendeiner Prämie versieht.
Dann muss man doch sich fragen ob man nicht tatsächlich mit irgendwas flächendeckenden,
sagen wir einem Helikoptergeld wirklich etwas bewirken würde insofern man dort wenigstens davon ausgehen kann dass alle etwas davon haben während diese,
Mercedes E-Klasse oder so sich auch die Leute kaufen würden ohnehin ob sie jetzt eine Umweltprämie bekommen oder nicht oder irgendeiner Kaufprämie bekommen oder nicht.
Und vielleicht wäre es wirklich eine ganz schöne Idee zu sagen Wir machen jetzt mal bis Dezember keine Mehrwertsteuer.
Könnte man machen das werde eine Steuer das wäre auf jeden Fall etwas was auch den Haushalten zugute kommen würde die ohnehin wenig haben die hätten nämlich dann definitiv mehr Geld wert 000 Euro Monat zum Kaufen.
Und wer das meiste davon an,
tausend Euro ausgibt der würde dann wenn wir keine Mehrwertsteuer mal hätten ein paar Monate würde der Hund zwischen 3 zwischen 1 und 3 Euro sparen.
Da stecken wir doch zwei kleine Clips aus dazu denn die Ideen die man jetzt hat so wie du sie auch hast.
Also zum Beispiel die Mehrwertsteuer auf bestimmte Sachen abschaffen und bestimmen das ist ja so eine Idee von Marcel Fratzscher z.B.
Der damit klar sagt Naja Mehrwertsteuer bezahlt man im Supermarkt und das sind halt Grundbedürfnisse die muss man sowieso einkaufen.
Also profitieren davon umso mehr diejenigen die weniger Geld haben also umso mehr das anteilsmäßig im Supermarkt ausgegeben wird das Geld umso mehr spart man oder profitiert man von so einer Mehrwertsteuersenkung.
Wie gesagt die Amerikaner die da schon und man sieht ja jetzt schon wie Trump wieder gegen China vorgeht.
Bananen Ideen die verfangen dann doch irgendwie im Weißen Haus sie kommen da irgendwie an unseren Wirtschaftsdaten.
Vielleicht habe ich das einfach auch für den Wahlkampf hat er dann Trump einfach im September sagt wenn er mich wieder wählt nächstes Jahr ein Jahr lang keine Steuern und dann müssen die Demokraten erst mal Argumente finden warum das Quatsch sein sollte.
Es wird natürlich schwierig zu argumentieren aber wir wissen ja wie in Deutschland die Diskussion läuft und haben wir ja mal zwei kleine Clips aus der Feindes Ecke.
Das eine ist Bund der Steuerzahler das ist ja dieser Fanklub von der FDP,
der sich da immer wieder engagiert und in Deutschland ist ja jetzt in der Debatte ob man wenn man so viel Geld für alles Mögliche ausgibt sich noch eine Grundrente leisten kann also das eigentlich verabschiedete Ding nämlich Menschen die 35 Jahre durchgehend gearbeitet haben oder 30 Beitragsjahre haben.
Dann einfach mal auf einem bestimmten Niveau zu heben.
Und da gibts hier vom Bund der Steuerzahler Kritik daran mit einem Gegenvorschlag aufgehangen Ancona und verlogen wie sonst nichts.
Mit den tiefroten Zahlen beginnt die Debatte über die angemessene Reaktion.
Reiner Holznagel der Präsident des Bundes der Steuerzahler fordert den Blick auf die Ausgaben zu richten und Prioritäten zu ändern.
Beispielsweise wenn wir jetzt mehr Forschungsgelder in die Erforschung eines Impfstoffes stecken was völlig richtig ist.
Da muss man auf der anderen Seite auch sagen wo wir keine Gelder mehr hingeben.
Holznagel denkt ebenso wie die deutschen Arbeitgeber unter anderem an die Grundrente.
Die Grundrente streichen wollen damit Geld für die Forschung bleibt das ist das Eins plus eins gleich zwei angeblich das ist wirklich so banal sowas zu sagen.
Ja das sind natürlich wahnsinnig.
Der zweite klebt jetzt direkt aus dem Bundestag und auch direkt von der FDP nämlich vom Fraktionsvize Christian Dior.
Der guckt hier mal so wie du die Idee hatte ist auf der Ausgabenseite eines Arbeitnehmers nämlich bei der Mehrwertsteuer im Supermarkt beispielsweise Erleichterung zu verschaffen.
Wie stehen denn so Einkommenssteuer und Gewerbesteuer im Verhältnis.
Bin ich für einen konkreten Vorschlag machen das schon gesagt auch in den Zeiten wo die Steuereinnahmen für die Kommunen gut liefen Stichwort Gewerbesteuer.
Für eine Cashcow in den letzten Jahren war die Wirtschaft gut gelaufen ist jetzt entwickelt sie sich sogar genau in die andere Richtung noch viel schneller als alle anderen Steuereinnahmen die Gewerbesteuer ist eine die sehr volatil ist sehr schwankend und Kommunen sind Institutionen die eigentlich stetige Steuereinnahmen brauchen.
Mein Vorschlag Lasst uns die Krise nutzen und von der Gewerbesteuer Abstand nehmen und den Kommunen lieber einen Hebesatz recht zu geben auf die Steuern stetiger fließen und die Einkommensteuer die Körperschaftssteuer das sind Steuern die kontinuierlicher fließen.
Deswegen rate ich dringend dazu diese Krise zu nutzen.
Wozu denn Gewerbesteuer. Die kann man doch einfach mal sein lassen.
Da geht es ja konkret ums Abschöpfen von Gewinnen genau wo sie anfallen also beispielsweise Porsche in Weissach eine Teststrecke.
Stattdessen kann man doch die Bürger einfach mehr belasten.
Da fährt man halt den neuen Motor Probe.
Ist deswegen die Gemeinde die am höchsten von der Gewerbesteuer profitiert nämlich mit 30 000 Euro pro Einwohner im Jahr.
Das summiert sich irgendwie auf 270 Millionen oder so..
Da sehe ich da kann man nichts machen. Bei so was vielleicht aber dieses grundsätzliche das man jetzt sagt Na ja bevor wir doch jetzt Unternehmensgewinne abschöpfen gehen wir doch lieber an die Einkommenssteuer ran. Und.
Sobald man jetzt eine Diskussion aufmacht hat man es mit solchen Typen zu tun und muss dann plötzlich Gegenargumente finden,
weshalb ich einfach hoffe dass wir nicht so ins Detail und Kleinklein kommen sondern dass die EU jetzt einfach europaweit diese 750 Milliarden veranschlagt sagt dafür bürgen bitte die Mitgliedsstaaten,
und abgestottert wird das über Plastik Abgabe Emissionshandel und der ganze Kram was ja europaweit schon so weit etabliert ist und nur noch nach Deutschland importiert werden muss.
Also mal gucken wie die Spielräume da sind auf der einen Seite tobt auch noch da kann man im Juni bestimmt rauf ein ganz großer Kampf.
Die Kommunen sollten ja sowieso schon entschuldet werden. Schon seit einer Weile Olaf Scholz ist es sehr wichtig dass die Kommunen die bezahlen am Ende die Gesundheitsämter die Hartz IV und so weiter die Schulen also alles was jetzt anfällt bezahlen die Kommunen.
Und sollte man nicht grundsätzlich einfach Kommunen entschulden auch mit dem Argument die sind alle unterschiedlich verschuldet also auf der Hand liegt weil da wo weniger Gewerbesteuer reinkommt in der Kommune muss auch mehr,
Sozialhilfe und so weiter ausgezahlt werden.
Das ist einfach da hat der erwirtschafte nicht eine Kommune besser als die andere.
Da hat man es einfach mit doppelseitig zu tun um so weniger Gewerbesteuer reinkommt umso mehr korreliert das auch mit da ist keine Industrie und sonst nichts.
Also brauchen die Leute da auch mehr Hilfe vom Staat.
Also summiert sich das ein bisschen auf und über die Zeit entstehen allzu große Umbrüche und Marcel Fratzscher In seinem Coruña Podcast auch schon gefragt Soll man jetzt wirklich zu irgendeinem zwölfjähriges Mädchen hingehen und sagen,
Wir können hier leider bei deiner Schule nicht dafür sorgen dass alles glatt läuft weil vor 30 Jahren deine Kommune sich mal an einem Bau von einem Spaßbad verhoben hat,
und seitdem bringt bringt das noch irgendwie weiter wenn man da jetzt sagt Nee das geht nicht weil ja nicht die Kommune unfair miteinander behandeln,
sondern Nee bei den Kommunen muss jetzt groß mit der Gießkanne einfach mal drüber gegossen und entschuldet werden damit die wieder handlungsfähig werden.
Wenn du einfach nur so einen Haushalt hast der dich in allem blockiert dann hast du auch irgendwann auf die Anträge zu schreiben das Land noch um Beteiligung zu bitten und findet halt einfach nicht mehr statt.
Naja mal gucken wie sich das so. Vielleicht haben wir Glück dann entfaltet sich das schon im Juni spätestens im Herbst so muss das Thema werden weil dann brechen die Kommunen einfach zusammen denn das ist vielleicht die Kennziffer auf die man jetzt achten sollte Gewerbesteuereinnahmen.
Da schlägt Coruna sofort durch. Das ist eine Steuer die 30 Prozent des Aufkommens in der Kommune.
Das ist so eine Steuer diese Gewerbesteuer ist die die jetzt so richtig wegbricht.
Da liegt wohl einiges zu arbeiten bereit. Na gut dann vertagen wir uns an der Stelle auf den Salon nächste Woche.
Was wir da lesen schaut dann muss am Wochenende selber nochmal die Listen zusammenstellen was ich Interessantes gefunden habe.
Ich habe ein bisschen Literatur sogar dumm auf Fragen des guten Stils gehen und so.
Wird das Wichtigste jetzt dass wir noch Haltung bewahren.
Bis dahin.
Tschüß.
Intro/Outro